Die Major League Soccer feiert Rekorde und hat nun ein Finale mit Thomas Müller von den Vancouver Whitecaps gegen Lionel Messi mit Inter Miami. Dazu die Vorbereitungen auf die Männer-WM im nächsten Jahr mit viel Pomp und Getöse. Und wir stellen uns hier im Rasenfunk die Frage, ist das der Versuch, vielleicht der letzte Versuch, Fußball in den USA zu etablieren und kann er gelingen? Wir werden darüber jetzt sprechen mit Jürgen Kalwa. Er ist freier Sportjournalist. Ihr kennt ihn hoffentlich schon aus vielen Sendungen hier im Rasenfunk. Und er wird uns seine Einschätzung nicht nur von vor Ort liefern. Jetzt gleich nach diesem Intro. Sie hören den Rasenfunk.
Er schießt! Kaiser Franz, Nummer 6 in seinem ersten Spiel.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das was ihr gerade gehört habt, das war ein sehr unwichtiges Thron, nämlich das erste Tor von Franz Beckenbauer für Cosmos New York und ein Meilenstein in der Geschichte des Fußballs in den USA, der entscheidende 11 Meter im WM-Finale 99 von Brandi Chastain, auch mit ikonischem Jubel. Wenn ihr es einmal gesehen habt, werdet ihr euch dran erinnern. Und ich glaube Jürgen hat es gleich erkannt. Jürgen, schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, herzlichen Dank für die Einladung und dafür, dass wir mal wieder ganz ausführlich über Amerika und die Verhältnisse hier reden dürfen. Ja, schön.
Es gibt gleich mehrere aktuelle Anlässe. Zum einen nehmen wir auf an dem Tag, an dem die Gruppen ausgelost werden für die Männer-WM im nächsten Jahr. Wir nehmen aber auch an dem Tag auf, am Vortag des Finals in der Major League Soccer. Und da gibt es gleich mehrfach deutsche Beteiligung, dass Thomas Müller zu den Vancouver Whitecaps gewechselt ist. Das haben alle mitbekommen. Nicht alle wissen, dass es auch den Sportdirektor Axel Schuster dort gibt, den wir von Mainz 05 und Schalke 04 noch kennen. Der ist jetzt schon seit fünf Jahren, glaube ich, in Vancouver. Du hattest die Möglichkeit, vorhin auf der PK zu sein, die es vor diesem Finale gab. Was war denn so dein Eindruck vom Drumherum um dieses viel erwartete Finale?
Also ich glaube, die machen hier sowieso einen ganz guten Job bei der Major League Soccer, wenn es um Medien, vor allen Dingen auch Social Media, soziale Medien geht. Und das war jetzt eine ganz normale Veranstaltung, eine Zoom-Pressekonferenz mit Axel Schuster, speziell für die deutschen Medien. Erstaunlich schwach das Interesse, obwohl es so wirkte, als würden da viele Leute zuschalten. Es war aber eine sehr kleine, exklusive Runde. Mein Problem mit solchen Veranstaltungen ist immer, auch mit Pressekonferenzen. Ich hätte gerne mit ihm mal alleine gesprochen und hätte auch gerne mal mehr auf den Zahn gefühlt. Nicht, weil man unbedingt immer alles unglaublich kritisch sehen möchte, aber doch ein bisschen differenzierter, ein bisschen distanzierter. Und was ich gerade rausgefunden habe, ist, dass Axel Schuster ein guter, mediener, erfahrener Promoter von amerikanischem Fußball ist. Also für ihn scheint die Welt ziemlich in Ordnung. Kann man verstehen, weil die Leistung im Moment stimmt. Er hat aber auch was gesagt, was ich fand, das war also jetzt sehr wenig dick aufgetragen oder gar nicht auf dick aufgetragen. Er hat die Leistungsstufe der MLS versucht zu charakterisieren. Und er nennt das die Leistungsstufe obere zweite deutsche oder obere zweite Bundesliga. Und das finde ich eine ziemlich redliche Einschätzung. Also trotz all dem Trara und dem Wirbel und was auch immer hier los ist und womit sich Leute auch gerne beschäftigen, wir ja heute auch. Das fand ich sehr gut, also kompetent. Das ist mein kurzer Eindruck von Axel Schuster. Und wenn es darum geht, herauszufinden, was hat er hier alles gemacht, damit das so gut wird, weil man kann das erkennen, die Leistungskurve der Mannschaft ist in seiner Zeit gestiegen. Dann liegt das nicht nur an Thomas Müller, was im Moment auffälliger ist. Diese Mannschaft hat auch ohne Thomas Müller schon sehr ordentlich gespielt. Und das geht auf eine andere Kappe. Das kann man nicht auch noch Müller in die Schuhe schieben.
Es ist tatsächlich ein Team mit sehr vielen unterschiedlichen Torschützen. Und damit unterscheidet man sich unter anderem vom Gegner mit Lionel Messi. Während ich diese Einleitung gesprochen habe, diese einleitenden Worte zum Podcast, da hatte ich so einen inneren Widerstand zu überwinden. Denn eigentlich ist ja dieses auf einzelne Personalien herunterbrechen in einem Teamsport wie Fußball, das ist ein bisschen plakativ. Noch dazu, weil jeder, der sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt hat, wie Thomas Müller bei Vancouver eingesetzt wird, man gesehen hat, also für ein ganzes Spiel reicht aktuell nicht der Fitnessstand. Das heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht allein Thomas Müller gegen Lionel Messi sein. Trotzdem ist es ja auch verständlich, dass es darüber verkauft wird, da die beiden sich ja auch 2014 im WM-Finale gegenüber standen. Glaubst du, das ist jetzt der Best-Case aus Vermarktungssicht her der Liga, dass es tatsächlich diese beiden Teams ins Finale geschafft haben?
Wenn man es mal nur unter dem Aspekt Müller sieht, Müller spricht erstaunlich gut Englisch, bringt sehr viel von seiner Personality, die wir aus Deutschland kennen. Mit ein, er ist immer noch ein bisschen verhaltener, das finde ich auch gut, weil ich glaube, er spürt instinktiv, dass er da mit manchen Witzchen oder so auch nicht richtig durchkäme, weil der Humor in Deutschland und der Humor in Amerika ist ein bisschen anders. Aber er ist unglaublich locker, er ist freigebig mit seiner Zeit, mit dem, was, worüber, welche Fragen er, er beantwortet auch Fragen. Es gibt hier in Amerika inzwischen so eine Kultur des Fragen-Ausweichen-Beantwortens und des Woanders-Hinschieben-Beantwortens. Und Müller, die Frage, die gestellt wird, die beantwortet er. Und wenn die länger ist die Antwort, dann fällt ihm immer noch am Ende ein, dass er ja vielleicht jetzt einen Teil der Frage nicht beantwortet hat. Also auch das ist eine Ausstrahlungsqualität, die man hier so nicht kennt. Und das ist zwar sicherlich nicht der wichtigste Wert an Thomas Müller, aber ich finde es von der Beobachtung her den interessantesten Wert, dass er also nicht nur, weil so wie er spielt, das ist nicht immer auffällig, wie wichtig oder wie gut er ist. Das sieht man ja kaum. Ich habe dir ja im Vorgespräch oder im Vorfeld mal meine Zuneigung zu Thomas Müller vermittelt damals, als es um das berühmte Spiel Deutschland gegen Brasilien ging. Und das wurde ja nun, wie ich finde, historisch Herrn Kroos gewidmet. Die Rolle, die Müller in dem Spiel spielt, ist unglaublich. Der ist an fast jedem Tor beteiligt und macht auch selber welche. Und findet auch Wege, so zu tun, als wollte er den Ball nicht. Oder man weiß auch nicht, ob er das also absichtlich gemacht hat. All diese Facetten, für mich war damals, habe ich ja dann auch geschrieben in diesem wunderbaren Sonderhof von Oliver Worm, Man of the Match war Müller. Und diese Fähigkeit, die der hat, die beschäftigt die Leute hier aber durchaus, weil man kann erkennen an so einem Fußballer, wenn die vordergründige Faszination nicht einfach nachvollziehbar ist, dann gibt es hier genug, inzwischen genug Substanz, wo Leute dann fragen, was macht der denn da? Oder die wollen das dann auch wissen, weil die Resultate haben ja wieder einen eigenen Wert für sich. Also insofern, wenn wir um die Konstellation best case oder so sind, also dieser Typ, Müller, der ist absolut gesund für den Fußball, der im Moment hier gespielt wird, auch wenn er jetzt schon 36 Jahre alt ist und natürlich nicht mehr genau das abliefern kann, was er 2010 in Südafrika gezeigt hat oder so. Und Messi ist so ein bisschen wie eine Zitrone, an der schon nichts mehr dran ist. Er kann immer noch auf einem Level wie diesem hier glänzen. Aber diese Fixierung auf ihn und dass eine Mannschaft quasi um ihn herum gebaut worden ist und so, das funktioniert, glaube ich, auch nur in einem Umfeld, in dem man wirklich auf diese ganzen utrierten Sachen Wert legt. Wer verkauft die meisten Trikots? Wer hat die meisten Instagram-Follower? Und all dieser ganze Schrott, der nichts mit dem Eigentlichen zu tun hat, was uns Beine ja interessiert, also was passiert da auf dem Platz. Wenn wir darüber noch schnell reden wollen, ich glaube, Vancouver hat eine gute Chance, das zu gewinnen. Wenn sie denn wirklich alles so gut machen, wie sie es auch zuletzt teilweise hinbekommen haben, das kann ich natürlich nicht prognostizieren.
Aber findest du, dass dieser Messi-Hype nicht dann doch auf einer sportlichen Grundlage auch steht? Also er hat unheimlich viele Tore erzielt in dieser Saison. In 28 Spielen 29 Tore, 16 Vorlagen. Das waren die Zahlen aus 24-25, also weit über einer Torbeteiligung pro Spiel. Er hat auch wieder viele Freistoßtore, hat auch da sämtliche Rekorde wieder geknackt. Also wir haben das ja durchaus schon häufiger gesehen und wir werden da auch heute darüber sprechen. Diese Systematik über Stars, die eventuell ihren Zenit überschritten haben könnten, sich eine Aufmerksamkeit ins Land zu holen für diese Sportart, die eben nicht die Aufmerksamkeit per se generiert. Diese Taktik haben wir schon häufiger gesehen. Ich würde aber sagen, gerade auch nachdem ich mich jetzt noch mal länger auch mit eben den Zeiten in den 70ern und so weiter befasst habe, also Lionel Messi scheint mir da sportlich schon auch noch wirklich eine Bereicherung zu sein und damit quasi auch durchaus mit Dingen auf dem Feld, den halb neben dem Feld zu rechtfertigen. Siehst du das anders?
Also ich fange da an, wo wir jetzt eine Mannschaft haben, Inter Miami, die im Finale steht und natürlich nicht, also natürlich, ich würde sagen, sie ist bei den Buchmachern wahrscheinlich favorisiert, das Spiel zu gewinnen. Und wie immer mit Finalspielen, ja, das kann auch in verschiedene Richtungen gehen, Verlängerungen, Elfmeterschießen und so weiter. Aber die Facette, die mich auch irgendwie erreicht hat, ist und ich greife zurück auf den Fall Beckham, der so das Modell ist für diese Taktik, einen berühmten Spieler, der gar nicht mal so gut ist, wie er immer gemacht wurde, der dann also mehrere Jahre braucht, bis diese Mannschaft, in der er da in den USA spielt, wirklich auch dann den Titel gewinnen kann. Das heißt also dieses Denken, dass diese Zauberer, die also bestimmte Sachen total klasse können, dass diese Zauberer des Fußballs irgendwie auch jetzt das aussprüllen und dann ist alles irgendwie wunderbar. Das ist eben genau das, was man glaube ich sagen sollte. Ja, der Blick auf diesen Sport oder diese Sportart in Amerika, die also von bestimmten Schwächen gezeichnet ist, das hilft dem, aber was nützt es denn wirklich? Wo ist der Jugendfußball in diesem Land? Also seit ein paar Jahren gibt es Messi und vielleicht haben alle möglichen Kids Messi-Trikots, aber wo sind diese Kids sportlich im Moment in ihrer Entwicklung und was wird aus denen außer vielleicht Spieler in der unteren Premier League oder in der oberen italienischen Liga oder so? Also ich will jetzt nicht gleich über die ganzen Dörfer reiten, aber...
Du hast schon viele gegen dich aufgebracht, Serie A-Liebhaber, David Beckham-Fans, Lionel Messi-Fans, mach nur so weiter, Jürgen.
Und wenn wir also jetzt diese WM sehen, lass uns das noch kurz zusammenbringen, dann siehst du eine Nationalmannschaft, die also Platz 16 spielen kann oder so. Und wenn es da für einen Trostpreis gibt, also Geld gibt es ja, dann wunderbar. Aber dieser innere amerikanische Anspruch, wir sind das Land, in dem alles möglich ist, dass Weltmeister, Olympiasieger am Fließband herstellen kann. Und das auch in anderen Sportarten, das tatsächlich hinbekommen hat. Stichwort Fechten. Die Amerikaner sind heute eine Weltmacht im Fechten. Die waren vor 20 Jahren gar nichts im Fechten. In solchen Einzelsportarten funktioniert das. Fußball ist so komplex, so kompliziert, braucht so viel Infrastruktur, damit es funktioniert. Das schaffen die hier nicht. Und okay, good luck, wenn ihr glaubt, die Major League Soccer kann jetzt, wie Axel Schuster heute gesagt hat, bald schon sowas sein wie untere Tabelle, erste Bundesliga. Ja, dann müssten aber von unten auch ein paar Spieler nachkommen. Man kann nicht alle irgendwie vom Baum holen, aus anderen Ländern und sagen, das ist jetzt unser Spielniveau. Aber du bist der Moderator, bitte organisier unser Gespräch. Ich möchte jetzt nicht so bewirken, das könnte ich über...
Ach, du weißt ja, Jürgen, du bist ja schon Rasenfunk erfahren. Wir lassen das hier dahin fließen, wo es uns hintreibt. Ich hole uns schon in die Struktur zurück. Aber ich würde dann doch gerne noch kurz bei diesem Punkt bleiben. Denn ist es denn wirklich wichtig, ob die Major League Soccer jetzt untere Hälfte erste Bundesliganiveau hat oder obere Hälfte zweites Bundesliganiveau, weil die spielen ja nie gegeneinander. Und eigentlich sprechen wir hier ja über eine Unterhaltungsindustrie, die zwar auch einen gesellschaftlichen Nutzen hat. Es ist gut für eine Gesellschaft, wenn wir Sport treiben. Und dazu hilft es auch manchmal anderen beim Sportmachen zuzusehen. Da möchte man es auch selber nachmachen. Die Argumentationslinie hast du ja gerade schon angesprochen. Aber es ist auch eine Industrie, die Geld verdient. Und durch Messi wird mehr Geld verdient denn je. Es ist die zweitbestbesuchte Saison nach der letzten Saison mit ungefähr 22.000 ZuschauerInnen pro Match. Es gibt einen zweistelligen prozentualen Anstieg bei Sponsoringeinnahmen. Allein durch Lionel Messi und den Effekt des Dynamic Pricings, das heißt, dass Ticketpreise nicht für Festpreise verkauft werden, sondern nach Angebot und Nachfrage individuell teurer werden, sollen 83 Millionen Euro zusätzlich deuler, Entschuldigung, eingenommen worden sein in dieser Saison. Das heißt, wenn wir das Ganze mal versuchen, von dem Sportlichen zu lösen, wo die Frage ist, wir sehen es dann bei der Weltmeisterschaft natürlich, wenn diese Teams dann letztlich der Länder gegeneinander konkurrieren. Aber ansonsten sehe ich ja nicht, dass der 1. FSV um 1.05 gegen Inter Miami spielt. Kann man es dann nicht auch unter dieser Brille betrachten? Und dann muss man doch eigentlich festhalten, zumindest Stand heute, Dezember 2025, ist das ein voller Erfolg und vielleicht auch zum ersten Mal einer, der so groß ist, dass er nachhaltig sein könnte.
Also ich bin vorsichtig, weil wenn wir so über verschiedene Ligen und Sportkulturen reden, dann hat das immer leicht so einen halb nationalistisch angehauchten Unterton, was ja auch in manchen Disziplinen, also wenn die Nationalmannschaften spielen oder wenn Olympische Spiele sind, wird das natürlich auch gepflegt. Also das ist für sowieso, du hast das ja auch schon angedeutet, das ist sowieso schräg, ja, dieser Dreh. Aber ich denke, für eine sich entwickelnde und hoffentlich auch positiv entwickelnde Sportkultur oder Sportartenkultur ist es wichtig, dass die Menschen, die in dem Land leben, das repräsentieren, was da identifizierbar ist. Also dass die besten Spieler möglichst aus dem Land kommen, in dem sie spielen. Oder aber, dass wenn sie dann, wie im Fall von deutschen Nationalspielern, in England spielen, der Grund der ist, dass sie so gut sind, dass sie in dem Land spielen müssen, wo mehr bezahlt wird. Und das ändert nichts an dem Ruf. Ich habe dir ja eine Liste geschickt vor unserem Gespräch, über was die New York Times, also die akut 100 besten Fußballer der Welt hat. Und da kommt man halt, wenn man das erstmal so stehen lässt, ich will auch gar nicht im Detail damit diskutieren, aber da kommen wir mit, ich glaube, wir haben 7 deutsche Fußballer unter den 100 besten eines amerikanischen Mediums. Und wir haben einen Amerikaner in dieser Liste, und der ist auch nicht ganz weit oben, der ist zwar im Mittelfeld, Pulisic, aber das mal als Ausbeute von fast 30 Jahren amerikanischen Fußballentwicklung. Nehmen wir das mal nur so als Anekdote, ja, stand heute vor einer Fußball-WM. Und das ist mein Thema eigentlich. Also vergleichen wir mal die Deutschen, und wie toll die sind, oder auch nicht. Sondern vergleichen wir mal die USA mit sich selbst, mit ihren eigenen Ansprüchen, mit ihren eigenen Fähigkeiten, mit ihren eigenen Mechanismen. Und dort, wo man zu sehr aufs Geld abfährt, und auf was macht der Investor, was will der Investor, wie will der Geld verdienen und so weiter, verlassen wir ja wirklich um fast komplett die eigentliche Dimension von diesem Ding hier, wofür wir uns interessieren, was uns fasziniert. Und ich weiß ja auch von dir, du analysierst Spiele so genau, ja, über taktische Überlegungen und so weiter. Das ist doch unser Modell, was uns mit diesen Sportern...
Aber das kannst du auch mit qualitativ schlechteren Spielen machen, ehrlich gesagt. Also kannst genauso gut dritte Liga analysieren wie erste Liga. Ist sogar ein bisschen einfacher, weil das Spiel langsamer ist, ehrlicherweise. Also ich verstehe, was du sagst und ich stimme da auch in Teilen zu. Ich finde es nur interessant, bei uns beiden ergibt das schon Sinn, dass wir quasi über die sportliche Ebene kommen und sagen, ist da wirklich eine nachhaltige Entwicklung zu sehen. Ich würde aber sagen, dass das eine Perspektive auf den Fußball ist. Den haben gar nicht alle Medien. Bei den allermeisten geht es dann doch eher eben einfach um den unterhaltenen Aspekt dabei. Deswegen werden da auch Nebengeschichten zu Hauptgeschichten über die beide, wir beide würden uns da gar nicht drüber unterhalten. Und für diese Medien, glaube ich, und die sind, würde ich sogar auch sagen, in der Mehrheit. Und jetzt nach dem, was ich jetzt recherchiert habe, ich will es nicht so tun, als ob ich mich in den USA gut auskennen würde von ein bisschen Recherche. Aber da hatte ich den Eindruck, das ist genau das, was die brauchen. Nämlich einfach nur Geschichten, die über einzelne Figuren erzählt werden können, wo man auch sehr, sehr plastisch, wo man einfach so tun kann, als wäre das jetzt wieder das WM-Finale. Und wir zwei und viele andere auch wissen, ey, das ist ganz weit weg von WM-Finale, weil die beiden sind viel, viel älter an den ganz anderen Punkten ihrer Karriere. Und guckt euch mal bitte die Mitspieler an, ohne jetzt despektierlich sein zu wollen. Aber vielleicht braucht es ja auch nicht diesen einordnenden Blick, um Spaß an diesem Finale zu haben und auch darüber berichten zu können.
Ja, aber du hast das Wort Nachhaltigkeit genannt. Also mein Gefühl für diesen amerikanischen Sport, oder diese Variante, beginnt 1982. Da bin ich hier Tourist und versuche krampfhaft irgendwo Fußballspiele zu sehen, die während der WM in Spanien stattfinden. Ich war dann in der Lage, auf einem spanischen Kanal das Frankreichsspiel, das Halbfinale, irgendwie nachzuholen. Das konnte ich auch nicht leiden sehen. Wenn auch in einem Komplettmitschnitt. Und ich habe dann das Finale gesehen gegen Brasilien. Da wurde Werbung reingeschaltet zwischendurch. Da wurde vorher die Abseits-Regel erklärt.
Die links laufende Spielewende, da wurde Werbung gescheitert.
Ja, das war selbst nachdem die North American Soccer League eigentlich schon einen ersten Weg gefunden hatte, um mit Publikum, teilweise enormen Mengen von Publikum zu sprechen. Und da würde ich erstmal für mich persönlich den Anfangspunkt setzen. Das ist, von dort aus sind wir sehr viel weiter gekommen. Aufgrund verschiedener Entwicklungsaspekte. Dazu gehört die Weltmeisterschaft 1994 als Verankerung. Dazu gehört auch, dass die Frauen sehr viel erfolgreicher sind auf der internationalen Ebene. Dazu gehört, wie das sich in dem Schulsport verankert hat, wie sich das teilweise zwischendurch im College abentwickelt hat und wo diese Liga irgendwann nach der WM 94 reinkommt, 96 und dann nach sehr vielen Hustenanfällen so langsam in den Schumm kommt. Aber geht es da weiter? Das können wir am Ende beim Resümee dann nochmal besprechen. Wir müssen das nicht erst vorziehen. Aber das wäre der Testfall, Nachhaltigkeit. Die haben ja schon einiges hingekriegt. Das ist so, wie wenn du mit Kindern umgehst und sagst, naja, also das ist ja schon alles ganz gut oder so. Wenn aber das eigentliche Interesse ist, und dann nehmen wir die Kinder wieder raus, aber das eigentliche Interesse ist, dass du sagen könntest, das müsste noch ganz anders landen. Dann frage ich mich, werde ich das noch erleben? Also in 30 Jahren bin ich bestimmt nicht mehr hier. Vielleicht sind die dann Weltmeister, weil sie den Dreh gefunden haben, aber vorher?
Okay, also lass uns da am Schluss hinkommen. Deswegen sage ich, ich kann den Hörern und Hörern ja mal kurz erklären, was wir heute machen. Was wir heute nicht machen werden, ist die WM, die Männer-WM, mit all ihren Facetten zu beleuchten. Das kommt vielleicht noch in einer eigenen Folge. Vielleicht war das auch mal unser Plan und wir haben uns von diesem Plan verabschiedet, aus verschiedenen Gründen. Was wir heute machen wollen, ist, indem wir uns gegenseitig an die Hand nehmen, mal eben zu blicken auf das große Thema Fußball in den USA. Und tatsächlich werden wir auch geschichtlich euch so versuchen, durchzuführen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie die Entwicklung eigentlich so war, von dem, was wir jetzt gerade in der Aktualität sehen, die Major League Soccer bei den Männern und wir haben die NWSL bei den Frauen, um dann eben am Schluss zu dieser Diskussion wieder zurückzukommen, Jürgen. Ich bin gespannt, wie viele Minuten uns trennen zwischen hier und dem Resümee, aber wir werden es herausfinden. Und lass uns mal einsteigen in die Geschichte. Ich werde jetzt versuchen, das wird jetzt so ein bisschen der Stil von Geschichten aus der Geschichte, ich hoffe, dass wir es ähnlich und unterhaltsam hinbekommen, das heißt, einer erzählt dem anderen eine Geschichte und der kann gerne ergänzen, denn der geschichtliche Teil, da warst auch du noch nicht involviert, wenn du 1982 anfängst mit deinen Fußballerinnerungen in den USA. Ich werde mal versuchen, dir das so ein bisschen näher zu bringen, du weißt natürlich auch schon sehr viel und spring jederzeit rein, wenn du möchtest. Es ist interessant, ich hätte nicht gedacht, ich habe allerdings auch ehrlicherweise noch nicht drüber nachgedacht, wann ging das eigentlich los mit dem Fußball in den USA? Und das ist tatsächlich schon ab Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts ein Thema. 1862 gründet sich in Boston der erste Fußballverein. Allerdings muss man da gleich einschränkend sagen, bei allen Teams in dieser Zeit ist es noch nicht klar, spielen die schon Fußball nach Regeln, die mit heute vergleichbar sind, oder geht das eher in die Rugby-Richtung? Je nach Interpretation kann man das unterschiedlich bewerten, aber meistens wird eben dieser Verein 1862 genannt aus Boston, ist damit auch älter als die Football Association, also der englische Fußballverband. Und tatsächlich schon 1884 gründet sich dann auch die American Football Association, das ist die AFA, die auch schon 1885 ein erstes inoffizielles Länderspiel noch bestreitet. Es wird noch eine ganze Reihe dauern, bis es ein offizielles Länderspiel gibt. Aber das sind dann so klassische Themen, Jürgen, das fand ich interessant. Verbandsstreitigkeiten und Konkurrenz zueinander. Plus, schon damals sehr früh Geld war ein ganz wichtiges Thema. Der damalige Verband, ich nenne ihn jetzt einfach den Fußballverband, der hat den American Cup ausgerichtet und hat auch eine Liga etabliert, die allerdings im ersten Versuch nur drei Wochen gehalten hat. Und schon damals gab es ein Thema, das über alles bestimmt hat. Und das war das Geld. Das war das Geld zum Durchführen von Spielen. Das war das Geld zum Decken von Reisekosten. Und letztlich, das fand ich wirklich interessant, auch schon sehr früh besitzergreifende Eigentümer von Vereinen. Also ich nenne es jetzt Vereine, aber eigentlich sind es eher Teams, die eben Eigentümern gehören. Das fängt schon hier Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts an. Interessanterweise haben wir Parallelen dazu zur Situation in England. Hast du dazu Gedanken, weil das ist ja was, was den deutschen Hörern und Hörern fremd ist. Wir kennen das nicht, dass eine Person ein Verein gehört und so wie beim Football zum Beispiel, beim American Football, dann auch diesem Owner, dem Besitzer oder der Besitzerin die Trophäe zuerst überreicht wird und erst dann darf der Quarterback und der Trainer dürfen das mal anfassen. Das wirkt auf uns fremd. Es ist aber tief im US-amerikanischen Fußball verankert. Hast du da Gedanken dazu, auch wie das zu erklären ist?
Ein paar Überlegungen. Also das erste ist, wir haben parallel die Entwicklung im Baseball hin zu einer Professionalisierung, Kommerzialisierung. Und da wird das auch schon ordentlich ausgelebt, so gegen Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts und dann noch stärker Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts, noch vor dieser ja sehr viel medienaffineren Zeit, die dann irgendwann mit dem Radio und dann später mit dem Fernsehen ja noch mehr ausgelebt wird. Und wir haben dann auch schon im Eishockey, wenn auch erst mal aus Kanada rüberschwappend, haben wir auch schon so eine Tendenz, die Sportarten auch kommerzieller zu betrachten. Wobei halt manche Sportarten verlangen auch ein bisschen mehr, wenn es darum geht, also einen Baseballplatz anzulegen mit entsprechenden Tribünen oder eine Eishockey-Fläche zu haben. Das sind natürlich auch wieder bestimmte Investitionen, die man bei einer simplen Rasensportart, wo man nicht so viel machen muss, kann man das auch besser hinkriegen. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, dass tatsächlich auch so Verstärkungsmechanismen in diesem Land eine Rolle spielen, also kulturell. Das Phänomen des deutschen Turnvereins wird mit deutschen Einwanderern, hauptsächlich in Pennsylvania, Pittsburgh, Philadelphia und so weiter, weil die kommen zu bestimmten Zeiten in bestimmten Ecken mehrheitlich an, wird da angelebt. Und auch solange die Deutschen, das hört rund um den ersten Weltkrieg auf, da werden die Deutschen diffamiert als Weltkriegsgegner und so weiter. Und die deutsche Sprache wird quasi unterdrückt und so. Aber da sieht man dann eine Kulturinsel, die also etwas mitbringt, wie zum Beispiel dieses Strukturenverein, das sind wir, das gehört uns. Und je nachdem, wie das dann organisiert ist, wir haben einen Vorstand, wir haben Kassenwart, wir haben alles Mögliche an Regularien, die diesen halbwegs demokratischen Charakter pflegt. In Kulturen, die woanders herkommen, ist das eben nicht so gelebt. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie nun also der mercantile Teil im amerikanischen Sport kulturell verankert ist. Es ist völlig klar, dass dieses, ja, also Deutschland war nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ein Wirtschaftswunderland. Die USA waren mit Beginn der Dampfmaschine ein Wirtschaftswunderland. Und da dreht sich irgendwie alles um Aufbauen, Ressourcen ausschlachten, Infrastruktur bauen, ja auch Einwanderer reinholen, um diese ganze Arbeit, die damals noch mit wenig Maschinen und viel Körperkraft erledigt werden musste, um das hinzukriegen. Das heißt, wenn ich mir das so ausmale, dann sehe ich die Amerikaner als ein Amalgam von einer Kultur, wo eigentlich dieses Selbstverständnis so gut wie keine Rolle gespielt hat, außer in der Politik selber, wo man also heute noch in Nordengland wirklich Basisdemokratie hat und die ist auch verankert. Das hat, irgendwie hat sich das im Sport nicht ausgelebt. Und dazu kommt noch, dass wir im Sport halt schon sehr früh die andere Verankerung haben, diese mehr selbstlosere Verankerung im Bildungswesen, nämlich in den Schulen und dann vor allen Dingen, dort fängt das eigentlich erst mal an, das kommt von den Colleges, den Universitäten, da wird das ausentwickelt und wird dann quasi runter abgegeben an die Highschools als Verankerung. Und da erlebt man eben eine andere Variante von von gemeinnützigen Konzepten. Und weil das aber da funktioniert, auch gerade mit den Mannschaftssportarten, mit den Infrastrukturproblemen, hat man natürlich dann für alles, was daneben leben will, hat man andere Nöte und zum Beispiel meines Wegen den Geldbedarf, um überhaupt anfangen zu können. Und da reicht es natürlich nicht. Man kann Fußball auch im Central Park spielen und muss nur ein paar Hütchen irgendwo hinstellen. Das ist natürlich nicht das, was die, die Fußball spielen wollen und können auch wirklich wollen. Also müssen sie sich was überlegen. Und wenn sie nicht genug Geld auf der Tasche haben, weil sie eben bestimmt zehn Stunden am Tag arbeiten und sechs Tage in der Woche, dann müssen andere Leute einspringen, die da irgendwie was bringen. Also und ich glaube, das ist dann irgendwann Selbstlauf Prinzip. Dazu kommt noch in anderen Sportarten, hat man das stärker gesehen, diese sogenannten Barnstorming Tourneen, wo also Mannschaften zusammengestellt werden im Basketball. Das prominenteste Beispiel sind die Harlem Globetrotters. Von irgendwann geht es gar nicht um Liegen, da geht es um diesen Show und Entertainment Aspekt. Und man geht auf Tournee, so wie eine Rockband auf Tournee gehen würde und zeigt seine Qualitäten. Und das hat es auch in anderen Sportarten gegeben, zum Beispiel im Football. Bevor das wirklich zu einer National Football League wird, entstehen schon diese anderen Interessen an dieser Sportart, dass man halt die, die nicht mehr im College sind, die schon 22 und älter sind, dass man die einsammelt und daraus solche Formationen bildet. Und natürlich geht es da auch wieder nur um Geld. Was bezahle ich den Leuten, damit sie mitmachen? Und was kriege ich auf der Eintrittskartenseite rein, damit ich das alles finanzieren kann? Und so gibt es so verschiedene, immer wieder aufs Mercantile hin wirkende Facetten, von denen ich mir ausmalen kann, dass sie alle für die Gemengelage verantwortlich sind.
Soziologisch ist das auch wirklich interessant, denn im europäischen Fußball, da ist es ja gut dokumentiert. Du hast es vorhin schon angedeutet. Er kommt eigentlich aus der akademischen Elite von Militärakademien. Über Militärakademien wird dann in Europa dieses Spiel weit verbreitet. Und es ist dann tatsächlich eine Entwicklung des frühen 20. Jahrhunderts, dass sich die Arbeiter schichten diesen Sport packen. Erst noch mit Missbilligungen derjenigen, die ihn ursprünglich ausgeführt haben, nämlich eben der meist militärischen Eliten. Und dann wurde es aber eben zu einem Massenphänomen. Und ich habe jetzt dazu keine Studien gefunden, die das noch mal explizit in den USA untersucht hätten. Aber es scheint mir da Parallelen zu geben, weil natürlich, das muss man sagen, diejenigen, die dieses Spiel dann auch in die USA bringen, das sind natürlich auch Immigranten, die eben aus Europa in die USA kommen. Es dauert zum Beispiel auch noch ganz lange, bis der erste Vorsitzende, der dann später des US-Verbandes tatsächlich auch jemand ist, der in den USA geboren war. Das war damals noch eine große Neuigkeit, dass das mal in Anführungszeichen endlich jemand war, der wirklich aus den USA kommt. Aber es gibt auch interessante Unterschiede. Also zum Beispiel ist einer der Unterschiede der 1884 gegründete AFA, also die American Football Association, von der ich gesprochen habe. Einer der Kritikpunkte an diesem Verband war, dass er sich zu sehr aufs Profitum fokussiert hätte. Also eine Diskussion, die der DFB noch nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg negativ beantwortet hat. Wir wollen keine Profis, wir wollen immer Amateure haben. Das war vom Beginn an anders. Vielleicht auch aufgrund der Umstände. Man könnte jetzt auch noch mal den größeren Bogen spannen. Ich will es nur andeuten, das müssen wir jetzt hier nicht ausdiskutieren. Aber die Funktion von Sport, die hat ja im Kapitalismus auch tatsächlich eine wichtige Rolle gespielt. Wir kommen von der 7-Tage-Woche irgendwann zur 6-Tage-Woche. Dann ist die Frage, was machen die Leute mit ihrer Freizeit? Und wie kann man sie vielleicht auch davon ablenken, dass sie unter der Woche mit ihrer Arbeitskraft einen Mehrwert schaffen, der nicht in ihren eigenen Taschen landet? Ich will jetzt nicht noch tiefer reingehen, aber ich glaube für alle, die so ein bisschen im Thema sind, die wissen jetzt schon, in welche Richtung das gehen könnte. Und das ist aber ein interessanter Unterschied. Und das ist tatsächlich aber etwas, was auch diese ganz frühe Verbandsgeschichte des Fußballs prägt. Denn wir haben eben diese AFA, die vor allem auf den Nordosten der USA fokussiert ist und tatsächlich aber auch eine enorme Abhängigkeit noch vom englischen Fußballverband, von der FA hat. Also bis, was unter anderem darin mündet, dass sie 1911 dazu gezwungen werden, Spieler zu sanktionieren, die gegen die Corinthians antreten, denn die haben damals verkürzt gesagt eine Auseinandersetzung mit der FA gehabt und tatsächlich hat dann die AFA, also die American Football Association, allen Spielern gedroht, die gegen die Corinthians in irgendwelchen Freundschaftsspielen antreten, dass sie auf drei Jahre hin suspendiert würden. Die FA hatte sogar lebenslang das Verbot gefordert. Und das ist ja durchaus also eine sehr nahe Abhängigkeit zwischen diesen Associations, zwischen diesen Verbänden. Und das führt auch unter anderem dazu, dass es immer wieder Konkurrenzverbände gibt, Konkurrenz-League dazu gibt. Das wird am Ende sogar in dem sogenannten Soccer War enden. Ich versuche da möglichst kurz mal durchzuführen. Die Details dazu ist wirklich interessant, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Da könnt ihr euch gerne noch mal einlesen. Also 1913 gründet sich dann tatsächlich die United Stage Football Association. Das ist heute die Soccer Association. Ich spreche einfach der Einfachheit, aber immer vom Verband, weil ich glaube, euch ist egal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie es dann die genaue Benennung ist. Tatsächlich tritt dieser Verband auch schon der FIFA bei und ist ab 1913 dort mit dabei. Das ist extrem wichtig, denn es gibt Konkurrenzverbände, die aber nicht von der FIFA anerkannt sind. Und so haben wir jetzt die ersten offiziellen Länderspiele. 1916 gibt es das erste. In Schweden, in Göteborg, glaube ich, war es eine 2 zu 3 Niederlage. Und es gibt aber Konkurrenzveranstaltungen. 1921, also acht Jahre nach Gründung der USFA, gründet sich die American Soccer League, eine Profi-Liga, die aus wieder im Nordosten der USA hervorgeht. Da gibt es auch erste Erfolge. Also Archie Stark ist so ein Name vom Bethlehem Steel. Also sowohl Bethlehem Steel als auch Archie Stark. Darüber stolpert man immer wieder. Das sind so die ersten ikonischen Namen dieser frühen Zeit im Fußball in den USA. Die spielen auch schon Spiele gegen Teams aus Österreich. Also zum Beispiel hier, wir haben ein Wiener Team, das besucht, geht auf Rundreise, verdient damit auch gutes Geld. Die spielen vor 46.000 ZuschauerInnen in New York. Und das Ganze eben in den 20er Jahren, Anfang der 20er Jahre. Allerdings, es gibt Probleme und das führt tatsächlich dazu, ich verkürze jetzt sehr, es gibt einen Konkurrenzverband, der sich einen eigenen Pokalwettbewerb schafft. Und damals ist es noch so, dass der US-Fußballverband sein Hauptgeld damit verdient. Also zum einen ist man von der englischen FA abhängig. Und zum anderen aber ist es so, dass man über Ticket-Einnahmen in diesem Pokalwettbewerb, den man selbst veranstaltet, sich eigentlich finanziert. Und zwar nimmt man da große Teile des Eintrittsgeldes, was damals ja die Haupteinnahmequelle für alle Vereine war. Jetzt gibt es einen zweiten Pokalwettbewerb von einer Konkurrenzorganisation. Daraufhin greift die FIFA und der US-Verband ein und verbietet die Teilnahme daran. Ihr könnt euch denken, was passiert. Manche Vereine halten sich dran, manche Vereine halten sich nicht dran. Und am Ende führt das dazu, dass Vereine austreten aus der bisherigen Ligenstruktur und die FIFA wirklich harte Sanktionen verhängt. Also es wird davon gesprochen, dass Spieler lebenslang gesperrt werden sollen, die jetzt in dem neu gegründeten Verband antreten sollen. Und das sind eben der sogenannte Soccer-War von 1928 bis 1929, der dann aber vor allem auch damit endet, dass Jürgen und wahrscheinlich dir ist es sofort aufgefallen, wenn ich das Jahr 1929 nenne, da ist noch was anderes passiert in den USA, nämlich der schwarze Montag und die große Depression, the Great Depression ist da gekommen. Letztlich, um es zu verkürzen, führt das dazu, denen geht es irgendwann wirtschaftlich allen so schlecht, dass sie dazu gezwungen werden, sich wieder zusammen zu tun. Und damit endet diese Streitigkeit. Ich musste aber ehrlicherweise schon daran denken, weil wir das immer wieder jetzt haben werden, dass wir so Konkurrenzveranstaltungen zueinander haben, dass es ein Muster ist, was sich noch wiederholen wird in der Geschichte des Sports in den USA. Aber damals diese 29er-Schnittmarke, ich glaube, an der kommt man eigentlich in keinem geschichtlichen Bereich vorbei, wenn man über die USA spricht, oder?
Das sind jetzt die internen Entwicklungsaspekte. Und gleichzeitig hast du ein Sportentwicklungsland, in dem parallel in den 20ern speziell und dann auch in den 30ern erst Baseball wirklich größer wird und das also in der Fläche, aber auch in den Quantitäten, also die Größe von Stadien, die da gefüllt werden und wie Radio dann anfängt, diese Sportart zu popularisieren speziell. Und du hast aber auch den sehr ernstzunehmenden Versuch, der Football-Leute mit der National Football League da einzusteigen. Das gelingt denen am Anfang nicht so gut. Warum? Die haben nun mit der Konkurrenz des College-Footballs zu kämpfen, wo also riesige dieser großen Stadien, die es heute noch gibt, sind uralt. Fassungsvermögen von 70.000 bis 100.000 Menschen, die also für Football zum Beispiel gebaut werden können und die aber im College hauptsächlich erfolgreich sind, bis in die 50er Jahre, wo das so ein bisschen sich aus die NFL mehr Erfolg hat, mehr Reichweite. Und dieser Faktor, der drückt natürlich auch, also wir haben ja nun Fußball in fast allen anderen Ländern auf der Welt, also sagen wir mal in den meisten Ländern auf der Welt, als die Sportart Nummer eins, die also keine Not hat, sich im Konkurrenzkampf um Aufmerksamkeit gegen andere Sportarten zu behaupten. Das ist eben hier im Fußball nie an den Punkt gekommen, dass Fußball soweit überhaupt mitkämpfen konnte. Und damit hast du verschiedene Facetten. Du hast die jungen Sportler, die nun ambitioniert genug sind, neigen dann irgendwann dazu, sich auf andere Sportarten zu verlegen, zu spezialisieren und werden dort besser. Die fehlen also im Talentepool. Du hast die Aufmerksamkeit, die jetzt zu der Zeit hauptsächlich durch Zeitungen, Tageszeitungen absorbiert oder repräsentiert wird. Und diese Ausgangslage hat sich für Fußball in Amerika nie verändern lassen. Und die Leute, die heute immer noch sehr skeptisch sind, die Amerikaner, die gibt es auch, die also sagen, ja Fußball, das wird wohl nix. Ich sehe das ja nicht so ähnlich. Die haben immer im Blick, ja Mensch, die gegen diese anderen Sportarten, in dieser Rolle, der auf Platz vier oder Platz fünf im Aufmerksamkeitswettbewerb, da muss man ja auch noch gegen anarbeiten, weil da gibt es so viele Mechanismen, die das dann wieder rückkoppeln, beeinflussen und so weiter. Also das gehört vielleicht an die Stelle als weiterer Stichpunkt. Und alle Versuche, die es eben seitdem, was du gerade schon skizziert hast, gegeben hat, Fußball hochzubringen, brauchten immer jede Menge Unterstützung. Und die FIFA hat ja wirklich erst mit der WM-Vergabe von 94 zum ersten Mal das Gefühl artikuliert, oh, das könnte ja sogar was Gutes haben.
Es könnte ja ein Markt sein, oder?
Fußball schenken oder so, oder? Es könnte ein Markt sein. Und auch eine WM, die also, wie wir ja wissen, die WM war riesig erfolgreich, was die Zuschauerzahlen anging, mit großen Stadien und so weiter. Das ist ja gar nicht so doof, mit den Amerikanern in ein Boot zu setzen. Ja, aber dazu mussten natürlich auch in der FIFA noch ganz andere Dinge passieren. Also Stichwort die Briten, die sich da irgendwie immer rausgehalten haben und das Gefühl hatten, damit haben sie nichts zu tun. Diese, wie nennen wir sie mal, bikontinentale Konstellation mit Südamerika und Europa, die alle irgendwie sagen können, wir sind mir. Was interessiert uns der Rest? Wir sind ja schon ganz international hier. Also sowas spielte alles mit rein. Ich könnte jetzt nicht Ursache und Wirkung benennen, aber ich glaube, es gehört zum Kontext von dem, was wir heute durchnehmen wollen.
Und wir haben das ja durchaus, man kann das auch aus der deutschen Perspektive nachvollziehen, dass der Fußball ja auch, also A, hatte er einen sehr, sehr schlechten Ruf, kommt auch über die Genese, was ich vorhin so zoologisch versucht habe zu erklären, aus welchen Schichten der Fußball ursprünglich kam und welche ihn dann aber in Massen praktiziert haben. Und gleichzeitig haben wir aber auch im deutschen Fußball sehr gut dokumentiert, eben dieses Ringen um Aufmerksamkeit. Wir haben eben aus verschiedenen, da kommen auch politische Gründe mit rein, eine Ideologisierung, eine Heroisierung der Einzelsportarten, dass du vorhin die Tornensportverbände genannt hast, ist jetzt kein Zufall. Und du hast uns jetzt ja gerade schon erklärt, wir haben auch in den USA mit vor allem damals schon Baseball, aber eben auch durchaus anderen Sportarten wie eben American Football ein Ringen um Aufmerksamkeit. Und da würde mich interessieren deine Einschätzung im Aufmerksamkeitslevel. Wo stehen denn olympische Spiele für die USA?
Die haben den interessanten Vorteil, dass sie nur alle vier Jahre stattfinden. Also wir sind natürlich jetzt inzwischen aufgesplittert in so zwei Jahresrhythmen, mit den Winterspielen und den Sommerspielen. Aber das war ja früher nicht der Fall. Das wurde ja alles immer in einem Jahr abgewickelt. Und damit kann man, also wenn es um mehrere Dinge geht, erstens die olympischen Sportarten sind sehr stark entwickelt und verankert an den Universitäten. Dort gibt es die Sporteindrichtung, dort gibt es die Trainer. Das heißt also der Top der Medaillen, die Medaillenqualitätsstufe Amerika ist vom College her getragen worden. Und die machen halt, weiß ich nicht, vier Jahre lang alles Mögliche. Die haben ihre Wettbewerbe, die trainieren. Aber werden dann wahrgenommen von der Öffentlichkeit zu einem überschaubaren Zeitrahmen. Dann weiß man ja, diese Teams fahren irgendwie mit damals noch mit dem Schiff nach Stockholm oder nach Antwerpen. Und da gibt es Berichte und so. Und dann, als die Medien sich verändern und Radio und Fernsehen dazukommen, also zum Beispiel 1936, der amerikanische Achter Ruhim Rudan, der da in Grünau am Start ist und auch am Ende die Goldmedaille gewinnt. Das ist ein Massenphänomen in den USA. Das weiß ich nun, weil ich mich unter anderem mit jemandem unterhalten konnte, der ein Buch darüber geschrieben hat, wie Radio, Kurzwelle zu dem Zeitpunkt, wie Radio da zum Beispiel eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Da lässt sich dann eben so eine Sportart im Durchlauferhitzer ganz schnell auf eine Temperatur bringen. Das ist also, weiß ich nicht, übertrieben. Aber vielleicht ein Drittel von Amerika hört die Live-Reportage aus Berlin, weil da sind diese Jungs aus Seattle und Umgebung, die sind alle Holzfäller-Kinder, die kämpfen nun erstens für ihr Land und sie kämpfen gegen die Nazis. Die Nazis haben auch unheimlich gute Rudere am Start und die werden auch benachteiligt. Die kriegen die schlechteste Bahn zugeteilt. Die Deutschen bringen die im Windschatten und so weiter. All das ist möglich, weil die Technik, das ist wieder ein anderer Aspekt, weil die Technik, die Technologie sich weiterentwickelt und solche Sachen dann auch sportlich, die Olympischen Spiele, anders zu packen kriegt. Und dann haben wir 1964 Tokyo, das sind die ersten Satellitenübertragbaren Spiele. Das hat natürlich auch eine Faszination für sich. Das sind zwar damals noch Satelliten, die drehen sich nicht mit der Erde. Also da hat man irgendwie eine Stunde lang Zugang. Da muss man wieder fünf Stunden lang abschalten oder so. Aber trotzdem hat man diesen Live-Aspekt und der lässt sich über die Olympischen Spiele auch wunderbar transportieren und so. Also das spielt sicherlich dort eine eigene Rolle. Aber nur, um noch mal rauszudestillieren. Also die Verankerung dieser Sportarten an den Colleges ist die wirkliche Stütze. Da muss niemand, der der Rudert, der muss sich nicht wirklich selber ein Boot bauen und eine Regatta-Strecke über den Ausbargang oder so. Das gibt es dann alles schon. Und damit hat man also auch schon mal einen Rolling Start, wie man hier sagen würde.
Ich habe die Frage deshalb gestellt, weil nämlich interessanterweise genau in dieser Phase, in der wir uns jetzt gerade noch befinden, nämlich die Great Depression 1929, es geht los und es bilden sich jetzt mehrere Verbände, die sich miteinander bekriegen. Aber keiner kommt von der Stelle, denn sie alle haben wirtschaftliche Probleme. Genau diese Phase wird ironischerweise von manchen Beobachterinnen als Golden Era als erste goldene Ära des Fußballs in den USA bezeichnet. Und wie kommt es dazu? Und da spielen nämlich zwei Weltmeisterschaften eine Rolle und eben einmal Olympische Spiele. Und die beiden Weltmeisterschaften, das ist tatsächlich die erste 1930 in Uruguay. Daran nimmt die USA teil, gewinnt gegen Belgien und Paraguay und scheidet erst im Viertelfinale gegen Argentinien aus. Ein großer, auch sportlicher Erfolg. Und 1934, die WM in Italien, an der nimmt man auch teil. Allerdings ohne Sieg. Und dazwischen liegt ein Ereignis, das könnte vielleicht mitprägend gewesen sein, dafür, dass der Fußball in dieser Phase nicht von der Stelle kommt, nämlich die Olympischen Spiele in Los Angeles. Weil man sich da nicht einig wird über, zum einen, Amateurstatus, also welche Spieler dürfen dort antreten, ist ja bis heute eine große Thematik, dass eben keine Profis teilnehmen sollen an Olympischen Spielen. Ist inzwischen ja schon aufgeweicht, müssen wir nicht ins Detail gehen. Und aber auch Reisekosten werden da ein Thema. Und weil man sich da nicht einig ist, da spielt auch die FIFA eine Rolle, wird Fußball aus dem Programm der Olympischen Spiele in Los Angeles genommen. Und das ist jetzt natürlich sehr viel konjunktiv, aber wenn wir uns dann später angucken werden, jetzt gleich kommt dann ja der Zweite Weltkrieg als Cut und dann geht es erst danach weiter. Aber ich habe da immer wieder dran zurückgedacht, wer weiß, was das vielleicht hätte ändern können für diese Sportart. Denn später werden wir ja vor allem bei den Frauen genau das erleben. Über Erfolge bei olympischen Spielen kommen sie wieder und wieder in ein nationales Bewusstsein. Und weil sie auch sehr erfolgreich sind, führt das zu weitergehenden Effekten. Hast du da noch Gedanken dazu, zu diesen 32er-Spielen?
Nee, dazu nicht, sondern ich finde den Sprung zu den Frauen ganz hilfreich, weil da kann man zum Beispiel ableiten, ja, es gab ja schon Frauenfußball-Weltmeisterschaften. Ich erinnere mich, ich war im Trainingslager der Amerikanerinnen in Orlando in den frühen 90er Jahren. Ich glaube, das war das, die WM in Schweden, die da anstand.
1991 die erste offizielle WM der Frauen in China wurde die dann aufgespätet.
In China, okay. Und da haben wir also noch kaum Wahrnehmung, was die Öffentlichkeit in den USA angeht. Da wirkt die olympische Goldmedaille wie das Zaubermittel, wie der Zauberstab. Irgendwas daran scheint dem größeren amerikanischen Publikum, natürlich auch den Medien bedeutsamer zu sein, als die Fußballweltmeisterschaft. Also womit wir aufgewachsen sind. Die olympischen Spiele im Fußball, die gehen uns irgendwie hinten runter vorbei. Und das interessanteste Phänomen ist in der Zeit 1960, 1964, als die DDR und die Bundesrepublik irgendwie eine Mannschaft auswürfeln müssen, die dann in die gesamte deutsche Mannschaft bei Olympia antreten kann. Das ist so, finde ich, die heißeste Fritte an der Rolle der Deutschen im Fußball bei Olympia. Die Weltmeisterschaft und natürlich dann als die Europameisterschaft ins Rollen kommt. Das waren immer die wichtigeren bedeutenden Turniere unter anderem, auch weil da eben die besseren Spieler waren. Aber der Glanz dieser Medaillenerfolge, das kann man in Amerika sehr gut. Aber das spricht sich gut rum. Also Jesse Owens als Figur 1936, Gewinner von vier Goldmedaillen oder drei? Drei. Auch im Waldspunkt. Vier. Das hat was und das schaffen die olympischen Spiele irgendwie in diesem Land und die Fußballweltmeisterschaft hat das eigentlich auch erst hierher geschafft oder dadurch, dass die Fußball-WM hier dann auch mal stattgefunden hat, kam das dann auch stärker ins Rollen. Und wenn wir dann wieder zu den Frauen gehen, weil ein paar Jahre später, 1999, haben wir eine Frauenfußball-WM und siehe da auch die, zum ersten Mal so richtig für Amerikaner, auch die hat richtig Power, da kommt richtig was. Die Stadien sind voll und die Begeisterung ist da. Und natürlich gewinnen auch die Amerikanerinnen. Aber da kommt dann diese Schiene oder diese Dimension erst so langsam rein. Das ist das als Motivationselement und vielleicht auch als etwas, was Prozesse hilft zu verjüngen und zu verstärken. Was du gerade so erzählt hast, sind ja alles so diese heretischen Entwicklungen. Einer will Papst sein und die anderen wollen eine andere Konfession. Und dann gibt es halt dauernd nur Zersplitterung und Streit. Und man findet nicht die Linie. Und diese Fixierung auf bestimmte Ereignisse, auf die man hinarbeiten kann, hilft auch diesem Prozess, über den wir jetzt so ein bisschen, ja, mehrere Jahrzehnte würden wir jetzt so wegmarschieren.
Ja, und wir sehen eben, und deswegen hatte ich das jetzt eben auch hier nochmal hervorgehoben, diese Olympischen Spiele in Los Angeles, wo im Fußball nicht Teil des Programms ist. Es gibt einen ganz großen strukturellen Unterschied zwischen dem Fußball der Männer in den USA und dem Fußball der Frauen in den USA. Das werde ich dann später auch nochmal erklären können, wo das herkommt. Und das hat nämlich vielleicht auch ein bisschen damit zu tun, Fußball ist hier keine Olympische Sportart. Wir sind im Jahr 32, der Zweite Weltkrieg kommt, große wirtschaftliche Probleme. Das heißt, Fußball liegt da nieder, ist jetzt auch nicht die erste Priorität. Das heißt, wir springen jetzt in die Zeit nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Inzwischen hat sich auch die USFA umbenannt. Ab jetzt ist es nicht mehr Football, sondern Soccer. Also die USSF ist es jetzt. Vielleicht schon die erste Niederlage gegen den American Football. Wer weiß da schon, wie man das interpretieren möchte. Es gibt auch weiter Spiele, auch des US-Nationalteams der Männer. 1952 spielt man zum Beispiel gegen Schottland vor über 100.000 ZuschauerInnen in Glasgow. Es gibt auch kleinere Turniere, so pan-amerikanische Spiele, an denen man teilnimmt. Aber es gibt eben vor allem auch eine Konkurrenz anderer Sportarten. Und da sind die 60er ganz entscheidende Jahre. In den 60ern gründen sich die American Football League und die American Baseball Association in Konkurrenz jeweils zur National Football League und zur National Basketball Association. Gleichzeitig wächst auch die NHL. Und in dieser Phase, da passiert eben im Fußball noch nicht so arg viel. Wir werden gleich darüber sprechen, welche Liga sich dann gründen. Aber Spoiler, die wird nicht viel Erfolg haben. Ist das vielleicht tatsächlich, wenn wir jetzt kurz bei den Männern bleiben, der große strukturelle Unterschied, dass sich hier eben andere Sportarten jetzt schon auf eine Art und Weise kommerziell professionalisieren, dass der Fußball immer im Hintertreffen ist, weil er die Aufmerksamkeit nicht mehr bekommt?
Weil die Rolle, die Fernsehen spielt, hat mindestens zwei Aspekte. Das eine ist, dass du ein Publikum erreichen kannst, das größer ist denn je. Und das ist eben auch ein Live-Publikum. Und nicht nur einfach, so wie heute unsere YouTube-Habchen nach dem Spiel, sondern es wird ja auch zur wachsenden Einnahmequelle. Und auch hier hast du ja so eine Grenze von Ressourcen. Du hast einerseits diese Ressourcen-Kapazitätssituation mit der Aufmerksamkeit des Publikums, aber auch diese Geschichte mit dem Geld, dass Fernsehsender, die nun hier ja kommerzielle Fernsehsender sind und deshalb auch ein stärkeres Interesse an der Förderung und Entwicklung haben, dass die aber auch, die können die auch nicht ihre Ressourcen oder ihre finanziellen Einnahmemöglichkeiten willkürlich ausbauen. Die sind auch beschränkt und die müssen also ihr Geld irgendwie einteilen. Das heißt, du hast also hier in dem amerikanischen Fernseh, in der Fernsehwelt von heute, wo du also immer noch terrestrische Stationen hast, du hast Kabelfernsehen und inzwischen eben auch Streaming, hast du aber auch so eine Entwicklung, naja, ein Kanal oder ein Sender kann sich halt ein oder zwei Sportarten dann leisten, wo sie intensiv dran sind. Aber sie können auch nicht, was meinetwegen die Rolle mal des öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehens war, die Abbildung von ganz viel verschiedenen Sport, das hat es hier nie gegeben. Also du hast so, auch wieder so Druckpunkte. Und da bist du immer Stiefkind, wenn du auf dieser niedrigen Ebene anfängst. Und selbst eine, sagen wir mal völlig, vielleicht nachvollziehbare Entwicklung, also mit der, so ein Ultimate-Fighting-Kram, die können auch erst so langsam eine Rolle spielen. Heute spielen sie die dominierende Rolle, weil das Interesse an dem klassischen Boxsport nachgelassen hat. Also da geht quasi die Drehtür weiter. Und die, die vorher drin waren und irgendwie verdient haben, die sind wie ausgeblutet, da ist nichts mehr. Und dann kommt diese neue, neuere Idee, die im Grunde eine alte ist. Also wir kämpfen mit sehr brutaler Technik. Die hat dann eine Chance und dann, da ist Platz. Aber wo Soccer müsste, das andere ist irgendwie verdrängen. Und erst jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass die Liga begreift, dass sie diesen Wettbewerb annehmen wollen, indem sie nämlich jetzt gerade frisch den Kalender der Liga umstellen, also die Ankündigung, dass sie sie umstellen werden. Und damit kommen sie ganz direkt nochmal in Konkurrenz mit Football, mit Eishockey, mit Basketball. Und irgendwas in dem Selbstbewusstsein der Leute, die da heute die Weichen stellen, scheint sich auch geändert zu haben. Das heißt nicht, dass deren Rechnung aufgeht. Aber es heißt zumindest mal, wir haben einen neuen Pegelstand, was Soccer oder Fußball hier in diesem Land oder was die Liga angeht. Und das könnte man auf der haben Seite verbuchen, nachdem wir ja hier so verschiedene Dinge suchen. Was geht hier, was funktioniert, was ist nicht so gut und so.
Also dazu muss man eben kurz erklären, bisher ist der Fußballtermin nicht den anderen Sportarten so gut es ging, aus dem Weg gegangen. Übrigens jetzt auch bei dem Finale. Also das findet nicht aus europäischer Sicht so statt, dass man das hier in Europa auch bequem verfolgen kann, sondern weil wichtige Bowl-Spiele im College-Football anstehen, die später kommen, die eben die Aufmerksamkeit wieder wegsaugen würden. Aber jetzt eben stellt man um auf den europäischen Kalender. Das heißt, die neue Saison wird eben im Spätsommer starten und wird dann eben im Frühjahr, im Übergang zum Sommer beendet sein. Das war bisher anders und damit ist man eben in Konkurrenz unter anderem zur NFL, die ihr Saisonhighlight im Februar hat und so weiter und so fort. Also interessante Entwicklungen und vor allem eben auch mit Blick nochmal zurück, denn das, was du uns gerade zum Leihsport erzählt hast und zu der Aufmerksamkeit, die man hat durchs Fernsehen, Sportgeschichte kann man immer auch als Medien- und Technologiegeschichte verstehen, das ist tatsächlich auch Initiator für dann letztlich eine neue Gründung einer US-Profiliger im Fußball, denn die WM 1966 in England, die erzeugt ein großes Zuschauerinteresse, ist auch die erste Weltmeisterschaft im Fußball, die in Farbe übertragen wird. Das Finale wird insgesamt zwischen, soll es rund 400 Millionen Menschen erreicht haben an den Bildschirmen, ist die größte globale Fernsehzuschauer-Anzahl seit der Beerdigung von Winston Churchill, nach dem, was ich recherchiert habe. Und das ist eben auch ein vielgesehenes Sport-Event in den USA. Wahrscheinlich, mutmaßlich, nach allem, was man weiß, viel von eben Menschen, die in die USA gekommen sind und eben einen europäischen Hintergrund haben und daher eben das Interesse an diesem Sport haben. Und das führt jetzt zur Gründung von nicht einer, sondern, na klar, wir sprechen über die USA, gleich zwei Profi-League, die profitieren wollen von diesem Interesse, das sich eben manifestiert hat in den guten Zuschauerzahlen am TV. Es gibt einmal die NASL, das ist die National North American Soccer League, die auch die Unterstützung erhält des Verbands unter FIFA. Und es gibt die National Professional Soccer League, die NPSL. Die beginnen beide 1967, also im Jahr nach der WM, ihre Saison. Aber es passiert das, was immer passiert. Die FIFA schlägt sich auf eine Seite, nämlich auf die der NASL und Warnspieler, die in der anderen Liga antreten wollen, dass sie auf Lebenszeit gesperrt werden würden. Und ein bisschen überraschend, aber da müssen wir jetzt nicht in die Details gehen, kündigen dann Ende 1967 beide Ligen an, dass sie fusionieren würden. Es gab vorher so eine Schadensersatzklage, da hatten die ein bisschen Angst vor. Plus in den ersten Jahren ist es auch, oder in diesem ersten Jahr, es ist auch nicht so wahnsinnig erfolgreich verlaufen. Also es war nicht so, dass die Millionen, die das WM-Finale Deutschland-England 1966 verfolgt haben, dass sie dann direkt auch an den örtlichen Fußballplatz oder noch in andere Stadien, das waren auch keine Fußballstadien, gelaufen sind, um sich diese Ligen anzugucken, sondern wir sprechen hier von sehr, sehr wenigen ZuschauerInnen, auch dann eben in der NASL, also so heißt dann die weitergeführte Liga. Wir sprechen da von einigen tausend ZuschauerInnen, die pro Spiel kommen. Der Schnitt liegt im Jahr 1974 bei knapp 8.000 ZuschauerInnen. Man versucht damals mit Regeländerungen, das ist auch vielleicht das, was ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, mal mitbekommen habt, versucht man, das für ein US-amerikanisches Interesse zu verformen, dieses Spiel, also unter anderem führt man ein, das abseits erst ab einer 35-Jahrt-Linie gilt. Die FIFA kommt dann irgendwann und sagt, das geht nicht, es ist weiter ab der Mittellinie. Man führt aber auch zum Beispiel ein, das Elfmeterschießen, um einen Sieger zu bestimmen, wenn nach normaler Spielzeit und Verlängerung es noch unentschieden steht. Das ist interessanterweise etwas, was sich dann tatsächlich fortsetzt im Weltfußball. Man hat auch ein ganz interessantes Punktesystem mit Bonuspunkten für geschossene Tore zum Beispiel, um die Attraktivität der Spiele zu steigern und damit Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen. Aber Jürgen, es sind keine Regeländerungen, die für Aufmerksamkeit sorgen. Es ist auch nicht vielleicht die Qualität des Sportes generell, sondern es ist ein Mann, der dann tatsächlich den Effekt hat. Wir haben wirklich erstaunliche Parallelen zu dem, was wir auch heute mit Lionel Messi haben. Am 10. Juni 1975 kommt Pelé und der kommt auch zu New York Cosmos. Also auch nicht in irgendeine Stadt, sondern eben in eine Metropole. Kannst du vielleicht versuchen zu beschreiben, was das damals bedeutet hat und wie oft ist dir das eigentlich jetzt noch in deiner Arbeit? Du lebst jetzt schon viele Jahre in den USA und berichtest eben auch für deutsche Medien. Wie oft läuft dir eigentlich Pelé noch über den Weg und diese Geschichte?
Das letzte Mal lief er mir über den Weg, als ich Jürgen Klinsmann bei ESPN getroffen habe, um ihn zu interviewen. Und da kam Pelé gerade auch durch die Studios und kriegte eine Klubung. Und es gab, das habe ich auch auf Band irgendwo, es gab diesen kurzen Dialog zwischen Klinsmann und Pelé, die sich natürlich beide kannten. Und er ist schon ein bisschen angedickter Pelé und sie reden über Gewicht, Körpergewicht und so weiter. Also das war das letzte Mal. Ich müsste jetzt im Kalender nachgucken, wann das genau war. Das war noch bevor Jürgen Klinsmann Trainer in den USA wurde. Oder Nationaltrainer der USA wurde. Der war gerade bei Bayern München rausgekegelt worden. Und der Rest ist natürlich über, es gibt eine wunderbare Dokumentation, also Dokumentarfilm über Kosmos, wie das angefangen hat. Also über solche Dinge oder auch mal, wenn man, wie ich das gemacht habe, als Messi kam, habe ich dann einmal die volle Kelle genommen und habe das dann auch in einer Geschichte für die FAZ ein bisschen ausgebreitet, wie das so war damals. Und für mich ist das Wichtigste an diesem Ereignis, aus welcher geistigen Quelle die Verpflichtung von Pele kommt. Die kommt nämlich aus der Quelle der Rockmusikindustrie der beiden Ertigen Brüder, das Label Atlantic, was also ein wunderbares Schallplattenlabel war, wo also wirklich extrem viel wichtige Musik gemacht und veröffentlicht wurde. Die hatten eine Nase, die hatten genug Geld und die hatten genug Nase und die konnten sich das ausmalen, wie man das alles irgendwie hinkriegt. Und die leben nun auch nicht mehr, die kann man heute auch nicht mehr interviewen, man müsste also jetzt entsprechende Literatur sich angucken. Aber diese Verzahnung von Unterhaltungsindustrie Konzept mit Fußball in Amerika, die ist so plastisch in dem Moment, weil kein Mensch, der aus dem Fußball kommt, hätte jetzt gedacht, also wir können diesen Mann irgendwie nach New York bringen, weil New York ist doch eine tolle Stadt oder so. Und ich weiß nichts über die Beckenbauerverhandlungen, aber möglicherweise wurde dann das nochmal überlegt. Witzigerweise, da wir gerade über 1966 und die WM gesprochen haben, Pelé erlebt ja da eigentlich ein Fiasco bei dieser WM. Der fällt da also auch verletzt irgendwie aus. Aber hat halt 1970 dann schon wieder richtig was zu bieten. Während das so Beckenbauer WM ist, da kommt er so richtig zum ersten Mal voll zur Geltung und wird jemand. Und das wäre schon interessant. Ich weiß nicht, ob du jetzt zufällig auch nochmal danach gestöbert hast, wie das mit Beckenbauer eingefädelt worden ist. Aber auch da werden konverzielle Interessen. Vielleicht war Herr Schwagen.
Ich habe das damals für Elfleben noch mal genau nachrecherchiert. Also Beckenbauer hatte im Grunde drei Gründe, das Land zu verlassen und welchen davon man, welcher da jetzt Ausschlag geben war, das ist dann im Bereich der Spekulation. Einmal hat er privat damals ein Verfahren wegen Steuerhinterziehung verloren und da musste Geld nachzahlen. Und das hat bei ihm nach allem...
Aber das ist günstig verloren. Er hat es sehr günstig verloren.
Er hat es sehr günstig verloren und er war trotzdem sehr erboßt darüber, dass er es verloren hat. Also nach allem, was man weiß, hat er das schon mal als Affront verstanden, dass er da jetzt noch mal im Nachhinein Steuer nachzahlen soll. Gleichzeitig gab es eine private Geschichte, auf die ich nicht näher eingehen will. Das ist Boulevard-Thema. Könnt ihr euch vielleicht auch denken, was es gewesen sein könnte bei Franz Beckenbauer. Und das dritte ist dann tatsächlich ein sportlicher Aspekt. Beim FC Bayern war Franz Beckenbauer damals alles andere als unumstritten, aber nur mannschaftsintern. Nach außen hin war es immer noch der große Franz. Und das war auch vielleicht Teil der Kritik, die mannschaftsintern annehmen kann. Unter anderem wortführend durchgeführt von einem gewissen Uli Hoeneß und einem gewissen Paul Breitner. Die haben wirklich eigentlich kaum eine Gelegenheit ausgelassen, um an Franz Beckenbauer Kritik zu üben, zu sticheln. Er hat da auch durchaus zurückgeschlagen. Also ich möchte jetzt nicht hier irgendwie eine Opferrolle von ihm umsetzen. Und das alles wird wohl dazu geführt haben, dass der Schritt in die USA zumindest leichter war. Plus schlecht verdient hat er bei Cosmos definitiv auch nicht. Plus, und das ist jetzt aber dann schon sehr im spekulativen Bereich, es könnte auch sein, relativ bald nach dem Abschied von ja auch seinem Manager Robert Schwan, der ja bis dahin auch bei den Bayern eben Manager war. Da wurden auch, was den FC Bayern betrifft, gewisse Steuerthematiken nochmal virulent. Und eventuell hat er da auch schon einen Tipp bekommen oder hat er auch schon so eine Ahnung. Und das alles hat wohl dazu geführt, dass eben auch Franz Beckenbauer dann bei Cosmos New York aufschlägt. Und das ist eben auch die Phase, in der man eben über große Spielernamen und Glitzer und Glamour versucht irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen. Also es ist geradezu grotesk. Da spielen Spieler wie eben Pelé, Franz Beckenbauer, Johann Kreuf, George Best, Gerd Müller, natürlich dann auch Gordon Banks, Jeff Hurst, Eusebio und Giorgio Chinaldia kommt dann auch noch aus Italien. Und die spielen aber zum Teil auf grün gefärbter Erde, die aussehen soll wie Rasen. Aber sie spielen vor ZuschauerInnen. Es kommen viele, viele Menschen. Also bis vor, Pelé war bei Cosmos New York das bestbesuchte Spiel mit 8000 ZuschauerInnen besetzt und nach seiner Ankunft haben sie einen Durchschnitt von 28000 ZuschauerInnen und insgesamt steigt das sogar bis auf 40.000. Also könnte man ja auch sagen, eigentlich hat das funktioniert, was man sich erhofft hat und was du ja gerade auch schon mit dem Kontext ein bisschen hinterfüttert hast, woher die Geldgeber für diese Idee kamen. Woran glaubst du denn, dann ist es letztlich dann doch gescheitert, dieses Projekt Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen?
Also ich glaube, es scheitert am Ende mit dem, was auf dem Rasen angeboten wird. Und ich habe mich mal vor ein paar Jahren mit dem auch damaligen Torwart von Kosmos unterhalten, Hubert Birkenmayer aus Deutschland, der gar nicht so erfolgreich war in der Bundesliga. Also gehörte er eher zu den Graubrot-Tor-Leuten. Ich will ihm nichts anhängen, aber er konnte halt dann auch in Amerika glänzen. Und er hat das durchaus zu erklären versucht, wenn da nicht nachgefüttert werden kann, wo eine Erwartungshaltung angezüchtet wird, und wenn da nicht diese Allstars, diese Superstars irgendwie immer weiter nachwachsen, weil man sie unter anderem auch gar nicht bezahlen kann in diesem Ausmaß, dann lässt das automatisch nach. All diese ganzen Yellow-Press-Hebel, die dieses Phänomen anheizen können, das lässt alles nach. Und die Generation, die wir gerade genannt haben, oder die du gerade genannt hast, die hören irgendwann sowieso auf, also müssen ja wieder neue kommen. Und Kosmos war in diesem kosmos, in diesem amerikanischen Kosmos, also wie anspruchsvoll auch immer dieser Titel war, der war ja nicht doof, weil die Spieler kamen von überall her, aber der Kosmos war im Grunde sehr beschränkt. Das war der Publikumsmagnet. Und die waren auch sportlich natürlich überragend. Und wo die, es hat Birkenmayr gesagt, wo die auftraten, da wurden Leute gezogen. Da stiegen die, so wie jetzt bei Messi auch, da stiegen dann die Zuschauerzahlen enorm. Und es gab ein anderes Problem, auch hier gehe ich wieder auf Birkenmayr zurück. Damals wurde das zwar im Fernsehen übertragen, aber es gab, die Leute, also die Liga musste das verschenken. Die konnten dafür gar kein Geld bekommen. Die Sender, die das dann gebracht haben, waren natürlich happy. Sie hatten Programm, Liveprogramm und konnten dann auch Werbung verkaufen, aber davon haben sie nichts abgegeben. Das heißt also diese Refinanzierungsquelle, die sich in Amerika schon sehr viel früher als relevanter Teil des Sportkommerzes entwickelt hat, die war zu dem Zeitpunkt versperrt. Und all das trägt dann wachsende Scannen, fehlender Nachschub und fehlende Einnahmequellen über die Eintrittskarten hinaus. Also es gab ausverkaufte Stadion. Die sind ja dann in ein Footballstadion, in die Kosmos in ein Footballstadion gezogen. Also damals noch Giants Stadium hieß. 70.000 Kapazität oder so. Und die haben das gefüllt. Und das ist auch toll. Ich habe das gesehen, als Matthäus da aufgelaufen ist. Da hatten sie also mit Mühe 15.000 Zuschauer. Und dieses riesige Stadion hatte eine Echo von den Paaren, die da geklatscht oder geboot oder sonst was gemacht haben. Das war grotesk. Das war wie auf der Geisterbahn. Also wenn man auch diese Stadien nicht hat, zum Beispiel, in die man halbwegs voll machen kann, dann fehlt auch noch mal diese Stimulanz, dieses Gefühl des Publikums. Wir sind da und wir unterstützen eine Mannschaft oder so. Das hat zumindest die MLS, da sprechen wir noch drüber, konsequenterweise von Anfang an versucht, einiges anders zu machen, als die North American Soccer League. Heute sind sie zumindest, was diese All-Star-Dimension angeht, genau an der Stelle wieder angekommen, wie vorher. Weil in den USA irgendwas danach schreit, dass man auf Umaufmerksamkeit kämpft, die weiter reicht, als nur hier ist ein tolles Produkt oder Fußballspiel.
Du hast uns aus deinem Interview mit Hubert Birkenmayer auch einen Ton mitgebracht. Und der hat mich auch noch mal auf so einen anderen Gedanken gebracht. Wenn du magst, dann spiele ich ihn mal kurz ein und dann erzähle ich dir, was jetzt noch so meine Überlegungen waren, auch als Unterschied von damals zu heute vielleicht.
Wenn 70.000 Leute im Stadion waren, ich weiß nicht, ob da vielleicht 10.000 oder 15:000 Amerikaner dabei waren. Es waren meistens die Ethnik-People, die sich mit ihren Spielern identifizieren wollten. Viele Deutsche, viele Brasilianer, Jugoslawen. Aber das hat sich dann später geändert. Man hat ja kaum Fußball gesehen im Fernsehen hier. Das Einzige war Soccer made in Germany. Oder wenn man eine Weltmeisterschaft hat, man musste in Madison Square Garden gehen, um das nicht anzuhören. Das hat sich dann alles geändert. Fußball wurde am Fernsehen gezeigt, obwohl die Vereine keine Fernsehgelder bekommen haben. Die Vereine haben das einfacher, die kriegen Fernsehgelder. Das gab es bei uns nicht. Deswegen, diese Liga hat eine bessere Chance, zu überstehen.
Da hatte ich nämlich einen Gedanken zu, weil ich bin ja eingestiegen, zu erzählen, welche aus europäischer Sicht absurden Regeländerungen eingeführt wurden, um eben den Fußball für ein amerikanisches Publikum zu popularisieren. Dann habe aber Hubert Birkenmayr, der uns erzählt, die Leute, die da im Stadion waren, das waren eben vornehmlich welche, die vor einem Migrationshintergrund her mit dem Fußball zu tun hatten. Für die ist ja dann auch einigermaßen grotesk, wie dieses Spiel verändert wird. Kann das vielleicht auch so einen Unterschied erklären zwischen damals und heute, dass aus verschiedenen Gründen, auf die kommen wir zum Teil auch glaube ich noch im Verlaufe unseres Gesprächs, wie eben jetzt auch ein Publikum in den Stadion haben, dass wenn es da ist, dann auch nicht nur mit den Regeln vertraut ist, sondern auch mit den Sehgewohnheiten, die Fußball ebenso bietet. Nämlich, dass es relativ unterbrechungsfrei und auch mal langweilig sein kann, aber dass man das eben aushalten muss, weil der eine Moment im Fußball entscheiden kann, anders als in den meisten anderen populären Sportarten in den USA. Ist das vielleicht so ein Unterschied?
Ja, also wir haben eine ganz andere Breite. Ein Aspekt würde ich jetzt hier einwerfen. Es spielen mehrere Millionen Menschen Fußball in Amerika. Zu jeder Zeit. Und das sind hauptsächlich erstmal Kinder und Jugendliche, aber auch Erwachsene. Und dieser Transmissionsriemen, das also an den Schulen und in Colleges dieser Sport weiter gewachsen und entwickelt worden ist, führt zu einem halbwegs vorinformierten Publikum. Und dann kommt von außen die Premier League als Fernsehprodukt. Und die Premier League könnte einen eigentlich dazu bringen, zu sagen, na ja, die Leute interessieren sich aus irgendeinem Grund für Englischen oder diesem, das ist ja auch ein Weltfußball geworden, aber dieses aus England stammende Qualitätsprodukt. Aber das hat ja auch Konsequenzen. Also wenn dir das gefällt. Und wir haben, die haben die höchsten Einschaltquoten im Fußball, im amerikanischen Fernsehen. Premier League. Wenn dir das aber gefällt, wenn du da dran bist, wenn du da morgens für aufstehst quasi, weil das live aus England übertragen wird, dann wirst du auch angefüttert mit Sachverstand. Gerade auch weil unter anderem die englischen Fernsehreporter, und die sind ja auch in der Sprache, die die Amerikaner einfach nachvollziehen. Aber die englischen Fernsehreporter, in fast allen Sportarten, sind hochkompetente, sehr gute Leute in ihrem Metier. Ich würde sie immer als die Nummer eins in diesem Arbeitsbereich nennen, soweit ich das überblicken kann. Und dieser Transmissionsriemen kommt dazu. Und da gibt es einen Podcast namens Men in Blazers, der sich eigentlich mit dieser Geschichte schon früh, als Podcast schon früh damit beschäftigt, aber auch einen enormen Zuspruch hat. Und diese Mischung aus, da lernen wir was über Fankultur, da lernen wir was über das Spiel, wir lernen was über entscheidende Figuren, ist bestimmt hier eingeflossen, um diesem Publikum was zu geben. Und wenn du dich dann mit dem St. Pauli Supporters Club in Brooklyn beschäftigst, was ich auch schon mal gemacht habe, dann merkst du, da kommt noch was dazu. Die identifizieren sich mit einem halbwegs obskuren Thema, aber auch, weil da so ein politischer Anklang ist, der hier im Sport immer so weggedrängt wird. Shut up and dribble ist so der Slogan der Fox News Leute. Also haltet euch bitte aus Politik raus und so. Und natürlich wird das auch so praktiziert. Die meisten Sportler haben Sorge, sich überhaupt zu äußern. Aber dann hat die das Anteil...
FIFA braucht zum Beispiel verzichtet auf Antidiskriminierungskampagnen, die man sonst rund um WMs immer durchführt.
Ja. Und da hast du aber dann... Also gerade dieser Typ von Fußballfan ist nun nicht unbedingt jetzt total drin im Fußball oder so, sondern ist drin in diesem Fußballkulturelement und guckt sich vor allem Pauli an, wenn es dann irgendwo zu gucken gibt, streamen, weiss ich nicht. Und ja, das kannst du dann auch plötzlich irgendwie wahrnehmen, dass in den USA, in diesem riesigen Land mit 350 Millionen Menschen, dass da solche Dinge auch irgendwo ein Saatkorn Qualität haben und dass sich daraus was entwickelt. Und so gibt es also in einer MLS bekannter Weise, also das Team Minnesota United ist bekannt für auch für seine Fans, die alle ein bisschen heller im Kopf sind und die das auch als ihre Leidenschaft für den Fußball auch als so ein halbpolitisches Statement betrachten gegenüber den anderen Sportarten, die sie wegen ihrer fehlenden politischen Dimensionen einfach nicht interessiert. So hast du eine ganze Reihe von Kleinigkeiten, die sicherlich über verschiedene Stränge, verschiedene Kanäle auf das Gesamte einen Einfluss haben. Bis hin, wie die Investorenlandschaft in Amerika aussieht. Die Investorenlandschaft sieht so aus, du kannst in dem Mannschaftssport, wo es am lukrativsten ist, zu investieren. Es ist alles begrenzt. Du hast Ligen, die sind ohne Aufstieg, ohne Abstieg. Da reinzukommen, ist ganz schwierig. Und das ist der Grund, warum du zum Beispiel heute eine unglaubliche Menge an amerikanischen, reichen Amerikanern, die im Sport, zum Beispiel in der Premier League investieren. Ich habe den letzten Stand nicht. Es sind glaube ich in der Premier League, es sind zehn Amerikaner, die da eine Rolle spielen. In den Ligen darunter gibt es auch jede Menge. Da gibt es dann dieses Phänomen, dieser Wrexham United, was ist denn Wrexham United? Wrexham FC.
Wrexham FC.
Ja. Also ein Ryan Reynolds und andere Schauspieler, da eingestiegen sind, als das noch nicht mal, als es ein Non-League-Football war, da noch nicht mal richtig mitgemacht hat. Und die das hochgebracht haben, jetzt in die zweite Liga, Championship, die da sogar mithalten, die jetzt ein Stadion bauen oder ausbauen und alles Mögliche hinkriegen. Und da lecken viele amerikanische Investoren, die haben da quasi Blut, die spüren da was. Weil die wissen, die können auch irgendwie das alte Konzept von Kapitalismus, wir steigen mit niedrigen Preisen, niedrigen Kosten ein und verkaufen mit Ertrag oder Gewinn und Profit irgendwann später oder so. Das lässt sich da irgendwie hinkriegen. Also hast du auch diesen Teil, also eine bestimmte andere Schicht von Leuten, auch irgendwie an den Rädern mit dreht oder was. Also alles nicht unbedingt jetzt sehr super genau verankert, aber ich denke, das sind alles so Aspekte, über die man stolz hat, wenn man sich mit dieser Lage in diesem Land beschäftigt.
Ja, total. Also zum einen Rats am AFC ist es natürlich, als ich es gesagt habe, dachte ich mir, irgendwie klingt es noch nicht richtig. Aber das Interessante ist nämlich, dass das sich wiederholende Mechanismen sind. Und während man damals noch sagen konnte, also wenn wir quasi wieder zurückspringen in diese Mitte der 70er, als eben Pelé und die anderen Stars in der NASL damals auflaufen, dann hast du damals zwar ein Publikum, das wesentlich noch migrantisch geprägt ist und deswegen auch andere Vorstellungen vom Fußball hat. Damals hatte dieses Publikum aber noch nicht die Möglichkeit, an jedem Wochenende die Premier League zu verfolgen. Das heißt, es ist schon ein interessantes Zeitfenster, in dem es vielleicht möglich gewesen wäre, hier etwas zu etablieren. Und interessanterweise hast du aber mit dem zweiten Aspekt, den du gerade angesprochen hast, nämlich die Investoren und gerade die US-Investoren, die jetzt in den europäischen Fußball hineindrängen, hast du auch schon einen der wesentlichen Gründe genannt, warum das damals schiefgegangen ist, Mitte der 70er. Denn das gewachsene Interesse, die höheren Einnahmen, das führt auch zu einer Zunahme an Teams. Also wir starten in der NASL mit neun Teams und wir haben dann bis Mitte der 70er, bis Anfang der 80er haben wir dann schon 24 Teams, auf die diese Liga gewachsen ist, von denen aber etwa die Hälfte relativ schnell bankrott geht. Und da kommen verschiedene Dinge mit rein. Zum einen, Peli spielt irgendwann nicht mehr bei Cosmos New York. Auch Franz Beckenbauer spielt irgendwann nicht mehr bei Cosmos New York. Wir haben wieder eine Konkurrenzliga, interessanterweise diesmal eine Indoor-Liga. Die Major Indoor Soccer League hat damals eine Rolle gespielt. Dann wird die WM 86 nicht in die USA vergeben, sondern nach Mexiko. Plus wir haben auch den Warner Communications Konzern, der ein ganz, ganz schweres wirtschaftliches Quartal hat. Die waren wesentlicher mitfinanziert von vielen Teams und auch von der Liga. Das heißt, da kommen jetzt verschiedene Dinge zusammen. Das einzige, was davon übrig bleibt, ist die Erkenntnis binnen weniger Jahre, von 1982 bis 85. Das sind so drei Horrorjahre. Da reiht sich schlechte Nachricht an schlechte Nachricht, bricht diese Liga komplett zusammen und auch kommende Versuche mit rein amerikanischen Teams, wo man dann eben versucht hat, also auch in der NASL noch, hat sich in Washington, glaube ich, ein rein US-amerikanisches Team gegründet, um eben zu versuchen, mit diesem USP, sage ich mal, Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen. Es sollte nicht funktionieren. In einer auch, muss man sagen, wirtschaftlich angespannten Situation, Anfang der 80er, geht es generell mit der Wirtschaft, auch in den USA, ein bisschen südwärts. Und dann ist aber binnen weniger Jahre diese Liga-Geschichte und interessanterweise hängt eben auch damit zusammen, dass da Leute Geld gerochen haben. Aber es lag halt nicht genug Geld für alle da und deswegen sind sie alle mit Verlusten rausgegangen. Und ob das eine Parabel auch auf unsere Gegenwart ist, das würde mich wirklich mal interessieren.
Also die MLS verdient unterm Strich kein Geld. Die Investoren, die dort eingestiegen sind, und die sind ja zwar nominell an bestimmte Teams geknüpft, aber sie sind alle eigentlich Investoren eines großen Konstrukts, nämlich der Liga selber. Und so gab es auch Phasen, in denen, weiß ich nicht, vier oder fünf Teams gehörten irgendwie an Schutz oder so. Der das also mal zwischendurch quasi aufrecht erhalten hat, was da schon kippelte, weil die Anfangsjahre dieser MLS waren auch nicht besonders lukrativ. Also gab es da so ein paar, die wirken wie Mäzenaten, aber bei Anschutz war noch nie jemand als Mäzenin unterwegs. Die haben immer genau auf das Geld geachtet, aber die waren auch schlauer als andere Investoren im Sport, weil die haben sich zum Beispiel ganz deutlich auf den infrastrukturellen Teil fokussiert. Für die war wichtig der Stadionbau als Einnahmequelle im Laufe der Zeit oder in anderen Bereichen eine Halle, wie in anderen Sportarten. Ich glaube, die haben auch die Berliner Basketballhalle hingestellt oder so. Und wo die dann auch wussten, irgendwann können wir das auch wieder weiter verkaufen, wenn das hier alles vernünftig funktioniert, dann verkaufen wir unsere Anteile oder wir verkaufen die Immobilie. Und diese Logik, die in der MLS eine Rolle spielt, die hat irgendwann halbwegs funktioniert, aber auch, weil man eben dann Mittel gefunden hat, wie mit Matthäus und so, deutet sich das ja schon an, aber dann mit Beckham, weil man dann tatsächlich wieder in diese Tüte gegriffen hat, die man eigentlich schon aufgeblasen hatte, wie so eine Brötchentüte und eigentlich schon zusammengeknallt hatte, dass man da wieder reingreift. Und dann sagt der Mutter, nein, wir müssen hier irgendwas machen. Und das ist das, was diese Liga bis heute am Leben erhält. Dass es doch immer wieder irgendwie dieses Grundrauschen gegeben hat, wir müssen hier was machen, das ist es noch nicht. Ich glaube, die anderen waren, die früheren Beispiele waren immer sehr viel kurzfristiger motiviert und waren engagiert und konnten dann aber auch nicht durchhalten oder konnten sich auch nicht mit Gleichgesinnten so zusammenschließen. Das ist also eine bestimmte Richtung angenommen hat. Aber das sind sehr, das kenne ich ja noch nicht aus dem internen her. Ich kann das nur so beobachten oder habe ich beobachtet über die vielen Jahre.
Also da sind wir jetzt dann schon quasi in die Anfang 2000er gesprungen, da werden wir auf jeden Fall später nochmal drüber sprechen. Wir halten auf jeden Fall fest, Mitte der 80er ist der Männer-Ligen-Versuch im Fußball in den USA, der ist krachend gescheitert und es ist im Grunde nichts mehr davon übrig. Ganz anders ist die Situation bei den Frauen. Und das ist wirklich auch ein interessanter Unterschied, weil er eben etwas Strukturelles mit sich bringt. Also wir haben natürlich auch Fußball der Frauen schon früh im 20. Jahrhundert, wobei ich da wenig Dokumentation gefunden habe, wo man sich allerdings immer nicht so ganz sicher sein kann. Gibt es da wenig, weil es damals keine Frauen gab, die Fußball gespielt haben oder wurde diese Forschung noch nicht angestellt? Da muss man ja leider immer ein bisschen zurückhaltend bleiben. Was dokumentiert ist, ist, dass es in den 1950er Jahren in St. Louis zum Beispiel schon eine kleine Liga gab. In den 1960ern erste kleinere Frauenfußballprogramme an den Colleges, allerdings noch nicht finanziert. Es gab auch keinerlei Stipendien. Und das betone ich deshalb so, denn das ist die große Veränderung, die 1972 kommt. Am 23. Juni 1972 wird der Title IX als Teil der Education Amendments von Richard Nixon unterzeichnet. Und der Title IX, der forderte, dass wenn Bundesmittel für männliche Studenten verwendet worden waren, dass eine vergleichbare Summe für weibliche Aktivitäten aufgewendet werden musste. Und das hat zu einer großen Veränderung geführt in der Art und Weise, wie eben Mädchen- und Frauensport gefordert wurde. Also nur mal ein paar Zahlen zu nennen. An den Highschools in den USA waren 1971 rund 300.000 Mädchen, die Sport getrieben haben. Das ist Mitte der 70er, sind das schon 1,6 Millionen. Also das hat sich verzickfacht. Und im Highschool Fußball ist es ähnlich. Man spricht davon, dass Anfang der 70er rund 700 Mädchen überhaupt Fußball gespielt haben an Highschools. 1980 sind es schon 41.000. Also es ist ein Brandbeschleuniger für eine Entwicklung. Und gleichzeitig ist dann die interessante Frage, Moment mal, warum haben hier eigentlich bei den Mädchen in der Schule und im College, warum haben da nicht die klassischen in Anführungszeichen Sportarten profitiert? Also American Football, NHL, NBA und so weiter und so fort. Und tatsächlich gibt es dazu ganz gute Studien. Und das liegt daran, zum einen, weil Fußball ein Sport war, der als mediker maskulin konnotiert war und dementsprechend auch Eltern es gerne gesehen haben, dass ihre Kinder und ihre Töchter diesen Sport ausgeführt haben. Und dann war es tatsächlich auch so, zum einen dieses Feld war noch nicht besetzt. Du hast in den anderen genannten Sportarten hast du schon College-Programme und die hattest du bis dahin für Männer. Und wenn du jetzt aber schnell dir ein erfolgreiches Programm auferlegen wolltest, mit dem du auch dann ja eben dir gute Recruits ziehst, also neue Nachwuchs und das muss man ja auch dazu sagen, du kannst es vielleicht gleich noch kurz erklären, die Finanzierung von Colleges ist ja auch eine andere. Da ist es auch wichtig, dass man attraktiv ist für Eltern, dass man Erfolge hat. Es war eben einfacher im Fußball der Frauen solche Programme aufzusetzen. Und das führt dazu, also da gibt es auch verschiedene Stimmen dazu, die sagen, dass es fast so eine unbeabsichtigte Auswirkung dieser Gesetzesänderung war, dass eben gerade im Fußball der Frauen sich in dieser Phase von Anfang der 70er bis eigentlich heute, aber bis zu den 80ern haben sich schon sehr, sehr viele College-Programme nur für den Fußball der Frauen gegründet. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz großer Unterschied zu allem, was den Männerfußball in den USA betrifft. Kannst du uns noch vielleicht kurz mit ein paar Worten erklären, wie das an den High-Schools und Colleges so läuft?
Ja, also Nummer eins, die Verankerung von Sport in den Bildungseinrichtungen ist halt schon als Konzept seit über 100 Jahren da. Das heißt also Infrastruktur, Ideen müssen man den Leuten nicht erst verkaufen. Je nachdem, welche Schulen, gibt es verschiedene Spezialisierungsaspekte. Punkt zwei, als es darum ging, Title 9, wie wir das nennen, also 9 für 9, umzusetzen, ging es auch um die Frage, wie kann man am billigsten viele Beteiligte gewinnen, um diese Zahlen zu verschieben. Also eine richtige Gleichheit ist, glaube ich, heute noch nicht ganz erreicht. Es gibt immer noch Stellen, wo man nachbessern könnte, aber es hat sich also stark entwickelt. Es ging aber auch darum, zu zeigen, weil es gab Verpflichtungen, also da wurden Fristen gesetzt. Wann müssen Bildungseinrichtungen irgendwie dokumentieren, dass sie auch was gemacht haben? Ich dachte, es war nicht nur so, wir appellieren an euer gutes Gefühl. Also macht doch mal was für die Mädchen oder für die jungen Frauen. Und die Infrastruktur ist schnell da. Fußballfelder, kann man schnell mal Rasen mähen, alles abkreiden, Ball besorgen und so. Da kann man ruckzuck 20, 30 für eine Mannschaft oder auch für mehrere Mannschaften zusammenkriegen. Das hat sich auch im Basketball relativ gut entwickelt. Aber da natürlich hat man nicht, weil man ja nur fünf Spielerinnen hat, die gleichzeitig spielen können, hat man nicht so große Kader. Das hat sich auch inzwischen bei einigen Wintersportarten entwickelt. Eishockey ist ein gutes Stichwort, aber auch nur dort, wo Eishockey wirklich auch wiederum regional gespielt wird. Also das ging, das war der Brandbeschleuniger. Klar, es brauchte dazu die gesetzliche Idee. Und das über diese Schiene zu bringen. Klammer auf, da war aber kein Investor-Denken gefragt. Also natürlich muss man investieren in den Sport, damit er sich entwickelt. Aber nicht diese Leute mit Geld, die jetzt sagen, ich gehe da mit Geld rein und kriege dann hinterher irgendwann ganz viel Geld wieder raus. Das war eine wirklich politische Idee, die in den 60er Jahren über den aufkommenden, selbstbewussten Feminismus amerikanischer Prägung, der auch sehr pragmatisch, viel pragmatischer war, als jetzt, so wie ich das so aus Deutschland in Erinnerung habe, da ging es mehr um so eine ideologische, theoretische Fragestellung der Gleichberechtigung, Gleichbehandlung des Respekts und so weiter. Das war was für Akademiker im Grunde. Und die amerikanische Realität der 60er und 70er Jahre ist sehr viel bodenständiger, ist ja viel pragmatischer. Und da kommen natürlich sowohl Eltern als auch Lehrer und sonst welche Personen oder Lehrerinnen sind ja nun auch sehr stark vertreten im Schulbereich. Ich glaube, wir haben 60 Prozent oder so. Der Lehrer sind Lehrerinnen. Also das hilft da alles und da hat man dann die Zahlen relativ schnell und hat aber auch, glaube ich, beim beim Blick auf das, was da dann geboten wird, das Gefühl, ja das ist ja gar nicht, das ist ja nicht nur eine Beschäftigungstherapie oder irgendwie sowas, sondern es hat auch einen sportlichen, erzieherischen Wert. Ja und das ist das, was auch den Sport in den amerikanischen, Bildungswesen so relevant macht. Der erzieherische Wert von Sport, wo also Sport, als das in den Elite-Universitäten so vor 120 Jahren kultiviert wurde, in Yale und in Harvard, das war so die Kapitäne der Industrielandschaft von morgen ran zu ziehen. Also in diesen auch harten Sportarten, wie Football oder so, da lernt man alles Mögliche, was man später im beruflichen Alltag auch brauchen kann. Diese Idee hat sich sehr stark insgesamt im Sport ausgebreitet und wurde dann eben auch ohne Probleme auf die Frauen quasi ausgedehnt. Auf dem Motto, naja, Frauen, die kommen ja jetzt auch mit allen anderen Sachen hoch und so und so. Und dadurch gab es relativ wenig Widerstand. Also es gab Widerstand dieser alten American Football Trainer, die das Gefühl hatten, jetzt wird ihnen was weggenommen und Geld abgeschnitten und so weiter. Die haben unheimlich rumgekämpft und versucht, das zu untergraben. Aber nicht so die große amerikanische Öffentlichkeit, die also da einen Sympathie-Bonus auf diese neue Welt draufgeklebt hat und drauf geschickt hat. Und das, glaube ich, spielt eine Rolle, auch wenn zum Beispiel dann unter dem Dach des Verbandes, wo es dann um die Hochleistungsebene geht. Da braucht es natürlich dann noch wieder ganz andere Leute, die begreifen, dass das einen Stellenwert haben kann. Und die ersten Nationalmannschaftsteams, die so zu Olympischen Spielen und zu Fußball-Weltmeisterschaften fahren, die haben enorme Schwierigkeiten, wirtschaftlich oder auch sonst wie überhaupt irgendwie gefördert zu werden. Weil diese Ebene bleibt erst mal komplett ausgeblendet, als Title IX installiert wird.
Also das zeigt wieder ja, da wo die Verbände ins Spiel kommen und wie die Männer in den Verbänden ins Spiel kommen, da bewegt sich wenig. Da kommen wir gleich zu, ich möchte aber noch kurz diesen College- und Highschool-Aspekt fertig machen, weil das ist bis heute ein großer Unterschied des US-Fußballs zu vielen anderen Nationen, ja unter anderem auch zu Deutschland an den Highschools und in den Colleges. Da etabliert sich jetzt logischerweise auch eine Ligen- und Pokal-Wettbewerbsstruktur. Gleichzeitig haben wir feste Trainingsplätze, wir haben Orte für Training, wir haben das nötige Equipment, wir haben die entsprechenden Trainer und aus dieser Bewegung heraus fußt eine ganz breite Basis, auf der der Fußball der Frauen in den USA steht und ich denke, wir haben es jetzt gut genug hergeleitet, dass man auch versteht, warum das den Fußball der Männer nicht unbedingt in gleichermaßen betrifft. Und das drückt sich jetzt dann auch in Teams aus, die national eine Aufmerksamkeit bekommen. Also 1973 gründet Bill Keinder den Sting Soccer Club, beziehungsweise meistens ist dieses Team einfach als Sting bekannt, ist nicht der entsprechende Popkünstler, sondern ist dieses Team, das ist ein Highschool-Team für Spielerinnen unter 19 Jahren, die reisen 1976 als erstes Mädchen- oder Frauenfußballteam außerhalb, also das quasi so gilt als US-Nationalteam, auch wenn es noch keins ist, außerhalb der USA, spielen sie unter anderem gegen das Frauenteam Mexikos vor 35.000 ZuschauerInnen in Mexikostadt. 1977, einen Jahr später, nehmen sie auch an einem Turnier in Schweden teil und 1978 auch an dem Einladungsturnier, einem der taiwanesischen Einladungsturniere, da gibt es ja auch ein ganz wichtiges in der deutschen Historie des Fußballs der Frauen. Man kann es als WM bezeichnen, ist dann letztlich eine Definitionsfrage, wie man es nennen möchte. Aber das heißt, es gibt eben dieses Team getrieben vor allem von Bill Kinder und einigen Mitstreitern und die repräsentieren die USA, ohne dass der Verband dafür etwas tut. Der Verband möchte das auch nicht, der legt auch gerne mal Steine in den Weg, aber es findet eben statt und es findet eben statt mit jungen Spielerinnen, die alle in einer festen Struktur, die es bei den Männern nicht gibt, den Fußball lernen, erlernen und dann ja auch weiter betreiben, selbst Trainerinnen werden, selbst Spielerinnen werden. Und das führt eben dazu, dass diese Wurzel im College-Fußball, im Fußball der Frauen nicht wegzudenken ist. Also von 1991 bis 2015, wenn wir dann die erfolgreichen offiziellen Nationalteams der Frauen durchgehen, da hat fast jede Spielerin College-Erfahrung. Und das ist dann eher eine Ausnahme, so wie es in Deutschland so ist, dass ein Miro Klose noch ohne einen NSZ-Besuch zu haben, irgendwie im Nationalteam gelandet ist. Ähnliche Geschichten gibt es vereinzelt bei den US-Frauen auch. Also Lindsay Horan ist da zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel, dass sich da alle die Augen reiben und sagen, wie ist das überhaupt möglich, dass so jemand das dann trotzdem noch auf Nationalteam-Qualität schafft. Also sprich, die Basis an den Colleges, die ist sehr, sehr wichtig für den Fußball der Frauen und gleicht dann auch etwas aus, dass die Spielerinnen, die aus dem College-System herauskommen, dass die ja schon älter sind als europäische Spielerinnen. Also man ist so 22, 23, wenn man aus dem College herauskommt. Und wenn wir das vergleichen, wir sehen es ja in der Bundesliga der Frauen zum Beispiel, da laufen zum Teil 16-Jährige, hochtalentierte Spielerinnen herum oder 17-, 18-Jährige. Das ist ein großer Unterschied, aber dafür ist die Basis sehr viel breiter.
Also ich würde gerne an der Stelle darauf aufmerksam machen, während also diese Verzahnung mit dem Bildungswesen den Frauenfußball nach oben gebracht hat, ist genau das einer der Gründe, warum der amerikanische Männerfußball sich eben nicht wirklich entwickeln konnte. Weil ja, die amerikanischen Männerfußballer haben auch das Bildungsangebot im Auge gehabt, haben Stipendien und ähnliches im Auge gehabt, haben aber damit einen ganz wichtigen Teil ihrer eigenen, oder was die Eltern dann ja sicherlich auch immer mitbeurteilen, oder die Jugendtrainer beurteilen, einen Teil ihrer fußballerischen Entwicklung zu besseren Fußballern im Grunde verpasst. Weil ja, sie wurden sicherlich älter und immer besser, aber sie wurden nicht ausgereift besser, sie wurden nicht spezialisierter besser, sondern sie wurden zu diesen Konditionsbolzen hochgezüchtet, oder so, die halt 90 Minuten lang wirklich rennen können, auch mit ein bisschen Ball am Fuß oder so. Aber zum Beispiel die Entwicklung, die im Rest der Welt auf dem Fußballplatz durch die Arbeit von Trainern und die kreativen Ideen, die da ausgefiltert worden sind, die hat es hier quasi nicht gegeben. Und natürlich hatte auch am College kein Trainer irgendein Interesse daran mitzuarbeiten, weil das Interesse der College-Verantwortlichen, entweder die, die da was zu sagen haben oder auch der Trainer ist, dass sie gut abschneiden mit ihren Mannschaften im Vergleich mit anderen Colleges. Das heißt, wenn ich sowieso auf einem Level bin, das nicht richtig gut ist, dann ist auch egal, wie gut ich bin. Dann kann ich auch mal was gewinnen. Aber ich habe keinen Ehrgeiz, besser zu werden, weil ich sehe, die anderen werden auch alle besser. Oder die haben da Trainer, die neue Ideen ausprobieren und auch erfolgreich sind. Das ist ein Teil eines sehr verdeckten Problems des amerikanischen Fußballs. Das ist die Fußballspielkultur. Die Entwicklung, die woanders stattfindet, findet hier nicht statt. Und die wird übertünnt, je mehr man sich gute Spieler, ältere Veteranen reinholt. Die können das, was man heute braucht, weil das haben sie ja alles sich drauf geschafft. Aber die jungen Amerikaner haben das nicht. Und die haben das heute noch nicht. Das haben wir ja schon erwähnt, diese New York Times-Liste. Das ist der 100 besten Spieler der Welt. Und jemand wie Christian Pulisic ist ein Beispiel dafür, wie man eben nicht im System groß werden kann oder wahrscheinlich nicht wird. Weil der Vater schlau genug ist und weiß, was da heranführt an eine gewisse Klasse. Dafür sorgt, dass dieser Spieler null mit diesem etablierten System zu tun hat. Sondern er geht nach Borussia Dortmund. Und glaube ich, ist seine erste Station, wenn ich es richtig erinnere. Und da ist er glaube ich 60.
Aber ja, also er kommt auf jeden Fall nach Europa.
Und er ist noch ganz jung.
Ja, und das ist wirklich ein interessanter Aspekt, weil sich das bis heute durchzieht. Also zum Teil ist es ein Klischee über den US-Fußball. Eigentlich kann man sagen, egal ob Männer oder Frauen, bei den Frauen ist es aber dadurch, dass sie erfolgreicher waren als Nationalteam, da wird da, glaube ich, noch mehr darüber gesprochen. Aber es ist ein Klischee, das auf einer Wahrheit basiert, nämlich dass es vor allem eine athletische Überlegenheit ist, die dieses Team kennzeichnet und das sieht man auch immer mal wieder. Es gibt ja auch einzelne Spielerinnen, die von Colleges kommen und jetzt gerade in der Bundesliga spielen. Elegant Bone vom 1. FC Nürnberg ist da ein Beispiel. Physisch absolut eine der besten der Liga. Pässe in die Tiefe, not so much, würde ich sagen, da ist die Passquote sehr gering. Und das finde ich ist ein interessanter Aspekt, weil er basiert in diesem anderen Schulsystem, in dieser anderen Sportförderung im Detail und drückt sich aber letztlich bis heute aus. Und bei den Männern ist es sicherlich ein Hindernis. Bei den Frauen allerdings, und da kommen wir jetzt ja dann zum US-Nationalteam, da ist das ein wesentlicher Treiber dafür, dass letztlich auch der Verband irgendwann endlich mal erkennen muss, dass Fußball der Frauen eine Sache ist und dass man sie vielleicht unterstützen muss.
Also, obwohl das nicht nur eine Sache, Entschuldigung, sondern profitabel die Zuschauer, die bringen Geld rein und kommen an den Punkt, dass sie selber begreifen, wir müssen mal für uns hier was fordern, weil es nicht so ist, als würden wir hier durchgefüttert und nicht irgendwie am Katzentisch oder so, sondern wir sind Teil dieser Überlegung, ein Motor für die Förderung und den Ausbau von Fußball als Massensportart. Das haben die Amerikanerinnen auch, weil sie selber politisiert genug denken können, haben das eben dokumentiert. Und ich finde fast, die, die ein größtes Verdienst ist, gar nicht mal, dass sie irgendwas gewonnen haben, also auf dem Spielfeld, sondern dass sie das gewonnen haben. Diesen Wettkampf, wo man auch wieder Männern was wegnehmen muss, weil die Männer kriegen aus dem FIFA-Topf irgendwie ganz viel Geld und dann sitzen da irgendwelche Leute im Verband, die sagen, na ja, aber die Männer haben das ja mitgebracht. Dann können wir das ja jetzt nicht den Frauen geben oder so. Da brauchst du halt Frauen, die sagen, na ja, wissen wir mal, wisst ihr eigentlich, warum wir weniger Geld kriegen? Weil die FIFA ein derartig antiquiertes Konzept davon hat, wie man das Geld, was insgesamt erwirtschaftet wird, dann bezogen auf die Definition Spielerinnen oder Spieler verteilt. Und da haben die sich aber, die haben das erreicht. Und da würde ich gerne eine Kerze zünden für so viel Sinn, für selbst und für die, die danach kommen. Was auch wieder treiber werden können für eine Weiterentwicklung von Sport, von Kultur, von Gesellschaft, die wir, wenn wir uns mit der Geschichte beschäftigen und den hundert Jahren vorher, da gab es all dieses Denken ja noch nicht mal oder diese Sensibilität.
Im Gegenteil sogar.
Also, ich denke mal, reden wir weiter.
Man würde ja sagen, es ist traurig genug, dass man ein ökonomisches Argument machen muss, um eine Daseinsberechtigung für Sport den Frauen ausüben schaffen zu müssen. Aber selbst wenn wir mal kurz akzeptieren, okay, das ist unsere kapitalistische Welt und da wird eben alles aus einer ökonomischen Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung geprägt, selbst dann ist es absurd, weil auch der ökonomische Nutzen nicht ausgereicht hat für Frauen, um ihren Sport betreiben zu dürfen. Ich habe hier vor einigen Monaten eine Folge gemacht über den wirklich tollen Film Copa 71, in dem geht es um die inoffizielle WM der Frauen in Mexiko und das war ein kommerzieller Erfolg. Das war mit allen, nach allen Kategorien, war das ein sehr, sehr erfolgreiches Turnier und diese Frauen, die in einer anderen Welt aufgetaucht sind, als sie in Mexiko gelandet sind und dann wieder zurück mussten, muss man in dem Sinne fast schon sagen, in ihre Heimatländer, die wurden verspottet, die wurden beschimpft, sie wurden als Schande behandelt, haben zum Teil Traumata davon erlitten und das, obwohl es ein nicht nur sportlich interessanter und toller Wettbewerb war, sondern auch kommerziell. Das heißt, selbst wenn Frauen ökonomisch erfolgreich sind, wird ihnen der Platz nicht gegönnt. Also das wollte ich jetzt noch mal unterstreichen, dass es nicht mal das reicht, um eine Daseinsberechtigung zu bekommen. Ich werde es verlinken in den Shownutz, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, könnt ihr vielleicht nach dieser Sendung anhören. Und auch wenn wir uns die Genese des deutschen, des deutschen, des US-Frauen Nationalteams ansehen, dann sehen wir da auch wieder einen Verband, der es einfach nicht gecheckt hat. Das Nationalteam wird mehr oder weniger zufällig gegründet und es hält sich hartnäckig das Gerücht, der Verband hätte damals vor allem eine Klage verhindern wollen, denn das noch nicht entstandene US-Nationalteam wird zu einem Turnier in Italien eingeladen. Da reagiert dann der Verband darauf, indem er tatsächlich händisch Spielerinnen aus verschiedenen einzelnen Teams zusammenpackt und sie nach Italien schickt. Die Spielerinnen erhalten keine Gehälter und bekommen 10 Dollar pro Tag Essensbeihilfe. Da hat sich der US-Fußballverband wirklich übertroffen, aber das ist tatsächlich die Geburtsstunde des US-Frauen-Nationalteams. 1986 wird dann Anson Dorrance Trainer, der wirklich prägend wird. Er verändert nämlich auch so ein bisschen die Nominierungspolitik. Er ist der erste, also von erst zwei Bundestrainer muss man an der Stelle sagen, der dann auch Spielerinnen eine Chance gibt, die noch im Teenager-Alter sind, also unter College-Level. Er war ein sehr erfolgreicher Trainer am College im Fußball der Frauen, aber z.B. Mia Hamm, Julie Foddy oder Christine Lilly, die bekommen jetzt Einsatzchancen und er etabliert jetzt sämtliche Strukturen, die man in einem Nationalteam braucht. Training, Trainingskultur, Scouting und hat auch mit Michelle Aykers eine Spielerin aus dem 85er-Team mit dabei, die eine Ikone des US-Sports wird und unter anderem 1991 bei der ersten offiziellen Weltmeisterschaft. Es gab vorher schon Weltmeisterschaften, aber nicht von der FIFA anerkannt und durchgeführt. Die findet in China statt, über die haben wir vorhin schon kurz gesprochen. Und da ist es eben jene Michelle Aykers, die mit zwei Toren im Finale erfolgreich bestreitet. Die USA werden Weltmeisterinnen, sie gewinnt auch den Goldenen Schuh als beste Torschützin des Turniers. Und das, Jürgen, ist jetzt so ein Muster. Also ich werde jetzt noch, also ein paar der Erfolge werde ich schon noch nennen. Es ist aber Erfolg um Erfolg um Erfolg, den das US Frauen Nationalteam sich erspielt und damit eben auch Aufmerksamkeit bekommt. Kannst du das an etwas festmachen, woran das liegt, dass es ganz lange so ist, wir werden später auch noch über die Liga sprechen dann der Frauen, warum es ganz lange so ist, dass nur diese nationalen Erfolge bei irgendwelchen Turnieren, Aufmerksamkeit und damit auch Umsätze und Erlöse generieren und das aber auf einer kleineren granularen Ebene, nämlich auf Vereinsebene nicht funktioniert?
Es klingt für mich an dem Punkt an, dass Nationalmannschaftsdenken ist in den USA nicht wirklich so stark ausgeprägt, wie in diesem von mehreren Weltkriegen überzogenen Europa und der tribalen Definition von, wo komme ich her, wo gehöre ich hin. Nur bei Olympischen Spielen, das haben wir ja vorhin schon mal kurz drauf gehabt, ist das mehr ausgeprägter. Da gibt es die Hymne nach der Siegerehrung und da will man natürlich, dass ein Amerikaner auch immer auf dem Treppchen steht und so. Und da werden auch Medaillen gezählt. Und da spielt das im Sport eine gewisse Rolle. Die anderen Sportarten sind ja nun auch, also American Football ist ein klassisches Beispiel, oder auch Baseball im Grunde. Das sind rein amerikanische Sportarten. Die werden dann zu Weltmeistern erklärt, wenn sie da was holen oder gewinnen, die World Series. Aber das ist eine Anmaßung der Sonderklasse. Und im Grunde weiß das auch jeder hier in dem Land, dass man nicht gegen Japaner und sonstwie diesen Titel geholt hat, sondern in einem internen amerikanischen Wettbewerb. Also ich würde mal sagen, da ist so eine Art Vakuum vorhanden. Nicht, dass sich also jedes Vakuum mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit füllt, wenn du dann die Tür aufmachst oder so. Vielleicht füllt sich dieses Vakuum nur sehr langsam. Vielleicht wäre das auch dann kein Vakuum, sondern mehr, wenn wir aus der Art und Weise, wie Wasser geleitet wird, eine Schleuse aufmachen oder so. Und das geht den Berg, das Wasser fließt den Berg runter. Also das ist für mich der Ausgangspunkt. Der andere ist aber, und da springe ich ein bisschen raus aus deiner Frage, man kann anhand der Tatsache, dass jetzt andere Mannschaften die Amerikaner wegputzen können. Und das meine ich nicht mal die Deutschen, die also schon auch traditionell länger ganz ordentlich daran arbeiten, richtig gute Talente zu entwickeln. Da meine ich die Spanier, die quasi aus dem Nichts, oder Spanierinnen, die quasi aus dem Nichts kommen. Die Franzosen, die jetzt Französinnen, die jetzt natürlich mithalten können. Die Italienerinnen haben auch einen guten Eindruck gemacht. Ich meine die Schweden und so. Also jetzt auch die Engländerinnen auch nicht zu vergessen. Also die nicht mit diesem gleichen Basismaterial arbeiten können, um Talente zu fördern, zu entdecken und dann zu guten Nationalmannschaften, die mit sehr viel weniger auskommen müssen. Also Talentepool oder so. Und da siehst du, das Amerikanerinnen-Spiel ist im Grunde auch stehen geblieben. Das siehst du schon bei der Ballbehandlung, das siehst du schon bei allen möglichen Details. Die hatten immer ganz gute Torfrauen, aber die haben sich auch nicht weiterentwickelt. Dieser Teil des Spiels, den ich nenne mal, wo man erkennen kann, können die antizipatorisch mit dem umgehen, was da jetzt passiert oder so. Der ist hier stehen geblieben. Das hat sich jetzt ein bisschen wieder gesteigert. Die haben ja auch begriffen, dass sie nachlegen müssen oder so. Aber das nehme ich mal als Beispiel dafür, wie diese Struktur gleichzeitig, während sie was Gutes leistet, gleichzeitig aber auch auf der Stelle tritt und dann nicht an dem Prozess beteiligt ist, in dem Fußball kultiviert und verfeinert und verbessert wird. Und da siehst du aus meiner Sicht wiederum eine Grundschwäche im Verständnis von dieser Sportart in diesem Land. Also bis da mal Leute wach werden und sagen, hier kommt da keiner drauf. Und ich meine, gibt es irgendeinen Trainer aus den USA, dessen Namen du eigentlich schon mal gehört hast, also ja, das ist gerade Anson Doran erwähnt. Der bekannteste Trainer ist Jesse Marsh. Und der hat schon in Europa nicht viel auf die Beine gekriegt. Und jetzt kommt er mit Kanada eine schwierige Aufgabe. Aber das gehört ja auch zum Fußball. Wir fokussieren uns immer auf die Müllers, die Messies und so weiter. Da gibt es ja noch Leute dahinter, die eine ganz wichtige Rolle spielen als Laboratoriums-Doktoren und als Leute, die was umsetzen, die mit Persönlichkeitsfragen umgehen können. Und Mannschaften-Formen und Spielstil und so. Das ist ein weiteres Teil des Problems. Das müssen wir heute gar nicht analysieren. Also das liegt im Argen.
Es ist ja auch relativ auf der Hand. Also es steht und fällt mit den TrainerInnen. Und da hast du, also ich denke die bekannteste ist Jill Ellis, beim US-Frauen-Nationalteam. Und Jill Ellis steht nicht für eine Spielphilosophie. Muss man aber auch nicht als Trainerin. Man kann auch über andere Komponenten eine Gruppe führen und zu Erfolgen führen. Denn das hat sie gemacht wie eigentlich keine zweite. Und das ist ja interessant, wenn man sich zum Beispiel den relativ kurzen und dann doch sehr unglücklichen Stint von Jürgen Klinsmann als Nationaltrainer der Männer ansieht, dann war das etwas, über das hat er vom Beginn an geredet, dass er bessere Trainer ausbilden möchte, dass er helfen möchte, dass man Standards etabliert, damit die Trainer besser werden und das dann von der Basis aus eben Fußballspieler irgendwann auch im Leistungssport ankommen, die über ein anderes Repertoire verfügen. Und das ist jetzt ein bisschen ungerecht, weil wir scheren dann natürlich viele Spielerinnen und Spieler über einen Kamm. Also als du so über die US-Frauen gesprochen hast, ich meine ja, die sind im Achtelfinale der letzten WM ausgeschieden, aber in einem Elfmeterschießen gegen Schweden, da ging es wirklich um Millimeter, dass man da nicht weiter gekommen ist. Also ja, die liegen sportlich gerade, am Boden ist zu viel, aber sie sind eben nicht mehr so wahnsinnig erfolgreich wie früher. Aber auch da gibt es fantastische Technikerinnen, auch da gibt es Strategien des Spiels, auch da gibt es Spielerinnen, die sehr, sehr gut im Antizipieren von Spielsituationen sind. Aber in der Summe ist es dann dennoch ein Trend, der sich bei beiden Nationalteams, sowohl der Männer als auch der Frauen, erstmal noch deutlicher zeigt, eben, dass es viel über Physik geht, dass es viel auch über Athletik geht. Also wenn man sich die Einwechsespieler bei den US-Männern anguckt, die haben ganz oft, als sie noch Pflichtspieler hatten vor dieser WM, ihre Spiele dann gewonnen, wenn die reinkamen und die Gegner schon ein bisschen müde waren. Aber das ist eben nur über Trainer tatsächlich zu lösen, weil die formen die Spielerinnen. Und wenn wir uns jetzt angucken, dass ja viele aus dieser erfolgreichen Generation später dann auch mal Trainerinnen werden an irgendwelchen Colleges oder jetzt dann in Teams, die in der NWSL spielen, über die wir später noch sprechen werden, dann ist es ja auch völlig klar, die werden nicht einen Kulturwandel weitergeben. Da brauchst du dann jemanden wie San Diego Wave. Die holen sich da einen Trainer, der war früher bei Arsenal. Der holt sich unter anderem eine Anja Mittag. Und dann können so externe Einflüsse vielleicht auch etwas verändern. Deswegen, es ist so ein bisschen grobschlechtig, wie wir über das Thema sprechen. Ich wollte ein bisschen Differenzierung reinbringen. In Summe gebe ich dir aber trotzdem Recht, ehrlicherweise.
Ich habe ja auch gesagt, der gegenwärtige Stand ist wieder ein anderer als das, was mir so aufgefallen ist. Also, was, als man merken konnte, das waren ja auch die Japanerinnen zum Beispiel, als man merken konnte, dass in anderen Ländern auch Frauenfußball reüssiert und mit wie wenigen Mitteln das gelingt in diesen Situationen. Männerfußball ist für mich immer Island das Beispiel. Ich meine, wie viele Isländer, also Männer, spielen Fußball, ich weiß nicht, 10.000 vielleicht, 15.000, in der Altersgruppe, die da relevant ist. Und die können dann plötzlich auf, nicht immer, aber können eine Mannschaft zusammenbringen, die im Weltrahmen auf jeden Fall Beachtung findet. Und vergleich das mit den Millionen Talenten, die theoretisch in den USA zur Verfügung stehen.
Das stimmt natürlich, ja.
Ja, also diese Pyramide nennt man das ja, glaube ich. Also diese Leistungspyramide, die sieht Tanebüchen aus, wenn man weiß, wo die anfangen.
Und gleichzeitig ist es natürlich...
Die könnte beim Lotto mehr gewinnen, wenn sie da, also wenn sie einfach Leute früh genug rausnehmen würden und nach Barcelona oder nach Amsterdam schnitten oder so. Die müssten gar nicht noch nach irgendwelchen DDR-Sport-medizinischen Kriterien die bestmöglichen Talente im Alter von acht oder so rausfiltern. Die könnten wirklich sagen, ich nehme dich und dich und dich. Und ich bin sicher, die hätten eine bessere nationale Mannschaft am Ende. Aber das ist jetzt Spekulation, wird nie stattfinden. Und ich wollte einen Witz machen.
Ja, könnte man dann ja auch sehr zu Chinas Versuch, im Fußball der Frauen weltführend zu werden, was ja zwischenzeitlich auch mal erfolgreich war, könnte man da Parallelen ziehen. Aber ich glaube, einer der wesentlichen Faktoren, warum da auch erst jetzt aktuell unter Emma Hayes, der neuen US-Nationaltrainerin, so manches ins Rollen kommt, ist eben der Erfolg der vergangenen Teams. Also, weil der ist ja irre. Wir haben eben 91 die WM, die gewonnen wird. 96 holt man Olympisches Gold im Finale von Atlanta vor fast 80.000 ZuschauerInnen. Und die WM 99 ist ein Abstand. Absoluter Wendepunkt. Wir werden gleich noch mal drüber sprechen. Die ganze Generation, Brandi Chastain haben wir gehört, die hat im Elfmeterschießen damals das entscheidende Tor geschossen. Mia Hamm ist ein Weltstar. Das hat man auch hier in Europa damals schon mitbekommen. Und allein seit 99 hat das US-Nationalteam noch mal viermal olympisches Gold geholt und 2015 und 2019 die Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen. Und ich sag's mal so, wenn du so erfolgreich bist, dann ist es ja auch extrem schwierig, mögliche Defizite wenn sie denn da wären zu erkennen und zu adressieren. Das ist vielleicht dann tatsächlich erst möglich, wenn du halt dann mal auch durchaus ein bisschen unglücklich gegen Schweden im Achtelfinale ausscheidest. Das war nicht bei der letzten WM der Fall. Und da war dann das Entsetzen groß. Und dann haben erste Änderungen eingesetzt. Also was ich damit sagen will, ist, die waren glaube ich auch zu erfolgreich, als dass man da an diese Struktur hätte rangehen können.
Und noch was anderes, weil die Kinderkrankheiten im Aufbau einer amerikanischen Frauenfußball-Profiliga, die ja nun zweimal in eine Pleite geführt hat, wenn auch relativ schnell das auch immer geklärt war, das haut hier nicht hin. Aber die Stabilisierung, die da dann stattgefunden hat und die auch jetzt mit positiven Anzeichen weitergeht, also die Zuschauerzahlen dort sind gut, die Fernsehgeld-Situation ist aspektabel, also da kann man auch, glaube ich, einiges wieder erkennen. Also da wird ja schon vieles auf einem höheren Niveau präsentiert. Also die einzelnen Spielerinnen können sich zeigen und können einen Nationaltrainer oder Nationaltrainerinnen schon leichter machen. Weil, wenn das eine Bastelarbeit für den Nationaltrainer oder Nationaltrainerin wird, ich habe hier so viele Leute und ich brauche jetzt hier Holzschnitt, muss ich mit der Holzsäge irgendwie noch ein bisschen rumbasteln oder so. Das ist auch zu spät. Das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum Klinsmann nicht klargekommen ist. Weil er ist nun kein genialer spieltaktischer Influencer oder so. Der sagt den Leuten irgendwie, du spielst heute. Und dann macht ihr mal untereinander aus, wie das am besten geht. Das reicht dann nicht auf dem Level. Das kannst du ja auch schon bei deinen 8- oder 10-Jährigen in der F-Jugend erkennen. Wenn du es nicht schaffst, da ein bisschen reinzusortieren, machen die was sie wollen. Und das haut nicht richtig hin.
Ja, das ist ja auch, wenn man sich mit der Zeit von Jill Ellis als Nationaltrainerin befasst. So erfolgreich ist sie auch wahr. Da geht es dann auch im Detail um solche Themen. Also Fußballlehrerin kann man sein, indem man, also Lehrerinnen sind ja auch so. Sportlehrer kann auch einfach nur einen Ball in die mitschmeißen und sagen, spielt und der Mathematiklehrer oder die Lehrerin, die müssen dann doch noch mal ein bisschen anders pädagogisch vorgehen, um ihren Stoff an den Mann und die Frau zu bringen. Aber ich würde vorschlagen, wir sind damit ja eigentlich schon im Thema der Frauenliga gelandet. Dann lasst doch damit noch weitermachen. Da landen wir dann auch schon relativ bald, nämlich in der Gegenwart. Es ist tatsächlich diese WM 99, die einen unheimlichen Boom auslöst. Der wird dann auch zur Gründung der ersten US-Frauenprofiliga führen. Vielleicht, damit wir da nicht so drüber gehen, weil 99 ist wirklich, ich glaube auch gesamthistorisch, nicht nur sporthistorisch für die USA ein Wendepunkt. Magst du uns dazu noch zwei, drei Worte sagen? Du hast ja dann auch schon in den USA gelebt. Wie hast denn du dieses Turnier erlebt?
Naja, ich habe all das, was du jetzt schon gesagt hast, so wahrgenommen in der Jetzt-Zeit und dazu gehört natürlich auch. Ich bin ja im Grunde auch immer so ein bisschen eine Antenne für das Interesse, das aus Europa dann rüberkommt. Also wenn du einen Auftrag kriegst als Journalist, dann schreib doch mal bitte darüber. Das heißt ja, dass die Kollegen da hinten irgendwo in Frankfurt oder in Zürich, oder wo die auch immer sitzen, dass sie auch schon mal irgendwie darüber nachgedacht haben. Guck mal hier, was ist denn hier los? Also diese Entwicklung kriegt man schon mit. Also ich habe jetzt gerade noch mal nachgedacht. Also als ich im Trainingslager der Fußballerinnen war in Orlando, das war vor der WM 95. Das war noch ein sehr exotisches Thema. Ich habe damals auch mit den allen, denen ich reden wollte, reden können. Michel Akers und Mia Hamm und so weiter. Also es war wunderbar. Die waren sehr medienoffen. Die freuten sich, dass jemand kam. Und das hat sich eben 99 dann hochgeschaut gekristallisiert. Und hier auch, weil da gibt es immer so Unterstützungsphänomene. Also wenn dann plötzlich eine Firma, ich glaube, es war in dem Fall eine Getränkefirma, Gatorade oder so, Michael Jordan und Mia Hamm in einen Commercial rein stellt und daraus noch das auf der Basis eines Musical Titels läuft. Alles, was ich kann, ist das My Fair Lady oder was, das kann ich besser. Ja, könntest du eventuell, wenn du Lust hast, hier noch kurz rein spulen. Also musst du mal schauen.
Ich versuche mal, ich weiß nicht, ob das Gamer-konform ist.
I Can Do Better ist der original Song, den sie da singen, also, ne? Und da gibt es so diesen gespielten Wettbewerb zwischen Michael Jordan und Mia Hamm. Also da wird diese Ableger von, diese Entwicklung von amerikanischen Sport wird eben ernster genommen, weil sie kommerziell auch deutlicher wird. Und die Gründung der ersten Variante der Liga wirkte auch sehr solide. Also die haben, glaube ich, ein Gesamtbudget von 50 Millionen auf eine bestimmte Frist zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen. Und haben dann vielleicht auch, weil die haben später sehr viel stärker angefangen zu sparen, nicht richtig aufgepasst, was die Kostenseite anging. Vielleicht haben sie sich ein bisschen zu gut gefühlt und auch das Gefühl gehabt, okay, wir haben ja einigermaßen Stadien, also es waren kleinere, aber die hatten Kapazität. Sie haben auch namhafte Spielerinnen aus Deutschland geholt. Und also auch gleich gezeigt, ja wir oder Marta, die berühmte Brasilianerin hat auch gleich mitgemacht, gezeigt, wir nehmen das ja ernst, das ist uns wichtig. Aber da ist wieder noch so viel Entwicklungshilfe notwendig im Kultivieren des Publikums. Und da ist so ein Punkt ein Thema, welche Menschen schauen sich warum Frauen-Sport an? Und in Europa weiß man, das sind hauptsächlich Männer gewesen, die mit einem gönnerhaften Blick, weil die sind vorprogrammiert, Sportinteressiert. Und ich habe mit dem späteren Besitzer von diesem New Yorker Team, das jetzt Gotham FC heißt, mal gesprochen, einem Deutschen, der da Geld reingesteckt hat, der hatte drei Töchter, die alle Fußball spielten. Und er hat mitgekriegt, dass die sich überhaupt nicht für seine Liga interessierten. Die waren gut, die gingen zu Camps, die wollten auch was werden, vielleicht ein Stipendium kriegen und so. Aber die machten Fußball, betrachteten oder bespielten Fußball, als ihr eigenes Gruppenpsychologisches Konzept. Die waren aktiv, die wollten mit anderen Mädchen zusammen sein und was machen und gut sein und Spaß haben. Die waren nicht an dem Punkt sozialisiert, dass sie sich dafür interessierten, dass irgendwelche Fremden im Fernsehen da auftauchten und irgendwas machten, außer vielleicht bei den Olympischen Spielen oder so. Wenn du dieses Publikum nicht ranziehen kannst, dann hast du wieder einen Webfehler. Und wie machst du das? Ich habe keinen Tipp. Aber wie machst du das, dass du dieses Reservoir kultivierst? Und das ist jetzt, glaube ich, im Männerfußball auf jeden Fall geklärt. Das heißt, gelungen haben wir ja schon darüber gesprochen. Teilweise Premier League, andere Sachen. Und im Frauenfußball zeigt sich bei dem, wie diese Profi-Teams abstrahlen, was sie machen, was sie für Aktivitäten, wie sie auch Sport mit anderen Engagements verknüpfen, wie sie dich definieren. Also Los Angeles haben die da unheimlich gut mit angefangen, mit Angel FT. Da waren aber auch wieder Hollywood-Leute und Leute mit Sinn für Marketing und sonst was. Das war mit im Boot, da tut sich jetzt gerade was. Und das wäre ohne 99 alles überhaupt nichts. Aber es ist dann wiederum doch auch ein Testament für, wie langsam dann etwas auf die Beine gestellt wird, was ja dauerhaft sein kann.
Ja, vor allem, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob man nicht in der Nachbetrachtung zu dem Schluss kommen kann auch, dass der Erfolg des 99er Turniers ein Segen war, ein Fluch war auf der neu gegründeten Liga. Also das 99er Turnier, das war in allen Bereichen ein absoluter Wendepunkt. Es gab fantastische Einscheidquoten. Das Finale damals haben allein in den USA 40 Millionen Zuschauerinnen gesehen. Dieser Wert wurde von einem WM-Finale erst 2014 bei den Männern überboten. Das war ganz, ganz lange der Bestwert. Man hatte einen Zuschauer in den Schnitt von 37.000. Man hat bei einem Budget von 30 Millionen US-Dollarn 4 Millionen Dollar Gewinn gemacht. Das war auch das erste Turnier von Frauen, das einen Ertrag gebracht hat für diejenigen, die ihn veranstaltet haben. Und ich glaube, das hat dazu geführt, dass dann angesichts dieses Erfolgs, plus eben die Spielerinnen wurden zum Teil zu Popstars, die sind in Late-Night-Shows aufgetreten, Mia Hamm und Michael Jordan und so weiter und so fort, dass man glaube ich das Interesse an einer Liga grandios überschätzt hat. Also man hat 2001 dann die Women's United Soccer Association, also die WUSA, gegründet. Da waren 20 Nationalspielerinnen waren unter anderem dran beteiligt, plus eben der Discovery Channel, der auch gleich mit übertragen wollte. Und man hatte eben dieses Budget von 40 bis 50 Millionen US-Dollar. Das sollte auf fünf Jahre hin die Liga finanzieren. Und nach einem Jahr war das komplette Geld weg. Denn der Zuschauer-Innenschnitt, der lag bei 8000. Und der TV-Vertrag, den man hatte, der war zwar gut, aber die Sponsoren und so weiter, die waren alle unzufrieden. Denn das Interesse, das man antizipiert hat, wegen eben dieses tollen Turniers 99, das war nicht da. Und das führt dazu, dass diese Liga innerhalb kürzester Zeit auch unterstützt, muss man sagen. Man darf den 11. September 2001 da nicht rausrechnen. Da sind auch generell, da werden wir später bei MLS auch nochmal drüber sprechen. Werbegelder waren da auch nochmal schwieriger zu generieren. Aber 2003, im September, da ist diese Liga schon pleite und hat im Gegenteil sogar noch Schulden aufgebaut, die eben jetzt getragen werden mussten, dann im Nachhinein von den ganzen Investorinnen und Investoren. Und das, glaube ich, war auch eine Folge des Erfolgs dieser WM. Und da sich das jetzt auch nochmal wiederholen wird, ist das so ein bisschen das Damokless-Schwert, das immer über der Frauenliga im Fußball in den USA schwebt. Ich meine, wir zwei haben da auch schon drüber gesprochen, als wir die letzte Sendung zur NWSL hatten. Kann das dann diesmal nachhaltig sein, denn wir werden gleich noch über den zweiten Versuch sprechen, der auch in 100 Millionen Schulden geendet ist. Das finde ich interessant, weil ich festgestellt habe, als ich noch mal recherchiert habe, in den US-amerikanischen Quellen, zumindest in denen, die ich gelesen habe, da wird dieses Turnier 99 immer noch nur großartig beschrieben. Und diesen Zusammenhang, der aber für mich relativ klar ist, dass man auch deshalb die Liga überschätzt hat, weil dieses Turnier so groß war, das habe ich ehrlicherweise nur in europäischen Quellen gelesen und nicht in US-Amerikanischen. Kann natürlich aber auch sein, dass ich jetzt, ich habe jetzt hier nicht alles ausrecherchiert, dass ich da einfach nur ein bisschen kurzsichtig war. Aber wie würdest du das denn als jemand beurteilen, der viel näher bei diesen Prozessen mit dabei war?
Ja, so viel näher ja auch nicht. Ich meine, es ist ein riesiges Land und bis auf die paar Gelegenheiten, von denen ich ja auch schon gesprochen habe, habe ich natürlich auch nicht die Möglichkeit immer nachzufassen und auch nicht das Interesse zu Hause in Deutschland, an dem, was man da ausfindig machen kann. Also ich glaube, du bist da auch ein sehr herausragender Fall. Deine Interessenslage, dein Informationsstand, dein Wissen und deine Einschätzung, das ist nicht der Standard in der Rasenfunk. Das ist ja auch eben ein wichtiger Teil der gesamten Informations-Fußball-Informationswelt. Also ich war nicht so nah dran. Ich habe nur das Gefühl gehabt, dass die Amerikaner lernen, das ist sehr pauschal, die Amerikaner lernen sehr ungern aus der Geschichte und sie lernen sehr ungern aus anderen Ländern. Das ist irgendwie so, als möchte jeder das Rad neu erfinden. Und dann, wenn das nicht klappt, dann hat es halt Geld gekostet oder Energie oder so. Aber wir nennen das ja diese Can-do-Mentalität. Ich kann das hinkriegen oder so. Das ist bescheuert. Das gilt für alle möglichen gesellschaftlichen Bereiche hier. Das herausragendste Beispiel für mich ist medizinische Versorgung und das Gesundheitswesen. Das kostet pro Kopf doppelt so viel wie jedes andere Land im Rest der Welt und hat keine besseren statistischen Gesamtresultate, wenn es um Lebenserwartung oder andere Parameter geht. Die könnten studieren. In jedem anderen Land der Welt gibt es für das Gesundheitswesen. Die könnten jede Menge lernen und das Beste herausziehen. Nein, das machen sie nicht. Also das gehört für mich zu den, sagen wir mal, sehr grundsätzlichen Eindrücken von dem, wie hier Dinge laufen. Und eine Lektion, die man hätte lernen können, beim amerikanischen Frauenfußball mit einer Liga, sich anzugucken, wie lange die National Hockey League mit nur sechs Teams gespielt hat, mehrere Jahrzehnte, ja, die Original Six und die saßen in Montreal, Toronto, New York, Chicago, Detroit und Boston. Und das war es, als das so sich entwickelte in einer etwas andere Zeit. Da gab es noch nicht so viele Flugzeuge, mit denen man überall rumfliegen konnte. Man musste noch mit der Eisenbahn und sonst wie. Also eine gewisse Nähe der Teams zueinander, geografisch macht Sinn. Aber es waren auch Teams in den größten, wirtschaftlich auch attraktivsten Städten. Detroit hat man heute ein anderes Bild davon, weil die Stadt ist natürlich ziemlich runtergekommen. Aber Detroit war in den 60er Jahren eine der Maschinenräume des amerikanischen Wirtschaftswesens und die haben sich sogar mal für die Olympischen Spiele beworben und hätten das auch gestemmt, wenn sie das bekommen hätten. Also diese Lektionen von anderen, die werden hier nicht gerne beachtet und dann kommt die NHL irgendwann an den Punkt, dass das vielleicht jetzt interessanter wird und dann bauen sie so langsam an. Aber erst nach Jahrzehnten, okay. Muss man heute nicht unbedingt ähnlich machen. Oder auch dieses gesamte System, kein Aufstieg, kein Abstieg, was von Fußballgefällen in diesem Land gehasst wird. Weil es ist ein Teil, ein Konzept, das Wettbewerb im Grunde nivelliert und wegbringt. Das heißt, ein Motivationsaspekt von Wettbewerb und Kampf um Erfolg wird einfach weggedaddelt. Denn das braucht es nicht. Auch das könnte in einer frühen Phase eine Alternative sein. Wir bauen nicht einfach nur horizontal, wir bauen vertikal. Und gucken mal, was für einen Fahrstuhl wir hier bauen können. Das fehlt alles, weil man mit anderen Überlegungen unterwegs ist. Und das sind meine sehr generellen und distanzierten Betrachtungen zu dem Problemfeld. Weil jedes andere hat damit zu tun. Ja, da wurden Entscheidungen getroffen, da gab es Leute, die hatten was zu sagen, da gab es Leute, die haben Geld reingesteckt, da fehlten aber dies oder das oder das. Das ist ja leicht nachzuzeichnen, aber das Innere, das Wesentliche, glaube ich, liegt eben in so einer Verfasstheit. Und das, da komme ich immer gerne auf Jean Baudrillard zu sprechen, der ein wunderbares Buch von Amerika geschrieben hat vor vielen Jahren. Die Amerikaner leben eine Gesellschaft, die ist simuliert. Das heißt, die Annäherung an das, was sie machen, ist über das Verständnis von, wie simuliere ich am besten Fußball, wie simuliere ich am besten gesellschaftliches Leben. Baudrillard hat nicht in allem recht oder so. Und ich sowieso nicht. Aber das ist für mich eine wesentliche Inspirationsquelle geworden, dafür, um zu verstehen, was in Amerika eigentlich los ist. In Amerika ist eben Disney los. Wäre das so das Urbeispiel für Simulation von Entertainment von, weiß ich nicht, Spaß haben, Leben oder so. Oder Hollywood als Filmfabrik. Das kann man in Amerika machen. Die Simulation von Realität auf der Kinoleinwand. Möglichst echt vielleicht sogar. Und ich glaube, da mussten wir heute nicht hin. Aber da kommt man irgendwann an, wenn man so lange in einem Land wie ich jetzt hier in Amerika. Und ich weiß nicht, ob dir das jetzt nützt.
Zurückgeführt auf den Sport, zeigt das ja auch. Und das klingt jetzt wie ein Vorwurf. Ich will es aber nicht als Vorwurf verstanden wissen. Sowohl bei den Männern als auch bei den Frauen haben sich die Ligen gegründet, mit dem Ziel, Geld zu verdienen, weil man das Gefühl hatte, hier ist noch Geld zu holen. Und wie gesagt, ich meine das nicht als Vorwurf, denn wir leben in einer kapitalistischen Welt. Und es wäre völlig irre zu glauben, dass das im europäischen Fußball zum Beispiel nicht genauso wäre. Nur die Geschichte und die Rolle, die der Fußball in Europa gespielt hat, die ist eben eine andere und die war eine andere. Das heißt, hier haben sich auch die Bundesliga, die haben auch vorher schon gut Geld verdient und die haben dann auch eine Bundesliga gut Geld verdient, auch wenn sie so getan haben, als würden sie alle sich nur ein Minimumgehalt bezahlen und so weiter und so fort. Aber der erste FC Kaiserslautern, der war eben erst mal da und hat damals schon ein regionales Interesse gehabt und dann wurde er Teil einer Liga und konnte dann versuchen, in dieser Liga mitzuwachsen. Und es gibt ja verschiedene Beispiele, die jetzt gerade Insolvenzantrag angemeldet haben, waren ja auch Bundesliga-Gründungsmitglied bei den Männern. Es gibt verschiedene Beispiele auch von Vereinen, die auf der Strecke liegen geblieben sind. Aber das ist halt dann schon, scheint mir, ein elementarer Unterschied zu sein zu den Gründungsmythen und zu den Gründen für die Gründungen der Ligen im Fußball, sowohl bei Männern als auch bei Frauen. Man hat es aus dem Grund heraus gemacht, man hat gesehen, etwas hat funktioniert. Bei den Männern, WM 66, hohe Einschaltquoten, lasst uns eine Liga machen, da ist Geld zu verdienen, hat nicht geklappt. Bei den Frauen, WM 99, fantastische Einschaltquoten und noch viel mehr, lasst uns eine Liga machen, da ist Geld zu verdienen, weil nur deshalb geben die Leute dafür Geld und es hat nicht geklappt.
Und jetzt kommt aber ein interessanter, also oder, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nur sagen, du kannst auch die Männer-WM von 94 auch noch einreihen.
Ja, genau, zu der kommen wir noch.
Weil die war auch sehr erfolgreich. Da hatte man zwar schon im Hintergrund den Gedanken, vielleicht ist das der Schritt zu einer Liga. Also es war nicht so gekoppelt wie jetzt bei den Frauen mit 99, aber auch dort im Grunde der Schuss, wo der irgendwie, ja, den alle hören, wo keiner versteht, wo er hingegangen ist.
Der Unterschied war, 1994 bei der Männer-WM war es ja eine Bedingung der FIFA, dass diese WM in den USA stattfinden darf, dass eben eine Liga gegründet werden würde. Aber die Art und Weise, wie man dann diese Liga konzipiert hat, Anzahl der Teams, in welchen Stadien spielen wir und so weiter, die war halt dann wieder basierend auf dem Erfolg der 94er-WM völlig aufgeblasen. Interessanterweise gibt es hier aber, wir sprechen ja dann gleich nochmal über die Männer-Ligen. Ich würde aber gerne jetzt bis zur NWSL vorankommen, bei den Frauen noch. Hier gibt es dann schon einen Lerneffekt, weil du hast das vorhin so gesagt, man möchte nicht aus der Geschichte lernen. Ich finde, bei den Nachfolge-Ligen sind derer zwei und die aktuelle ist die NWSL. Da sehen wir, Dinge haben sich verändert. Also zum Beispiel Entity, Single Entities ist immer so das Stichwort. Das heißt, die Teams gehören nicht mehr InvestorInnen, zumindest in der Anfangsphase, sondern die SpielerInnen sind letztlich bei der Liga angestellt. Die Liga verwaltet das Geld, die Liga hat da auch klare Richtlinien. Es gibt Mindestgehälter, es gibt Maximalgehälter. Man versucht, das Ganze etwas kleiner aufzuziehen und eben kosteneffizienter aufzuziehen. Und das ist das, was 2007 passiert. Schon eine bemerkenswerte Lücke von vier Jahren zwischen 2003 und 2007. Dann wird die Women's Professional Soccer Liga gegründet und sie startet dann auch erst 2009. Das hat man noch mal nach hinten verschoben. Die Gründe dafür sind egal, aber alles ist ein bisschen kleiner, organisiert und es wird auch lokaler investiert, weil man eben hofft, dass man damit eben etwas schafft, was nicht zu aufgeblasen ist und deshalb scheitert. Allerdings muss man sagen, auch diese Liga, sie hält es nur drei Jahre aus. Im Mai 2012 scheitert sie mit einer ganz unrühmlichen Episode. Der Magic-Stack-Skandal von 2011, da ist Dan Borislav reingekommen in die Liga, hat sich ein Team gekauft, hat sich, also ich verkürze jetzt extrem, aber da hat sich aufgeführt wie die Axt im Wald, hat manche Nationalspielerinnen verpflichtet und mit Geld zugeworfen, andere auf die übelste Art und Weise bedrängt und eben im Gegenteil mit Geld zugeworfen, sondern die haben am Existenzminimum geknabbert. Da sind ganz ganz viele unschöne Dinge passiert und weil sich das später noch mal wiederholen wird, da haben wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, Jürgen wollte ich das hier noch mal ansprechen, aber das fand ich eben interessant, dass wir hier sehen, man hat dann schon versucht zu reagieren auf das erste Scheitern und es lag jetzt nicht an Dan Borislav, aber er ist ein Symptom dafür. Es kam halt dann doch wieder Leute rein, die sehr schnell sehr viel Geld verdienen wollten, die sich auch profilieren wollten. Also der wollte ja erst mal nicht Geld verdienen, sondern das war einfach nur ein Selbstdarsteller, sage ich jetzt mal. Ich glaube, das ist das freundlichste Wort, was mir dazu einfällt. Und wieder war eine Frauenprofiliga in den USA gescheitert. Und hättest du damals gedacht im Jahr 2012, dass das nochmal was wird, dass es noch einen dritten Versuch gibt und der hat jetzt Bestand. Also wenn wir über den WSL sprechen.
Ich habe das angenommen. Ich hatte ja diesen Investor aus Deutschland gerade schon erwähnt, dessen Namen mir jetzt leider nicht mehr einfällt. Ich müsste ihn jetzt nachschauen. Also der war bei Sky, so nannte sich das Team Sky sowieso. Und der hat mir das auch erklärt in dem Interview. Das war nämlich vor der WM als Steffi Jones als Werbebotschafter für die Deutschland-WM in New York eintraf und eine Veranstaltung gemacht hat in Harlem. Und da hat er mir zum Beispiel gesagt, wie sehr das fehlt, dass der Verband diese Liga nicht unterstützt. Die waren quasi für sich selbst. Und das kann man ja nachfunktionieren und sagen, na gut, das eine ist das hier und das andere ist das da. Was müssen wir das vermischen? Aber wenn man die Interessenlage erkennt, der Verband braucht Spielerinnen, die Titel holen können und die müssen wirtschaftlich tragfähig gefördert werden. Und die Liga ist der Spielort, an dem quasi eine Art von Training und von Fit halten und sonst was alles stattfindet. Dann braucht es eine Verzahnung. Und die wurde erst ein paar Jahre später tatsächlich auf die Beine gestellt. Und da habe ich in dem Moment geglaubt, genau das ist das eigentliche Problem für deren fehlenden Überlebensfähigkeit. Wenn so ein Topf von Gold irgendwo rumliegt und der wird nicht benutzt und nicht sachverständlich eingesetzt, zum Beispiel über das Bezahlen der Spielerinnen. Und das wurde ja später dann auch umgesetzt, dass die, die im Nationalmannschaftskader gespielt haben, dass die also ein bestimmtes Grundgehalt aus Chicago, wo der Verband es jetzt bekommen haben. Und das hat sicherlich auch alles, was danach noch passiert ist, also eine Entlastungsfunktion gehabt. Aber ob es wirklich der Weisheit letzter Schluss war, um das alles hinzukriegen, das kann ich jetzt nicht abschätzen. Es war vielleicht ein wichtiger Detailschritt, aber es brauchte vielleicht auch noch wieder andere Menschen mit anderen Sensibilitäten, um die nächste Auflage dann tatsächlich einigermaßen sattelfest hinzukommen.
Und vielleicht auch ein veränderter Zeitgast. Also Thomas Hofstetter ist der Investor, den du gemeint hast. Es hat mich jetzt auch eine kleine Weile gedauert, das noch nebenher zu recherchieren. Aber vielleicht auch tatsächlich, denn das Interessante ist ja, es gibt zwei Konstanten bis zur Gründung der NWSL, also der jetzigen Profi-Frauenleger. Die eine Konstanz ist, das Nationalteam ist es extrem erfolgreich und generiert damit auch für den Verband Gelder, an denen aber zunächst die Frauen noch nicht beteiligt werden. Und das zweite ist, die Liga kommt nicht auf die Beine. Die Liga wird konzipiert und egal, ob sie in der großen Variante konzipiert wird, nach der 99er WM oder in der kleineren Variante, das Interesse ist nicht groß genug und wesentlich dabei entscheidend sind die Einnahmen durch TV-Gelder und durch Sponsoren. Da wird so wenig erlöst. Und wenn ich mir jetzt dann vor Augen führe, dass 2012 dann eben schon die NWSL angekündigt wird und 2013 startet sie auch, dann sieht man, dass die verschiedene Phasen durchläuft und das ist zum ersten Mal, interessanterweise bezieht sich das auch auf den Fußball der Männer in den USA, dass ich in diesen Phasen eine Art organisches Wachstum erkennen möchte. Vielleicht ist das aber auch nur meine Interpretation. Also man startet 2013 mit wenigen Teams. Es gibt noch keinen TV-Di. Damals konnte man die Spiele auf YouTube alle kostenlos sehen. Es gibt aber auch geringe Fixkosten. Also die Spielerinnen haben damals wenig bis nichts verdient. Das gehört. Also ich möchte das jetzt nicht nur rein als Erfolgsgeschichte. Das ist auf die Nationalspielerinnen. Das erklärt ja auch nochmal, warum es für sie besonders wichtig war, nicht vom Verband diskriminiert zu werden. Also das erklärt das, glaube ich, auch nochmal. 2017 bis 2020 kommen dann neue Teams dazu. Die USA gewinnen dann nochmal die Weltmeisterschaft in Frankreich. Der Zuschauerinnenstitt steigt allerdings relativ moderat. Also die Steigung ist eine große von 5000 auf 7500. Aber insgesamt sind das immer noch nicht viele Zuschauerinnen, vor allem wenn man es mit dem Interesse am US-Nationalteam vergleicht. Wir haben jetzt hier allerdings schon die ersten TV-Gelder, die reinkommen. 10 bis 15 Millionen US-Dollar pro Jahr. Und dann kommt etwas, das hätte dem Ganzen eigentlich den Saft abdrehen können. Und darüber haben wir in zwei Sendungen auch schon gesprochen. Deswegen werde ich die auch nochmal verlinken. Nämlich 2021 Enthüllungen über den Trainer Riley und der sogenannte Yates Report, der diskriminierende Machtstrukturen offenlegt, sexuelle Gewalt gegenüber Spielerinnen offenlegt. Ein ganz dunkles Kapitel, wo wir damals noch darüber gesprochen haben, Jürgen, was bedeutet das jetzt für die Liga? Und könnte das jetzt schon wieder dazu führen, dass das Interesse zurückgeht und diese Liga-Pleite geht zum dritten Mal dann? Und ich glaube, jetzt können wir ja das zwischen Fazit ziehen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Danach ging es erst so richtig los. Was glaubst du denn jetzt mit der Rückschau? Was hat der Yates Report bedeutet für die Liga?
Um mal was ganz Gewagtes zu sagen. Also wenn du dir anguckst, was rund um diese Epstein-Affäre los ist. Die jetzt in Washington und rund um Donald Trump so viel aufsehen und so viel ständige Aufregung verursacht. Unter anderem weil da jemand ja auch versucht, das unterm Deckel zu halten. In Amerika hast du das schon immer wieder gehabt. Dass also die Misshandlung von Menschen, egal aus welchen Gründen, Leute sensibilisiert und neugierig macht auf etwas. Und wenn dann auch noch belegbar wird, dass das nicht einfach nur Geräusch ist und nicht nur, dann kommt halt, wir waren ja auch in dieser Phase, sehr oft wurden wir ja durch den Slogan Me Too daran erinnert, dass das also nicht nur einfach ein spezielles Thema aus dem Sport ist oder aus dem noch enger gefassten, aus dem Frauenfußball, sondern dass das ein gesellschaftliches Problem ist. Das heißt, die Grundsympathie, die Potenzielle Opfer, wenn das Medienecho entsprechend funktioniert, erreichen können, ist beachtlich in diesem Land und hat immer auch irgendwelche Auswirkungen, die man vielleicht auch nicht vorher abschätzen kann. Es gibt nur in Amerika den Begriff The Law of Unintended Consequences. Dafür gibt es nicht mal eine vernünftige deutsche Übersetzung, weil man das in Deutschland nicht kennt, diesen Gedanken. Also, was immer du an Guten tust oder tun willst, kann irgendwelche anderen Konsequenzen haben. Und die können auch doof sein oder schlecht sein oder so. Und das gehört für mich auch dann da verallgemeinernd rein. Also, das, was man da tut, kann auch eine positive Auswirkung haben. Also, an Intended, es war nicht, wir haben versucht, Krach zu schlagen, damit die Liga richtig viel Zuspruch erhält und vielleicht mehr Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer in die Stadien kommen oder die Einschaltquoten, sondern wir wollten eigentlich was Gutes erreichen, was uns wichtig ist. Und diese Verkopplungen über sonst welche Kanäle, die gibt es auch in anderen Ländern, aber hier in Amerika hat man dafür sogar einen Begriff und den wollte ich heute schnell mal stiften. The Law of Unintended Consequences. Du darfst es übersetzen.
Das Gesetz der unbeabsichtigten Konsequenzen hätte ich jetzt übersetzt. So ungefähr trifft es glaube ich den Wert, den Inhalt. Und das ist eben das Interessante. Also wir haben eben diesen Skandal, der führt auch zwischenzeitlich dazu, dass Spieltage nicht ausgeführt werden. Wir haben aber inzwischen eine Veränderung in der Struktur der Profi-Liga, denn wir haben eine sehr starke Spielerinnen-Gewerkschaft und die wird jetzt noch stärker. Das ist generell nochmal ein genuines Thema der US-Sportarten, wo die eine ganz andere Rolle spielen. Und die setzen jetzt aber Veränderungen durch und die sind weitreichend. Also du darfst zum Beispiel als Trainer einer minderjährigen Spielerin nicht einfach so eine Nachricht bei WhatsApp schreiben, sondern wenn du mit ihr kommunizieren bist, muss mindestens ein weiterer Coaching-Stuff, also noch jemand aus dem Trainerinnen-Team, in dieser Chatgruppe mit dabei sein. Davon gibt es ganz viele Regeln, die sind auch sehr kleinteilig. In MBHK, dem Podcast von Jose Henning, Anja Mittag und Tabea Kemmerda wird immer mal wieder darüber gesprochen. Sehr interessant. Es wurden auch NDAs, die Verschwiegenheitsklauseln, verboten bei Missbrauchsfällen, dass sie Anwendungsfinden dürfen. Also hier haben Spielerinnen mal wieder für sich selbst Recht erkämpft. Ein Recht, was man sich auch in anderen Gesellschaftsbereichen wünschen würde. Und ich will da jetzt keinen Zusammenhang herstellen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man da wirklich eine Kausalität rausstricken sollte. Aber zumindest damit korrelierend geht es der US-Frauenliga besser denn je. Es sind weitere Teams dazugekommen, auch sehr aufmerksamkeitsheiligende Teams. Adencio City FC hast du vorhin schon angesprochen, wo eben auch wieder viel Hollywood-Schauspielerinnen unter anderem mit involviert sind. Ich glaube, Selena Gomez, Selena Williams, Entschuldigung, war auch Teil der Investorinnen zu ihrer Gründung. Mit San Diego Wave ist auch ein Team in die Liga gekommen, das ein eigenes Stadion hat, das einen fantastischen ZuschauerInnenschnitt hat. Und das ist das, was sich verändert hat. Also ich habe vorhin gesagt, moderater Anstieg 2019, noch so 7.500. Jetzt sprechen wir schon von 11.000 ZuschauerInnen, über 11.000 ZuschauerInnen pro Spiel. Wir haben insgesamt über zwei Millionen Fans, die in die Stadion gehen innerhalb einer Saison. Und wir haben vor allem einen TV-Deal, der richtig Geld in die NWSL bringt. Und zwar so viel Geld, dass Europäische liegen da schon ganz schön schlotternde Knie bekommen haben. Und wir haben ja auch schon erste Spielerinnen gesehen, die trotz guter Angebote bei Top-Teens in Europa lieber in der NWSL ihr Geld verdienen. Also, wenn du dich mal vorsichtig an einer Prognose oder Einschätzung versuchen wollen würdest, ist das jetzt, ist die NWSL gekommen, um zu bleiben?
Ja, und meine Überlegung kommt aus dem Frauenbasketball. Eine andere Hintergrundgeschichte, eine Entwicklungsgeschichte. Aber wir sehen da ein jetzt überraschend starkes Publikumsinteresse. Das hat sehr viel damit zu tun, was für ein Basketball die Frauen jetzt spielen. Also da gibt es auch eine Qualitätsentwicklung. Welche Personen sind identifizierbar? Und da darf man, muss man, kann man nicht an der Hautfarben-Thematik vorbeigucken. Also wenn eine weiße Spielerin die beste Spielerin oder mindestens vielleicht zu den besten drei gehörenden gehört und eine Liga, die bis dato hauptsächlich von schwarzen Spielerinnen dominiert wurde, dann ist das für einen Großteil des sehr peripheren Publikums plötzlich auch interessant. Die identifizieren sich auch eher mit einer Person, die ihre Hautfarbe hat oder so.
Meinst du damit Kathleen Clark wahrscheinlich?
Kathleen Clark, ja. Also ich finde das auch ein sehr heikles Thema, aber ich kann da zumindest sagen, das ist ein Faktor in der Entwicklung. Okay, das ist nicht dasselbe wie beim Frauenfußball, aber was es erreicht ist, dass jetzt über Frauen Basketball eine andere Mannschaftssportart, die eigentlich schon länger rumhantiert, auch erstaunliche Mengen am Publikum zielt. Also da gibt es jetzt Live-Übertragung von Spielen mit einer Million Menschen, das entspricht fast dem NBA Durchschnitt, weil die spielen nur auch 80 Spieler und wer guckt sich das immer alles an, aber die sind schon sehr nah an dem dran. Und ich kann mir einfach nicht ausmalen, bei dem was ich aus diesem Land mitgenommen habe bisher, dass das so isoliert passiert. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass genau das, was mal Hofstetter mir gesagt hat, also seine Töchter interessieren sich nicht, für die, die da im Fernsehen spielen, dass das im Grunde abgearbeitet ist. Und wenn das stimmt, dass jetzt auch aus dem Reservoir Frauen als Publikum Zuspruch kommt, dann gilt das nicht nur für eine Sportart. Klar, jeder ist meistens ein Fan von einer Sportart. Aber auf der anderen Seite, rasanter Fußball ist genauso attraktiv anzugucken, wie rasanter Basketball. Und da gibt es auch Kabinettsstückchen, was immer dich da irgendwie begeistern kann. Also, da ziehe ich meine sehr positive Idee davon her, weil das kann nicht alles nur immer Einzelfall-Thematik sein. Und vor allen Dingen, du hast auch wieder andere Indikatoren. Also bei der Frauenbasketball-Liga siehst du auch, wie jetzt über Investitionssummen geredet wird, die früher theoretisch gar nicht denkbar waren. Und du siehst auch, wie diese Frauen in ihrer eigenen Gewerkschaft gerade aktuell kämpfen, um eine Vertragssituation, die also sich aus dieser gehobenen Armut rausbuxiert und auch eine Beteiligung an dem Erfolg garantiert, die ihnen quasi bestritten wird von diesen Investoren, die sagen, ja, wir hatten hier schon viele Verluste, ihr müsst das jetzt alle mittragen. Also, wenn jetzt für ein Team, da werden jetzt Preise aufgerufen für ein Expansion-Team, ein neues Team, 250 Millionen muss in den Ligatopf einbezahlt werden. Immer, das ist völlig irre. Und das ist vielleicht noch nicht der Preis, aber auch, ich glaube, soweit ich das mitkriege, auch aus dem Bereich der Frauenfußballliga hört man, dass da auch diese Parameter nach oben gehen. Ja, und wenn du also mehr Geld reinholen kannst, sodass also der Atem länger wird und du passt auf mit dem, was du da ausgibst, dann hast du eine Chance. Weil du hast auch eine mediale Veränderung. Der Konsum von Live-Sport ist zwar immer noch das Fernsehthema schlechthin, entweder terrestrisch oder kabel, aber du siehst ja auch, was jetzt die Streamer machen, die immer mehr in den Sport reingehen, Amazon und Netflix und YouTube. Und du siehst auch einen bestimmten Benutzerverhaltensveränderung. Dann kannst du das nicht live gesehen haben, aber dann guckst du dir diese ganz simpel zusammengeschnittene zehnminütige Zusammenfassung an. Das ist zwar komisch zu konsumieren, aber du kriegst auf jeden Fall die Essenz jeweils. Und dann hast du auch wieder einen anderen Zugang. Schneller, leichter. Du wirst vielleicht ein Dauerkonsument, der zwar jetzt nicht jedes Mal einschaltet, aber du wirst zu einem potentiellen Interessenten für die ganzen peripheren Geräusche, den Trikotverkauf, das Sponsoring, die Akzeptanz. Also wenn solche Frauen in der Werbung dann auftauchen, weil sie eingekauft worden sind von respektablen Unternehmen oder so. Also all das zeigt in eine Richtung von mehr Akzeptanz und mehr Interesse an Frauensport. Und weniger, oh, das ist ja alles irgendwie sportsweiter Klasse. Also dieser alte Vorbehalt, weil ich bin da auch inzwischen völlig angefixt von diesem Frauenbasketball, wie der gespielt wird.
Und es ist ein sich selbst verstärkender Effekt. Du siehst die Bilder aus einer vollen Halle, die völlig eskaliert, wenn da der Basserbieter geworfen wird. Und du möchtest mehr solcher Bilder sehen oder am liebsten, wenn es möglich wäre, dort selbst vor Ort sein. Und das siehst du nämlich bei den Frauen in Derpel, USL auch. Wenn du da eben ein Team hast wie Angel City, die eben 20.000 ZuschauerInnen eigentlich immer da haben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Instagram Reels ich in der vergangenen Saison gesehen habe. Einfach nur von Kreischen, also wo ein Tor fällt und man nur Kreischen hört im ganzen Stadion. Und das entwickelt einen regelrechten Sog. Man möchte dann auch dort vor Ort sein, möchte das auch so erfahren. Und ich glaube, diese Hürde haben sowohl die WNBA, als auch jetzt die NWSL, die haben diese Hürde genommen, dass du fast schon eine FOMO hast, wenn du die Spiele nicht wenigstens live verfolgt hast am TV-Screen. Deswegen wäre meine Prognose auch, ich glaube, diesmal hat das geklappt bei der Frauenliga, die bleiben. Was uns aber zu den Männern dann nochmal bringt. Und da springen wir jetzt nochmal zeitlich kurz zurück und dann landen wir in der Gegenwart und können ja mal gucken, ob wir da beim selben Fazit rauskommen. Ich bin mir da ehrlicherweise noch nicht so sicher. Also wir haben aufgehört bei der Männerprofiliga Mitte der 80er. Das ist krachend gescheitert. Es gibt dann verschiedene kleinere Ligen, aber eben keine nationale Profiliga. Und ich habe es vorhin schon erwähnt, damit die Männer WM 94 stattfinden konnte in den USA, hat die FIFA es zur Bedingung gemacht, dass eine neue Liga gegründet wird. Und das findet auch statt. Interessanterweise dauert es aber zwei Jahre bis nach der WM, bis dann diese Liga auch startet mit zehn Teams. Und man hat es anders strukturiert, als in der NASL, die ja gescheitert ist. Man hat einen Salary Cap von Beginn an. Auch hier haben wir die Single Entity-Regel. Das heißt, die Liga besitzt alle Spielverträge. Wir haben eine einheitliche Vermarktung. Wir haben ganz wichtiger Unterschied, eine Begrenzung ausländischer Spieler. Und man wollte langsam wachsen und eben nicht gleich wieder so viele neue Franchises aufnehmen, so wie es eben damals schon schiefgegangen ist. Wie blickst du denn jetzt zurück auf diesen, ja doch relativ steinigen Start, dann der MLS, der ja dann rund um die 2000er, und da hast du vorhin ja schon von gesprochen, es hing dann eigentlich am Wohl und Wehe von drei Investorengruppen, die dann diese Liga am Laufen gehalten haben. Woran liegt denn das deiner Meinung nach in der Rückschau oder lag das?
Also ich komme hier auch erstmal wieder von relativ weit weg. Wenn man denkt, man kann oben irgendwo ein Stockwerk reinhängen, in ein noch nicht existierendes Gebäude, das also eigentlich darunter nichts hat. Also auf was stützt du das? Sind das ganze lange Stahlstäbe? Oder wenn du nur ein Penthouse haben willst und sonst nichts darunter? Das ist das Bild, das ich benutze, wenn ich versuche zu beschreiben, was da gemacht worden ist. Keine Nullarbeit an dem, wie man Fußball von der Basis aus nach oben ziehen kann. Und das beinhaltet Narrative, das beinhaltet Mythen, das beinhaltet, wie Geld fließen kann. Und das sind Sachen, die von der FIFA geduldet worden sind. Also an dieser Liga ist so viel nicht normal. Und wurde von der FIFA immer geduldet. Da ging es um Transfer-Summen, da ging es um alles Mögliche. Am Anfang hatten sie auch einen Penalty-Shootout, weil sie keine Unentschieden haben wollten. Da wurde alles Kunstrasen, da war alles möglich, was heute vielleicht normaler wirkt als damals. Aber diese Art von Denken, die mussten die auch so langsam wegentwickeln. Und auch hier gibt es, wenn man den Indikator nimmt, also wie viel kann man heute für ein Expansion-Team die Liga einnehmen? Da sind wir bei mehreren hundert Millionen. 600, 700 Millionen. Das heißt, das ist schon eine Zahl. Aber es ist auch ein Mittel, um diesen Laden aufrechtzuerhalten. Weil es ist Geld, das von außen reinfließt. Das wird nicht von der Liga generiert. Das wird von Leuten, die Geld haben, wie auch immer, oder zu Banken gehen können, generiert. Und das ist dann auch irgendwann weg. Und dieser Investoren-Typus lebt auch von der Hoffnung, dass man irgendwann den Laden verkauft. Entweder wird das profitabel, wer weiß. Atlanta ist wahrscheinlich profitabel. Oder wenn man das dann verkaufen kann an den nächsten Besitzer, kann man dann da richtig viel Geld machen oder so. Was in anderen Ligen ja auch vorgekommen ist. Und das gilt auch für Europa mit Premier League und so. Oder auch mit dem, was in anderen europäischen Ligen, wo es insgesamt eine sehr ans amerikanische Urmodell angelehnte Besitzerstruktur gibt. Und dann ist aber die Frage, was braucht es, um diese Hoffnung oder diese Vision wirklich abzustützen? Und es geht nicht ohne eine Öffnung auf ein mehrliegendes System mit Aufstieg und Abstieg. Und auch dieser Playoff-Quatsch, wo das Team, das die beste Saison gefahren hat, nicht Meister wird. Und was ist dann dieser Meistertitel wert, wenn das irgendwie auf so eine komische Art und Weise wird?
Wir sind doch damit eingestiegen. Also in unserer Einleitung heute ist kein einziges Mal die Info gefallen, wer überhaupt die Meisterschaft vor den Playoffs gewonnen hat. Also ist das nicht... Also ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, weil wir ja auch hier aus der Männer WM 94 kommen. Und da kannst du ja auch gleich noch berichten, wie die vor Ort eigentlich abgelaufen ist. Und das Interessante ist ja, du denkst viel in Strukturen und in sportlicher Qualität. Ich versuche es mehr aus der Investoren sich zu sehen und dann denke ich in Merchandising erlösen in möglichen Refinanzierungen von Investitionen, die ich tätige. Und da ist es zum einen bemerkenswert, dass die bis 96 brauchen, um dann diese Liga wirklich zu starten. Das hat ehrlicherweise auch damit zu tun, dass der US-Fußballverband ein Chaosverband ist. In dem ganz, ganz...
Dass es gar keine guten amerikanischen Fußballspieler gibt, die man vorführen möchte. Ich meine, diese Mannschaft von 94 ist eine Söldner-Truppe, die nicht gekonnt und noch versucht wurde. Es ist irre eigentlich, wenn du anguckst, was die da auf die Beine stellen. Und kein Wunder, dass die dann auch rausfliegen und mit Glück in die zweite Runde kommen.
Ja, Glück und vielleicht noch ein bisschen Zutun.
Wer will denn das auf die Beine stellen, dieser Qualitätsstufe Fußball? Wer will denn, da haben wir ja mit Axel Schuss mal angefangen. Wer will denn, dessen Plan ist, ich mache ein Penthouse, aber die Lebensqualität in dem Penthouse ist zweite Liga. Und wenn ich Glück habe, vielleicht die obere Hälfte von der zweiten Liga. Das geht doch schon mal irgendwie gar nicht richtig auf.
Ja, vor allem auch der zeitliche Kontext, glaube ich, das noch ein bisschen so verklärt. Also bisher haben wir quasi die rein US-amerikanische Sicht abgebildet. Es gibt diese WM, die FIFA macht die Auflage, deswegen gründen wir noch mal die Liga und wollen damit natürlich auch Geld verdienen und so weiter und so fort. Wenn man sich aber mal anguckt, was rund um diese WM-Vergabe eben für 94 in Europa los war, da haben da alle Dollarzeichen in den Augen gehabt, weil man dachte, wenn jetzt die USA ein Fußballmarkt werden, dann müssen wir da Geld verdienen. Und mit wir ist jetzt gemeint Manchester United, Liverpool, Arsenal, der FC Bayern, Real Madrid, Barcelona. Alle sind sie in die USA geflogen. Da ging es los mit den Auslandstournähen und so weiter und so fort.
Das muss ich korrigieren. Gibt es historische, es gibt wunderbare Wochenschauaufnahmen, wie englische Vereine in den 50er Jahren, solche Touren auch schon drauf hatten. Aber natürlich, manches von dem, was wir versuchen, historisch zu kontextualisieren, ist historisch abgelaufen. Die Leute in den 90er Jahren haben bestimmt nicht mehr darüber nachgedacht, wie das war, als Sir Stanley Matthews da irgendwie eine Show abgezogen hat und wie da das Stadion voll war oder so.
Du hast völlig recht, aber damals hat man über diese Freundschaftsspiel-Turnänen, und das haben ja auch Bundesligisten gemacht, Kickers Offenbach spielen gegen Trinidad und Tobago und das habe ich mir nicht ausgedacht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hört, elf Leben dazu. Damals war das eine Haupteinnahmequelle, weil du da für jedes Spiel hast du Geld bekommen. Und diese Turnänen, die jetzt stattfinden oder die damals auch stattfanden, so Teams wie Real Madrid, die haben damit auch Geld verdient, weil der ihnen da ihr Sponsor richtig viel für gezahlt hat, weil er auf dem US-Markt eine wichtige Rolle spielen wollte, dass die rüber kommen. Aber das sind ja vor allem Marketing-Touren. Die zahlen da nicht Geld für, die kommen da schon auch mit einem Erlös raus. Aber der genuine Grund ist jetzt nicht, wir verdienen mit den einzelnen Spielen, die wir da machen, vor Ort Geld, sondern wir präsentieren uns da in einem riesigen Markt mit einer irren Kaufkraft und hoffen, dass wir durch ein Wunder, weil wir jetzt hier in Charlotte den 1. FC Köln mal haben spielen lassen, alle da FC-Fans werden und alle unser Merchandising kaufen. Wie das funktioniert hat, liebe Hörer und Hörer, könnt ihr euch jetzt überlegen. Aber das ist interessant, weil wenn wir dann nämlich wieder auf die MLS zurückblicken, sehen wir dann, die Konkurrieren nicht nur mit den US-Profiligen, also mit den anderen Sportarten, sondern sie konkurrieren ja auch mit, also du würdest jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen, richtigen Fußball, nämlich qualitativ besseren Fußball, in einer Zeit, in der es jetzt auch einfacher wird, den zu konsumieren. Jetzt haben wir schon das Internet, es ist noch nicht die Livestreaming-Zeit, dafür sind die Leitungen noch zu schlecht und die Datenraten zu gering. Aber du kannst dich immerhin schon informieren, du kannst Clips sehen und wir kommen ja dann jetzt dann in die 2000er-Reihen, da fängt das definitiv an. Und das finde ich interessant, war das Scheidmann damals nicht so wirklich mitbedacht zu haben. In den Quellen, die ich so gelesen habe, wird immer sehr, sehr viel darüber gesprochen, wie man sich gegen NFL, NBA und so weiter behaupten will. Aber wie man sich gegen Manchester United behaupten will, ist gar kein Thema. Und vielleicht war das ja auch einer der Geburtsfehler dieser Liga.
Und noch ein Thema, wie man eigentlich amerikanische Fußballer dazu bringt, auf einem einigermaßen anspruchsvollen Niveau Fußball zu spielen. Das war auch kein Thema. Das war so, als könnte man die wirklich alle irgendwie am College abholen. Und dann bauen wir die hier zusammen. Die sind dann zwar schon 22, 23, aber wir kriegen das irgendwie hin. Also auch da war wieder so ein Effizienz-Thema. Also das ist so eine Investorenlogik. Also ja, was habe ich hier für Ressourcen? Na ja, okay, das macht ja irgendwie, das könnte ja... Also sich zu überlegen, wie kriege ich Nachwuchs dahin, wo ich ihn brauche. Das hat ganz lange gedauert. Es gab zwar schon relativ früh diese eine Akademie in Florida, in Bradenton, die von dieser Vermarktungsagentur auf die Beine gestellt wurde und die wurde auch so ein bisschen modellhaft dann auch für andere Sportarten benutzt, aber völliges Defizit. Ja, ich male mir eine Liga, weißt du so.
Und wozu hat es geführt?
Pensing by Numbers, da gibt es diese Zahlen.
Stimmt, und die Numbers waren immer mit einem Dollarzeichen da hinten dran. Es waren allerdings keine hohen Numbers, denn hier Zuschausschnitt schon 1997, nur 13.000 ZuschauerInnen in den Stadien. Nach den Anschlägen vom 11. September wird auch die Liga abgebrochen und eigentlich gehen alle damals davon aus, dass das Cup-Finale, das Pokalfinale damals das letzte Spiel sein würde. Und dann kommen eben die drei Besitzergruppen, also zwei Personen plus die Kraftfamilie. Die besitzen NFL-Teams und die teilen sich quasi jetzt die Liga auf. Also die Phil Anschutz ist das, Lemma Hunt und eben die eben schon erwähnte Kraftfamilie.
Die kleine Einschub, die haben aber auch eben diese Stadien oder Hallen oder was auch immer. Die haben diese Denke, die wollen, wie ja jetzt auch immer noch, New England Revolution spielt ja immer noch in diesem riesigen Stadion, in dem die Patriots zu Hause sind. Ja, aber jetzt können die diese Stadien, die sie besitzen, können sie effektiver nutzen. Können also da mehr Sachen veranstalten. Und da muss man auch nicht viel wieder extra an Arbeit investieren. Die Stadien gibt es, die Leute, die da den Verkehr lenken, die gibt es. Und Parkplätze gibt es und so weiter und so weiter. Also da kommt dann der Motivationsgedanke ganz stark rein. Natürlich braucht es für ein erfolgreiches, komplexes Konzept viele verschiedene Einflussgrößen. Und wenn es dann die ist, dann ist es eben die. Aber ich will das jetzt nicht kleinreden, aber die Logik von wie man euch eine Liga.
Für die war es einfacher als die Verluste zu realisieren, war eben diese Effekte zu nutzen. Das ist das schönste Wort. Damit treibst du BWL an Tränen der Freude in die Augen. Synergieeffekte ist das Allerbeste, was sie sich hoffen, oft auch nur behaupten. Und tatsächlich überlebt so diese Liga und dann passieren zwei Dinge. Das eine ist Lionel Messi, zu dem kommen wir gleich. Aber zuerst kommt noch jemand anderes in der Liga und der bereitet letztlich auch den Lionel-Messi-Zugang vor, nämlich David Beckham. 2007 unterschreibt...
Das war nicht unser Matthäus, das wollten wir vielleicht noch kurz.
Nee, der war es nicht. He did not have a very bit lucky. Also 2007 kommt David Beckham, unterschreibt einen Fünf-Jahres-Vertrag bei LA Galaxy zur großen Empörung des Madridter Präsidenten. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das damals auch schon Perez war, der gesagt hat, warum geht er in diese Mickey-Mouse-Liga? Nur für David Beckham wird die sogenannte Beckham-Rule eingeführt. Gab es übrigens oft bei seinem Wechsel zu Real Madrid. Also offenbar, wenn du David Beckham haben willst, dann musst du dafür ein extra Gesetz erlassen. Ab jetzt können die Teams nämlich auch über den Salary Cap einzelne Spieler hinbezahlen. Und das ermöglicht er eben, dass man solche Stars verpflichtet, ohne den Salary Cap, also die Gehalts-Obergrenze zu sprengen. Und tatsächlich steigt jetzt die Zuschauer-Einzahl, auch die Einnahmen der Liga durch Sponsoring und Merchandise zahlen. Und David Beckham, und das ist eben ganz wichtig für alles, über das wir jetzt sprechen, der hatte eine Klausel im Vertrag, dass er für 25 Millionen US-Dollar, und da hat er wirklich einen Schnapper gemacht, sich eine eigene Franchise kaufen durfte. Und das wird er dann eben später tun mit Inter Miami. Und das ist jetzt diese Phase, David Beckham spielt in der MLS, Thierry Oury kommt, Alessandro Pirlo spielt, Villa, KK., die alle kommen in die MLS. Und wir haben aber, Jürgen, nicht nur diese Stars, sondern jetzt kommen auch neue Franchises mit dazu. Wir haben jetzt ein langsames Wachstum, die aber durchaus anders sind. Und darüber haben wir uns nämlich unterhalten 2018. Denn 2018, da ist Atlanta United Meister geworden und das erst im zweiten Jahr des Bestehens. Und Atlanta United hatte damals schon einen Zuschauer in den Schnitt von 48.000. Und darüber haben wir gesprochen. Was hat sich denn da verändert, dass das möglich war, dass ein neu gegründetes Team in einem riesigen Stadion dieses auch fast gefüllt bekommt? In einem Football-Stadion, genau.
Es ist auch dem Mann gehört, der dieses Fußball Franchise gewinnt. Es ist mehrfach unverständlich, auf verschiedene Anlegerweise. Atlanta hat zwei Versuche hinter sich, ein Ice Hockey-Team in der NHL zu etablieren, das dann also nach ein paar Jahren da nicht mehr weiterkommt und dann woanders hin wandert. Das eine war jetzt zwischendurch in Phoenix und das andere ist jetzt in Utah in Salt Lake City gelandet, weil das auch in Phoenix nicht geklappt hat. Und das andere ist dann in Winnipeg gelandet, wo man schon mal eins hatte, aber dann ist das, oder vielleicht schmeiß ich jetzt was durcheinander. Ich glaube, das Winnipeg-Team ist nach Phoenix gewandert. Ah, Mist.
Wir sind ein Fußballpodcast, das fällt niemandem auf oder sie sind Freunde.
Atlanta als Sportstadt hat zwar durch diese olympischen Spiele irgendwie so eine gewissen Aufwertung erfahren, aber an Atlanta olympische Spiele ist für mich folgendes Detail interessant. Diese olympischen Spiele haben null Spuren in dieser Stadt hinterlassen, außer einem sogenannten Centennial Park, in dem es eine Springfontänen-Skulpturartige Geschichte gibt. Also kein Brunnen, aber es kommen also aus Löchern in der, ja, und das sind irgendwelche Pflastersteine, die dich an irgendwas erinnern, dass da mal olympische Spiele waren. Vergleich das mal mit dem Olympiastadion von Berlin oder mit bestimmten anderen Bauten, die entstanden sind rund um olympische Spiele und dem Selbstverständnis einer Stadt. Also, mysteriös. Ich bleibe, mir ist nicht klar, nur die müssten die Expansion Draft auch besonders gut hingekriegt haben. Also, was die für Spieler dann abgreifen konnten, nachdem wie die Regeln da laufen. Also, existierende Mannschaften müssen dann, können nicht alle möglichen Spieler schützen. Sie müssen quasi 80 Prozent ihres Kaders dem Zugriff einer neuen Mannschaft zubilligen. Das haben wir jetzt auch mit San Diego wieder hingekriegt. Also, San Diego ist auch im ersten Jahr und die kommen also bis ins Halbfinale. Ist also auch eigentlich nicht normal. Aber haben wir auch neulich im Eishockey hingekriegt mit Las Vegas. Also, da gibt es glaube ich mehr Leute jetzt auch im Fußball hier, die analytisch rangehen an die Qualitäten der Spieler. Und ich habe das also in St. Louis, habe ich jemanden kennengelernt, der da auch in dem Club dafür zuständig war. Und ich glaube, dass die Qualität dieser Arbeit sehr gut ist innerhalb der Liga insgesamt. Die sogenannten Analytics, die Einschätzung, welche Qualitäten haben Spieler und wie können die dann auch zusammengebracht werden oder so. Ich glaube, das ist der auffälligste Bereich, in dem die Amerikaner im Fußball und in anderen Mannschaftssportarten aufgeholt haben oder sogar fehlerführend gewesen sind, weil das oft auch an Universitäten mit angeregt worden ist. Und nicht nur von Nerds, die jetzt irgendwie sich was anderes über Sport rausziehen wollen oder so. Also, ich gebe dir keine Antwort. Ich gebe dir eine ausweichende Hinweise auf, denkbar ist einiges. Sie haben den Erfolg nicht gekauft. Das ist schon mal klar.
Ja, aber das Interessante ist eben, der Erfolg hat jetzt auch, ich würde fast sagen, erstmals nicht mit einem Starspieler zu tun. Also, die haben eben diesen irren Zuschauerschnitt per se aus sich selbst heraus und hatten auch von Beginn an eine fantastische Stimmung im Stadion. Das war dann vielleicht auch ein sich selbst verstärkender Effekt, denn das wurde sehr früh berichtet. Ich weiß auch noch, dass das damals ein großes Thema war, als die eben die ersten Spieler hatte, was da eben für eine Stimmung war. Da wurde dann, also, da wurde auch in US-Medien manchmal so getan, als ob das besser sei als in Europa und in Südamerika. Ist ja egal, wie man das bewertet. Aber es war auf jeden Fall Thema. Und vielleicht hat das auch dazu geführt. Und ich finde es aber erwähnenswert, weil jetzt kommen wir ja dann zu Inter Miami und Lionel Messi. 2020 geht dann Inter Miami in den Spielbetrieb. 2023 steigt Apple in die Liga mit ein, mit 2,5 Milliarden US-Dollarn auf zehn Jahre hingerechnet. Also 250 Millionen pro Jahr können wir einfach grob rechnen. Und Lionel Messi kommt eben in die Liga. Und all das, was wir vorhin eingangs besprochen haben, das greift jetzt nämlich der Messi-Effekt, der zweistellige Anstieg bei Sponsoring erlösen, das Dynamic Pricing. Du kannst es quasi, du kannst an den Zuschauer schnitten, kannst verfolgen, wo Messi gerade spielt, ob er Heim- oder Auswärtsspiel hatte. Aber deswegen wollte ich eben Atlanta unbedingt vorher nochmal erwähnen, weil der aktuelle Erfolg der MLS eben nicht nur Lionel Messi ist, sondern wir hatten eben schon dieses Sonderphänomen Atlanta. Und wir haben auch dieses Sonderphänomen Vancouver, die ja auch eine Tradition haben. Du hast es auch vorhin angesprochen, die auch viele Zuschauer haben, die jetzt zwar zum ersten Mal auch das Stadion ausverkaufen konnten, aber ob das jetzt wirklich nur an Thomas Müller lag oder nicht vielleicht daher, dass man jetzt die Chance hatte, ins Finale einzuziehen, wer mag das schon voneinander trennen? Also jetzt mit dieser langen Herleitung, die wir jetzt gemacht haben, zu welchem Resumé würdest du denn dann kommen? Ist das jetzt sowas wie damals Pele und Beckenbauer mit Messi und Müller? Ist ein bisschen Gotteslästung, was ich gerade betreibe, aber verzeihts mir, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Oder fußt das dann doch auf einem stabileren Fundament?
Also der Teil, den du jetzt schon gut dargestellt hast, ist stabil. Also das sind jetzt keine heiß und fettig hochgejubelten Geschäftsideen. Die Idee selber und wenn die Investoren dahinter, und das sind jetzt also in Miami zum Beispiel riesen, erfolgreiche und reiche Bauunternehmer, die sich da reinholen lassen. Und Beckham hat ja inzwischen fast alles von dem, was ihm da gehörte, mal von ihm am Anfang verkauft. Also das ist ja auch nicht doof. Dann nimmt er halt das Geld mit und spielt da mehr so die Rolle des Frühstücksdirektors oder so. Aber ist natürlich auch als Person für jemanden wie den Spieler Messi, der auch in eine fremde Umgebung kommt und in eine fremde Sprache und so, ist das eine Ansprechperson. Ist der Mann, der Tom Brady dazu gebracht hat, in Birmingham zu investieren. Also dieser Ebene von Figuren, so berühmte Sportler, die nun auch mehr Geld haben und in mehr Sport investieren.
Eine tolle Welt, Gott sei Dank.
Das ist wie so eine Art Party-Truppe. Die kennen sich von irgendwas. Die sind also gemeinsam bei Adidas aufgetaucht. Wo auch immer. Die sich dann treffen bei Events oder so in Monaco, wenn es Preise gibt.
Ja, dann kaufen sie sich einfach einen Verein. Ist doch wirklich schön, dass es 50 plus 1 gibt.
Das sind nicht mehr Wanderarbeiter, die nun sagen, wo kann ich am meisten verdienen? Da gehe ich dann jetzt hin. Sondern auch dieses Klima von, wie wird mit Fußball umgegangen, innerhalb dieser Besitzer- und Management-Ebene. Auch im Grunde beachten und auch Tests haben. Was Messi raushandeln konnte über eine normale Gehaltsgeschichte, beteiligt zu sein direkt an den Apple-TV-Einnahmen. Was man in Hollywood irgendwie beteiligt am Brutto ist. Die Prozentzahlen, die du haben willst, wenn du da Schauspieler bist, dann möchtest du gerne am Brutto der Einnahmen beteiligt werden. Nicht am Netto, weil am Netto bleibt nichts übrig. Da gibt es halt sehr kreative Buchhalter in Hollywood, die das alles so weit runterrechnen. All das sind Indikatoren dafür, dass diese Leute, die gut vernetzt sind, die gut spielen, die Namen haben, die was mitbringen, Instagram Millionen, Follower und so weiter, dass die auch nicht sich einfach nur so, sagen wir mal so wie damals Gerd Müller da in Fort Lauderdale gelandet ist oder so. Ja, da verdiene ich auch mehr Geld und so. Ja, das war es dann.
Der dann noch ein Steakhouse nebenher betreibt, wo er in Brasilien ein bester Kunde war.
Ja, und wir sind woanders. Also, meine Indikatoren dafür, dass das stabil gebastelt ist, jetzt so wie es ist, ja, daran glaube ich. Woran ich nicht glaube, ist, dass ein amerikanischer Fußball davon profitiert. Dass also der junge Mensch in Amerika, der Fußball spielen möchte und der vielleicht auch Talent hat, dass der an dem Punkt kommt, dass er da eine Rolle spielt in diesem, in dieser Welt der MLS. Und dass er dann auch in der Nationalmannschaft mit dabei ist und die dann auch besser sind, als sie jetzt sind. Da gibt es keine Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass das schon in zwei, drei, vier Jahren überhaupt irgendwie denkbar ist. Es kann, es kann da hingeführt werden. Und jemand wie Pochettino nimmt das auch so wahr. Ja, er nimmt das an, diese Herausforderung.
Also der US-National-Trainer muss man dazu sagen.
Ja, Trump fragte Infantino bei einer dieser furchtbaren Weißen Haus Meetings, können wir denn auch mal Weltmeister werden oder so? Und er dachte vielleicht ja jetzt schon dieses Jahr oder so. Also Pochettino nimmt das an.
Hatte er da nicht einfach nur nach einem Preis gefragt? Und wenn wir, wir kennen Gianni Infantino, diesen Preis gibt es also.
Na gut, also nur ein kurzer Seitenhieb in eine andere Richtung. Ja, es ist denkbar, es gibt, es gibt Substanz mehr denn je. Und trotzdem ist, wenn die das nicht so hinkriegen, dass Ambition, sportliche Leistung, Ambition, Erfolg wirklich instrumental wird für das, was sie da machen. Sondern es weiterhin so eine, na ist doch egal, wer hier gewinnt, also wir steigen hier nicht ab, also wir verlieren auf jeden Fall nicht unser Geld oder so. Geht das nicht? Ich meine, selbst die Liegen, die heute anders funktionieren, als die früher mit ihren Vereinsstrukturen da im Top, wo ein Kanellers irgendwie rumfahren konnte und so, mit Kikas Offenbach, selbst diese Liegen haben immer noch, hier sagt man, die eye on the prize. Also dann ist es zwar jetzt vielleicht eher die Champions League, die das jetzt trägt und nicht mal unbedingt die nationale Meisterschaft, obwohl du musst dich ja auch in der Liga ja auch irgendwie qualifizieren und so, aber ohne diese Essenz von Sport, und das ist auch eine ura-amerikanische Essenz, hier sagt man, der zweite Platz ist der erste Verlierer. Eigentlich geht es darum, immer der Beste zu sein und oben zu stehen und so. Und wenn das nicht eingepflegt wird, sorry.
Ja, und gleichzeitig finde ich es dann doch interessant, weil ich glaube, dass halt die Geschichte des US-Fußballs, so wie wir sie jetzt erzählt haben, in, es klingt bizarr, aber trotzdem in aller Kürze, wie wir sie erzählt haben, sagt aber halt auch so viel darüber aus, wie sich Unterhaltungsindustrien verändert haben und wie sich Geldströme verändert haben. Wir sprechen jetzt eben davon, also in der Anfangszeit waren es Industrielle, die sich Fußballteams leisten wollten. Dann waren es schon erste reiche Menschen, meist aber noch Medienmenschen, die versucht haben, Synergieeffekte zu schaffen, indem sie sich etwas kaufen, dass sie in ihren Medien stattfinden lassen können. Und jetzt sind wir in einer Welt angekommen, in der Menschen einfach wahnsinnig viel Geld haben. Und dann ist es halt das 15. Sportteam, was sie sich noch kaufen. Dann retten sie auch eine Liga. Ja, dann dürfen die bei mir im Stadion spielen. Ist ja kein Problem. Im LL übrigens so ist auch Raber Leipzig entstanden. Da wusste auch jemand, der an diesem Stadion beteiligt war, nicht, wen man da drin spielen lassen sollte. Aber da könnt ihr euch nochmal selber einlesen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ich finde, das kann man gut nacherzählen an der Geschichte des US-Fußballs, ehrlicherweise auch bei den Frauen. Und das zeigt auch, dass diese Fragen, die wir haben, und ich glaube auch manchmal, es tut mir leid, ich weiß, dass du unzufrieden bist mit der Qualität des Unterbaus des Fußballs in den USA. Aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht, dass es wirklich eine Rolle spielt. Es geht nur um, wie viel Geld können wir durch diese Industrie in den Raum werfen und da macht sich jeder von uns davon die Taschen voll. Und wenn jemand ein Cashout will, dann verkauft er halt sein Team. Also Inter Miami wird von Forbes mit einem Wert von einer Milliarde US-Dollar bewertet. Das ist mehr als Inter Mailand zum Beispiel. Egal, was man jetzt auf diese Bewertung geben will, aber so komplett aus der Luft gegriffen ist sie auch nicht. Also da hat David Beckham auf jeden Fall einen guten Schnitt gemacht, als er sich da hat rauskaufen lassen. Aber ich finde das sinnbildlich für unsere Welt. Ich glaube, die MLS und auch die NWSL, die werden allein deshalb nicht scheitern, weil es inzwischen so viele Menschen mit unendlich viel Geld gibt, dass die sich das einfach leisten, weil es ja auch was ist, mit dem man im Rampenlicht steht. So wie früher eigentlich auch schon. Es gab schon immer Leute, die wegen des Prestiges des Vermeintlichen in den Fußballreihen sind. Und ich würde sagen, allein das wird die MLS immer am Leben erhalten, ohne dass sich das bewertet haben will.
Also ich würde gerne noch auf Folgendes aufmerksam machen, mehr im amerikanischen Kontext. Sportarten wie Baseball sind auf dem absteigenden Ast. Das ist ein kulturelles Phänomen. Heißt nicht, dass diese Baseball-Liga, die macht auch jetzt immer noch unglaublich viel Kohle, dass die jetzt gleich vor der Pleite steht oder so. Obwohl die mit den Verträgen, die die im Moment basteln, mit den Spielern, wo sie also 10-Jahres-Verträge machen und 500, 600 Millionen Dollar fest ausloben, die ja jemand bezahlen muss. Das ist eher ein sehr spekulatives Verhalten. Und zum Beispiel Galopp-Rennen war auch mal eine ganz riesige Sache. Ist auch jetzt nicht weg vom Fenster. Oder Boxen, Profi-Boxen war mal riesig. Und es ist alles abgerutscht. Und dann sind andere dafür aber hochgekommen, wie Profi-Basketball. Ice hockey ist im Moment auch immer noch auf einer guten Entwicklung. Und diese Phänomene, dass also sich Dinge da verändern, genauso wie der Stellenwert von anderen Bereichen der Entertainment-Industrie, sagen wir mal wie Hollywood-Film oder wie Rockmusik oder populäre Musik. Sport hat das ja irgendwann komplett getoppt. Das waren in den 50er-, 60er-, 70er-Jahren jeweils andere Abteilungen der Entertainment-Industrie. Also was ich sagen will, ist, es gibt da keine Nummer, auf die man wirklich setzen könnte auf dem Roulette-Tisch. Sagen, die gewinnt so, dass ich da heute Abend mit Gewinn abziehen kann. Also vielleicht, wenn ich einigermaßen gut Roulette spiele und mit Mathematik mich auskenne, kann ich über eine Mini-Marge pro Abend, kann ich mich ja auch irgendwie durchschlagen, so wie das auch gute Wetter im Pferdebereich oder sonst wo. Die können das analysieren. Wo sind die kleinen Vorteile, die ich jetzt habe, weil ich mich damit beschäftigt habe.
Das ist ein bisschen aber auch mein Punkt, weil ich glaube, darum geht es nicht mehr, weil sich die Struktur jenseits der einzelnen Sportarten verändert hat. Also ich glaube zum Beispiel nicht, und so kann man übrigens auch die aktuellen TV-Zahlen der MLS interpretieren, die ja nicht die besten sind, obwohl Messi seine beste Saison spielt, sondern nur die zweitbesten. Ich glaube nicht, dass nach Lionel Messi das Interesse genauso groß sein wird wie jetzt. Denn das ist ein Ausnahmefußballer und er spielt jetzt dort und er bringt ja auch noch sportliche Leistungen. Ist uns dann ehrlich gesagt egal, ob das jetzt irgendwie vergleichbar ist mit der zweiten Liga. Also sprich, dieser Effekt, der wird irgendwann weggehen. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das so kurzfristig ersetzt werden kann, denn Messi und auch Cristiano Ronaldo sind Einzelphänomene, in deren Fußstapfen es dann zwar Spieler wie Kieler in MWP oder Erling Haaland und so weiter gibt, die aber dennoch anders, glaube ich, wirken. Zumindest aktuell noch, würde ich da einen Unterschied machen.
Haaland hat null Ausstrahlung. Ich meine, der spielt einen tollen Mittelstürmer, aber ich meine, das geht schon mit den Haaren los. Und die Art und Weise, wie er sich körperlich bewegt, wenn er nicht hinter dem Ball hinterherläuft, das ist wie einer, der kommt aus vom Land. Das ist kein sophisticated Fußballspieler. Und das ist keine Figur, die man in Amerika brauchen könnte.
Ja, ja, okay. Ja, jetzt weiß ich, wie du kommst.
Ja, ja, okay. Ja, ja, okay. Ja, ja, okay. Ja, ja, okay. Ja, ja, okay. Das haben wir ja schon ausführlich hin und hin und weg gesprochen haben.
Genau. Und jetzt kommt aber, ich glaube, mein letzter Punkt, den ich machen will. Selbst wenn der Messi-Effekt verflöge, was ja relativ wahrscheinlich ist und wenn das Geld, das man in der MLS verdienen können würde, weniger werden würde. Ich glaube, jetzt jagt es Investorinnen nicht mehr davon, denn die Menschen, die jetzt im Fußball involviert sind und wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel, das habe ich vergessen zu erwähnen, aber wir haben ja auch Multiclub-Ownership-Systeme. Also irgendwann ist der Brausekonzern in die MLS reingekommen, irgendwann ist die City Football Group in die MLS reingekommen und so weiter und so fort. Ich glaube, dass der moderne Sport sich zunehmend so organisiert, dass die Menschen, die Sportvereine besitzen und damit Geld verdienen wollen, nicht mehr nur in einer Sportart oder in einer Liga aktiv sind, sondern die sind überall aktiv. Und wenn die MLS in 30 Jahren abgelöst wird von Wasserball oder von was auch immer, dann ist das für diese Leute überhaupt kein Drama, weil bis dahin haben die sich die interessantesten Wasserballteams gekauft. Und deswegen können die sich dann das MLS-Team auch noch leisten. Und dann dürfen die vielleicht in der Wasserballhalle auch mal trainieren. Dann haben wir wieder schöne Synergieeffekte. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach ein Unterschied zu der Situation in den 70ern, 80ern und 90ern.
Ja, und es gibt noch was, wobei ich jetzt mehr nicht ganz sicher bin, weil diese Liga ist noch nicht gegründet, aber sie ist im Gespräch ernsthaft. Es gibt einen Hang dieser Leute mit Geld, die sich am Sport irgendwie beteiligen wollen, jetzt globaler zu denken. Also es gibt ein sogenanntes Project B. Das ist eine Frauenbasketballliga als Konzept, die angelegt wird, als in der Saison, die die sind, fahren die rund um den Globus. Die spielen gar nicht mehr, also im Rahmen eines irgendwie national definierten oder kontinental definierten Wettbewerbskonzepts, wo wir ja herkommen historisch. Also Sheffield Leeds, Burnley, Derby, das ist alles irgendwie, kannst du zu Fuß machen oder so, ja, da kommt das irgendwie her. Ich sehe schon die nächste Stufe, Raketenstufe, dass man also diesen Raum verlässt und in einen anderen Bezugsraum hinein, so wie die Formel 1, das ja dann auch schon vorlebt, ja, dahin kommt. Und dann wird das immer noch um Geld gehen und immer noch all das, was wir heute besprochen haben, wird eine Rolle spielen. Aber das Gesicht des Ganzen wird anders sein. Und die Identifikationsgedanke, den man haben könnte, warum mag ich den Spieler, warum mag ich die Mannschaft oder so, wird sich auch nochmal in eine andere Farbe umwandeln lassen. Und das ist noch nicht Realität. Das ist vielleicht jetzt schon plausibel. Nächste Phase.
Sehen wir auch im Fußball. Ich meine, die Club WM kann genau als ein Versuch der Etablierung einer solchen Liga langfristig gesehen werden. Sehen wir aber auch in anderen Sportarten. Also für mich die Sport-Business-Meldung dieser Woche war, dass Borussia Dortmund jetzt überlegt, hast dich dann doch noch irgendwie die Basketballabteilung ernsthaft anzugehen, weil man dann Teil der NBA Europe werden wollen würde und die Bayern nämlich noch ein bisschen zögerlich sind. Und alles an Absurdem, was der moderne Sport zu bieten hat, steckt in diesen Sätzen, die ich gerade gesagt habe. Denn nichts davon ist für sich genommen falsch. Jürgen, hast du noch abschließende Gedanken? Ich für meinen Teil muss sagen, ich bin ausgeredet und ausgedacht, ich glaube jetzt den Fußball in den USA besser fassen zu können.
Ja, also das hoffe ich ja auch, dass das genau das Resultat ist, von dem, was wir heute versucht haben. Also ich will jetzt nicht noch den Korruptionsskandal andiskutieren, das haben wir ja auch schon gemacht, kannst du ja auch verlinken. Da gibt es so eine amerikanische Facette, wie ein korrekt funktionierendes Justizministerium mit Staatsanwälten ein Weltumspannungs- und Korruptionsfall attackiert und dann auch abhandelt und gleichzeitig auch die Erkenntnis, dass alles das, was im Bereich Fußball und Sport mit Geld zu tun hat, auch immer am Rand der Korruption ist oder über die Grenze getreten ist. Und das sind, was Korruptheit angeht und Korruption ist, in Amerika kein Musterland. Das wollte ich nur reinwerfen, nicht als weiteres Thema. Vielleicht gibt es ja nochmal auch vor und rund um die WM und rund um diese merkwürdige Männerfreundschaft.
Die wir gerade verpassen. Während wir gerade aufnehmen, Jürgen, wird der Preis, der extra für Donald Trump geschaffen wurde, ihm um den Hals gängig. Ja, aber so transparent können wir ruhig sein. Ursprünglich war der Plan, dass wir eben über die WM 26, die Männer WM sprechen und eben die vielen Dinge, die da dranhängen, inklusive eben Gianni Infantino, Donald Trump und so weiter und so fort. Und allein dieses Thema wurde größer und größer, je länger wir uns damit befasst haben. Und das wird aber noch kommen. In welcher Form und wann? Das schauen wir mal. Aber das ist jetzt quasi der Auftakt dazu. Wir haben uns jetzt dann eben dann auf die Geschichte des Fußballs in den USA konzentriert, weil das jetzt auch der bessere Zeitpunkt dafür zu sein schien. Jetzt vor diesem Finale zwischen den Whitecaps und Inter Miami. Aber das wird noch kommen. Und wenn du Lust hast, auch sehr gerne mit dir, Jürgen.
Oder auch mal mit einer größeren Runde. Vielleicht hast du ja noch ein paar, die du aus dem Ärmel ziehen kannst.
Ich schaue mal. Also, Jürgen, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Ich weiß auch, ich möchte auch nochmal betonen, das ist nicht selbstverständlich. Ich schreibe dir vor ein paar Wochen eine E-Mail mit, ich würde irgendwie gerne was dazu machen. Was denkst du dazu? Du antwortest immer sofort, auch wenn die eine Mail nicht angekommen ist, da kannst du ja nichts für. Du gibst immer sofort Input und dann lässt du dich aber Last-Minute von mir, du gibst mir schon ein fertiges Konzept und der Max denkt drüber nach und sagt, weißt du was, wir bohren das an 20 Stellen auf und machen es viel, viel größer und länger und du sagst einfach nur, okay, so machen wir das. Also ich kann wirklich nur betonen, wie toll das ist, so jemandem wie dich deinem Rasenfunk kamen zu dürfen, dass du dir diese Zeit nimmst. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass ich da drauf eingelassen hast. Alles Gute. Danke, wünsche ich dir auch. Und ich werde natürlich alle unsere Sendungen, liebe Hörer und Hörer, die werde ich verlinken. Also wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ach, schade, dass diese drei Stunden jetzt schon vorbei sind, es gibt noch zehn weitere zwischen Jürgen und mir, wo wir über die FIFA gesprochen haben, die FIFA-Prozesse, die in WSL und Atlanta United. Wird alles verlinkt in den Show Notes. Und dann danke ich auch euch, liebe Hörer und Hörerinnen, denn auch eine Sendung wie diese hier ist nur möglich dank eurer Unterstützung. Im Rasenfunk gibt es keine Werbung, im Rasenfunk gibt es keine Sponsoren und wir haben auch keine Paywall hochgezogen. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwilligen Beträge, die ihr uns überweist. Wie ihr uns die zukommen lassen könnt, geht per Paypal, Kreditkarte, Überweisungen. Das erfahrt ihr alles in der Videobeschreibung und in der Podcast-Beschreibung oder indem ihr einfach auf rasenfunk.de geht. Dort gibt es oben den Unterstützen-Button. Und wenn ihr auf den klickt, dann landet ihr direkt bei allen Informationen. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Enno, bei Kaya und ihrem Papa, bei Timo Benden, bei Fabian, bei Andi C und bei Marlo Telli. Sie alle haben sich auch als SupporterInnen registriert. Und so konnte ich ihnen hier nach dem Zufaß-Prinzip danken. In diesem Sinne, es wäre ganz toll, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk bewertet und wenn ihr uns weiter empfehlt. Wenn ihr diese Sendung vielleicht zum Anlass für eine Unterstützung nehmt, freuen wir uns auch sehr darüber. Auch die Gäste bekommen natürlich ein Honorar. Und da möchte ich euch danken für eure Aufmerksamkeit, wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de ist der perfekte Ort dafür. Und da wünsche ich euch eine gute Zeit. Kommt gut durch die Monate. Bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald. Ciao! Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser. Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr KNAUSA.